on Movamax quasi Bumm Zack Return Hier um die Ecke, ja quasi direkt neben der Metaebene wurde der Computer erfolgt.
Achso, das ist jetzt also ein shameless self plug oder wie das auch mal heißt.
Diese ganze Sendung ist ein shameless self plug.
Sind doch hier so eine Werbesendung, oder?
Wir sind eine Werbesendung, die geht es nur um Geld.
In der 60. Folge kommt es endlich mal raus.
Ich verkaufe dir was, die Langneuen Partner, ihr Partner in allen Fragen, wenn es um die Säcke geht.
In jedem 7.Ei ist ein Palme Pré dabei.
Ich verweile dich da deine Sendung von Beton Zoo.
Das kann man sogar noch kaufen.
Hast du eigentlich schon deine Eneloop Batterien in den BC-2700 gesteckt? Du warmmarte Trinkrauch.
Mein MacBook Air. Das Tolle. Das kann man sogar noch kaufen. Was auch wirklich extrem rotartig ist und was man gar nicht genug betonen kann ist, wie leicht dieses Teil ist. Das kann man sogar noch kaufen. Und wo sind die Millionen?
Herzlich willkommen bei Bumm Zack Return.
Ja, ja, ja, wir sind's wieder mal die schlimmen Jungs, die schlimmen Jungs aus der Meterebene kriechen wieder in euer Ohr. Hier ist Mobile Max Ausgabe Nummer 61. Heute mal in etwas eingeschränkter Besetzung. Max ist nicht dabei, der hat sich krank gemeldet.
Erschöpft gemeldet vom Umziehen.
Ja, ja, das stresst.
Der hat so viel, heute die Kleidung wechseln müssen. Das ist ja gar nicht mehr.
Ja, Max, aber wir reißen das heute hier für dich mit. Und wir begrüßen alle unsere Hörer da draußen an den Hörgeräten. Haben wir denn irgendwelche Themen?
Boah, ich hab mir das mit einem neuen iPhone abruntergelassen.
Also von Nokia gab es jetzt irgendwie nichts, da haben wir ja gar nichts zu erzählen.
Ja, ist komisch, ich weiß auch nicht. Die müssen irgendwie mehr bringen, damit wir da auch entsprechende Themen haben. Was sollen wir denn sonst machen?
Naja, also ich hab ja irgendwie vorhin, hab ich ja gelesen, dass Heise, also die, die den Mac und die Macintosh-Plattformen gefühlte zwei Dekaden komplett ignoriert haben, was ja nicht ganz stimmt, aber so gefühlt als Mac-User, die haben jetzt ja selber einen Korrespondenten zu diesem Event, der da gerade war, hingeschickt.
Entschuldigung, ja, ich war gerade abgelegen.
Der Heise.
Ah, Heise, echt wirklich, die machen das jetzt auch.
Die sind jetzt so drin, ja? Die haben wahrscheinlich auch einmal auf dem Schreibtisch geguckt und gesagt, Jungs, merkt ihr noch was? Wir müssen da auch hin. Ja, dann haben sie auch gleich noch den Steve-Life abbekommen, wenn das stimmt.
Ich finde, das entwickelt sich ganz gut bei Heise.
Ja, ja, es wird.
Also der Buyout der Blogger-Szene hat wohl funktioniert soweit.
Sie stellen ja neu ein sogar. Wir haben ja heute schon.
Wir sind heilig, ne?
Ich hatte von denen auch schon Post.
Habt ihr dieses neue, habt ihr dieses Heft schon bestellt, was da jetzt in den Handel kommt? Ich wollte das irgendwie online. Gedruckte Ware? Tote Bäume. Also das erste Sonderheft, was sie gemacht haben vor einem Jahr oder so, was wohl ganz gut lief.
Ja, hatten wir ja berichtet hier.
Ja, das war auch okay. Also das war wirklich gut. Es war sehr auf so Switcher auch eingestellt, klar. Nachvollziehbar. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt bei dem aktuellen immer noch so ist oder ob sie jetzt davon ausgehen, dass schon alle geswitcht haben. Ja, also ich hab versucht, das Ding online zu bestellen und das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert und ich weiß jetzt gerade aber nicht mehr so genau, warum eigentlich. Irgendwie musste man sich da, glaube ich, einen Account klicken und das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her und da dachte ich mir Scheiß drauf. Und ich werde es noch mal probieren oder mir das Ding dann vielleicht tatsächlich an so einem Tote Baum Laden kaufen.
Tote Baum Dealer.
Haben sie tote Bäume?
Ja, gerade frisch was rein bekommen.
Unter dem Ladentisch kriegt man das dann so durchgeschoben. Ach Macintosh. Und dann guckt ihr so nach links und nach rechts und so, schaut auch keiner.
Früher gab es nicht mal eine Mac-Zeitschrift an der Tankstelle. Da musste man schon in ausgewählte Zeitschriften gehen, um überhaupt so was wie eine Mac-Welt zu kriegen. Und jetzt interessiert es mich aber auch gar nicht mehr, was die da so schreiben. Aber es gibt bestimmt jede Menge Leute, die das noch sehr interessant finden. Na ja, wir können ja auch noch ein bisschen weiter darüber reden, weil sonst ist ja nicht viel passiert eigentlich. Na ja, gab es eigentlich am Anfang was außer der Mac-Welt? Nee, oder?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Mac-Welt.
Ja, danach.
War das danach? War Mac-Welt die erste deutsche Publikation?
Also ich mir 95 oder so bei einem guten Papst-Computer-System noch gab. Als ich mir den gekauft hab, da gab es Mac-Welt in meinem Schrank. Da hab ich auch noch ganz viele von damals kürzlich erst weggeschmissen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Na ja, die Wikipedia weiß das im Zweifel bestimmt.
Aber ich weiß, was meine erste Internet-Macintosh-News-Quelle war, wo ich so auf die Art, wie man das heute ganz normal tut, mir sozusagen meine Insider-News geholt habe. Macintosh, die gibt es auch immer noch. Ja, besser noch. Also Macintosh war am Anfang...
Macintosh.
Macintosh, das kennt ihr.
Na klar, da hab ich ja... Ich hab doch mal macseite.net gehabt.
Das war im Prinzip ein Klon davon, ne?
Mehr oder weniger, nur ein Gelb.
Damals hab ich ja auch mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ob ich nicht auch mal so einen Mac-Blog aufmache.
Eigentlich war das ganz cool.
Also Blog hieß das ja damals noch nicht, aber so eine Seite.
Einfach jeden Tag 5, 6, 7 News geschrieben, mal so kurze 1, 2 Zeile mit einem Link zum Originalartikel. Und das ging schon ganz gut ab eigentlich.
Aber Macintosh war wirklich the resource.
Aber die haben irgendwann umgestellt. Jetzt ist es ja sehr stark so forums-based, also dass die User selber schreiben und...
Das war aber auch schon immer so, dass die da extrem viel Feedback... Also zumindest haben sie eine Menge Feedback eingesetzt. Und die hatten dann immer so diese Topic-Seiten. Und eigentlich ist das auch eine wunderbare Ressource, wenn man das ganz genau wissen will. Und nicht jetzt immer nur an diese Rumor-Geschichte. Das kam ja dann später erst so. Mac OS Rumors? Mac OS Rumors.
Das kam alles später.
Damit ging dann irgendwie dieser Powerpage, O'Grady's Powerpage, die seinerzeit mal die neuen Powerbooks geleakt haben, was ja so der Affront war, nachdem Apple, also danach hat Apple dann diese Secrecy eingeführt.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr so.
Naja, das war so. Die schwarzen Powerbooks, die Pismos, die hatten sie nämlich da irgendwie drin. Und das hat dem Olin Steve überhaupt nicht gefallen. Da fing es dann wahrscheinlich an mit der Krankheitsung. Oh Grady, du hast Steve getötet!
Was dann erst Zink Geek erst dann angerichtet hat.
Zink Geek und Apple Insider, was ich heute immer noch für eine hervorragende Quelle halte. Die schreiben auf jeden Fall viel und ausführlich. Ja, all das.
Und jetzt gibt es ja eine neue Seite, die hab ich dir auch getwittert. Oder was heißt neu? Aber die hab ich erst kürzlich gefunden, dieses Mac-Stories.
Ja, stimmt.
Die kommt eigentlich auch ganz gut her. Die haben auch irgendwie echt...
Seit wann gibt's die denn eigentlich?
Ja, die ist relativ frisch. Die sieht auch vom Design relativ frisch aus. Wohingegen Mac-Rumors und Apple Insider immer noch so ein bisschen den Anschluss noch nicht ganz geschafft haben. Sind die so ästhetisch auch ganz vorne mit dabei. Die Mac-Welt gibt es übrigens in Deutschland seit 1989. Also...
1989?
Okay, die Mac-Up wurde 1984 gegründet.
Ja, die Mac-Up gibt es länger.
Krass, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Oh wei, ich habe überhaupt keine Mate. Ich wusste die ganze Zeit, irgendwas fehlt.
Kannst du mir auch gleich noch eine mitbringen, please? So, kurze Werbeeinblendung.
Was erzählen wir heute?
Es ist ja fast nichts passiert die letzte Woche.
Jetzt kommen wir, jetzt lasst uns hier über diese komische Scheiß-iPad reden. Das war ja wieder mal so der unspektakulärste Event ever. Sowieso diese ganzen Secrecy, Whistleblower und Geheimnisverräter, die nehmen auch wirklich aus der dröge, also aus der unspannsten Keynote noch das letzte Fünftchen Spannung raus.
Ja, das ist schlimm, oder?
Also man weiß, okay, Einladung, irgendwie geht es ums iPad, okay, und dann weiß eigentlich schon alles vorher.
Wir sollten eigentlich so den Mobamex Black Badge of Shame verteilen für all diese ganzen Geheimnisverräter, die vorher irgendwie schon so die Luft rausnehmen.
In Hollywood gibt es doch hier diesen für die schlechtesten Schauspieler, was war alleine die Himbe, oder was? Die könnten ja den Blackberry verteilen.
Der Blackberry of Shame. Genau, das ist eine gute Idee. Genau, und dann machen wir noch einen Sonderpreis, den Mobamex Award of Distinction, für die Seite, die so einen Gerücht gestreut hat, was alle geglaubt haben und was total falsch war. So wie jetzt mit den neuen MacBooks und diesem 16 GB SSD, die drei Sitzungen.
Ja, wie wir auf so einen Schwachsinn kommen. Da könnte ich gleich voll einsteigen.
Noch mal. Nein, wir wollen über iPad reden. Ja, das ist jetzt ganz frisch. Wir haben zu diesem Zeitpunkt gerade diese sogenannte Keynote, die ja nur im Text ablief, weil da Leute freundlicherweise geblockt haben. Ich weiß nicht, was sie davon abhält, das live zu streamen. Sie haben es hier letztens zweimal gemacht.
Ja, weil könnt ja sein, dass Steve irgendwie auf der Bühne umkippt und... Wobei wir eh mit Verzögerungen streamen. Haben sie im letzten Mal auch so mit einer leichten Verzögerung gestreamt. Die haben jetzt die Technik so wie in Hollywood da im Start.
Nippelgate.
Zum Beispiel. Ja, aber hier beim Oscar hat ja auch eine irgendwie fucking irgendwas gesagt. Und das wurde auch, weil es ja mit 5 Sekunden verzögert gesendet wird, war nicht mehr zu hören später, wie auch immer die das so schnell schaffen. Also verstehe ich ja auch nicht so ganz, wie die das machen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt eben präsentiert, was wir alle schon wussten, ein neues iPad.
Wir wussten gar nichts.
Natürlich.
Netter Thema, lass mal auflisten.
Na, wir wussten ja schon mal, dass keine doppelte Auflösung kommt. Hat der Gruber gesagt.
Sagt es wahr.
Ja komm, also ehrlich, ist jetzt schon mal so ein bisschen so. Na und dann jetzt hier die Tage davor kam ja schon alles irgendwie dünner. Die ganzen Cases kamen schon. Unterschiedliche Farben, ja.
Und ich meine sogar auch irgendwas, irgendwie gab es irgendwo mal so einen, gab es nicht auf dieser CES irgendeinen bekloppten Prototypen, der irgendwo rum lag und vorhin so, als ich das gesehen habe, schien mir das sogar fast ähnlich zu sein.
Na vor allen Dingen, ich mein, okay, also es wird keine größere Auflösung geben. Man hat das Case gesehen, was jetzt dünner aussah und dann mussten sie ja noch irgendwas bringen, aber es war etwas wie schneller halt. Und jetzt ist es halt noch schneller geworden. Und Kameras, zwei Kameras. Ich hatte bei unserer Umfrage intern, bei der teaminteren Umfrage, habe ich auf zwei Kameras getippt und...
Ja, da lag ich total falsch. Also ich dachte, sie lassen die zweite Kamera weg. Und jetzt gibt es wohl doch eine, ne? So, ich gehe hier gerade mal dieses Log durch, weil das ist glaube ich die beste Methode, jetzt nichts Wichtiges zu vergessen. Also erstmal haben sie angefangen, rumzubraggen, wie viele Books sie doch verkauft hätten. Und so, das finde ich ja ganz interessant. Und ich denke, mit dem neuen Gerät dürfte das mit dem iBooks auch nochmal einen Zacken attraktiver werden.
Warum?
Weil es leichter ist, ganz einfach. Also es wird sich noch einfacher halten lassen. Und das ist definitiv bei dem iPad derzeit noch so ein Punkt, das schon eben wiegt. Weil es wiegt immer noch, so ist es nicht.
Aber 100 Gramm weniger ist schon ordentlich.
Das wird man wahrscheinlich merken. Am Ende wünscht man sich aber wahrscheinlich noch mal 500 Gramm weniger.
Na das geht ja nicht.
Aber das finde ich schon erstaunlich. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht... Es ist nach wie vor Alu, oder? Ja, ich habe dieses Video kurz vorbeilaufen lassen.
Sieht ja so ein bisschen mehr iPhone 4 mäßig aus, ne?
Findest du, ne? Das ist ja nicht so ein Dings drumherum. Also das ist etwas, was mich jetzt nicht so überrascht hätte, wenn das iPad in so einem iPhone 4 Look daher gekommen wäre, mit so einem Stahlband drumherum. Auch wenn es nicht jetzt so...
Aber es ist ja jetzt sogar noch dünner als das iPhone.
Dünner als das iPhone?
Ja, angeblich. Na, das 17 Zoll Notebook, das 17 Zoll MacBook Pro ist ja auch dünner als das 15 Zoll, ne? Also wenn man mehr Fläche hat, dann kann man das auch noch ein bisschen mehr verteilen. Ja, hat er doch gesagt, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, hat er gesagt, dünner als das iPhone 4. Das ist schon gut. Und schwarz und weiß, aber das bezieht sich natürlich nur auf diese Vorderseite. Gut, maletwegen. Ich würde mir trotzdem nur einen schwarz kaufen, aber es gibt wohl Leute, die stehen irgendwie auf weiß. Das ist wahrscheinlich für die Ärzte. So in der Klinik. Wenn wir nicht so ein schwarzes Gerät haben, das wirkt ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen morbide. Also ein weißes Gesundheits-iPad.
Eigentlich könnten sie dann auch... Können sie sich eh nochmal ein Aufkleber oben drauf machen?
Das ist ein schöner Placebo-Effekt. Ich denke, wenn die Leute so von einem weißen iPad ihre Gesundheitsdaten runtergebetet bekommen, dann fühlen sie sich auch gleich viel besser. Ja, dann haben sie ein bisschen auf Android rumgehackt. Ja, zu Recht. Ich meine, ich sehe das ja nicht so richtig, dass auf Android so viel passieren wird dieses Jahr. Da gibt es ja eine große Erwartung. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, die Developer, die werden einfach in Scharen nicht davonlaufen, weil sie sind ja noch gar nicht da, aber sie werden halt auch nicht in Scharen hinrennen. Natürlich so viele aller wichtigsten Sachen, Twitter hier, Facebook da, da wird es natürlich auch weiterhin entsprechende Versionen auch geben für diese Geräte. Aber ich denke, das ist nicht das, was den Wert des iPads heutzutage im Wesentlichen ausmacht, sondern was den Wert ausmacht sind vor allem diese ganzen vertikalen Applikationen. Ich glaube, sie hatten hier auch so eine Demo mit Leuten, die mit autistischen Kindern mit dem iPad arbeiten. Da gab es ja schon vor einigen Wochen mal so einen Bericht. Ich weiß nicht, ob der euch auch aufgefallen ist. So ein Erfahrungsbericht von einer Mutter, die einen autistischen Sohn hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt die Story war, die sie hier gebracht haben. Das ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Ich habe mit einer Doktorin gesprochen, aber es war so eine Mutter, die halt meinte, autistische Kinder sind halt schwierig. Aber dann hat sie mir irgendwie ein iPad gekauft und das war irgendwie genau das Ding. Da war dann einfach Fortschritt zu sehen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz zusammen, woran sie diesen Fortschritt festgemacht hat. Aber die Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Gerät war einfach intensiv und man hat einfach gemerkt, dass das eben etwas ist für so Vollnerds. Also so richtige Autisten sind ja eigentlich Vollnerds. Es gibt da auch solche und solche Autisten, ganz klar, und ich kenne mich da auch nicht wirklich gut aus. Aber das hatte ich schon mal gehört, das war für mich jetzt keine News. Auch keine News war die Information, dass da jetzt ein A5-Chip drin ist. Ich glaube, das hatte ich auch schon mal mit dem Namen vorhergesagt. Also Dual Core, wir können wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass es halt so eine Cortex A9-Basis ist.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach ein A4 und verdoppelt, oder? Plus bessere Grafik.
Ich denke, das Basis-Design von dem A4, das Prozessordesign, ist ja dieser Cortex A8. Single-Core-Arm-Design. Man lizenziert das Design und dann macht man eben seinen eigenen Silikon da draus. Und der A9, der war ja schon letztes Jahr, hat er sich ja schon abgezeichnet, bzw. veröffentlicht, war schon fertig. Aber muss halt auch erst mal umgesetzt werden, weil nur wenn die das so vorstellen, gibt es noch lange kein greifbares Teil. Und das ist jetzt hier noch nirgendswo erwähnt worden. Das wird sich sicherlich noch klären, aber ich vermute mal schwer, dass es eben das ist, weil alle anderen machen das ja auch. Also alles, was Dual-Core-Arm ist, ist halt dieses Cortex A9. Wo ich halt wirklich überrascht war, waren ihre Claims bezüglich der Grafik. Also neunfache Geschwindigkeit. Ich meine, da fragt sich natürlich, an welcher Stelle sich dieses neunfache zeigt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich bei 3D-Spielen.
Du meinst, das ist nicht alles neunfache, sondern nur bestimmte Sachen. Und da würdest du gerne wissen, welches.
Jaja, genau. Also das ist definitiv... Also ich meine, Apto 9 heißt nicht, dass alles neunmal so schnell ist, sondern das heißt, dass bestimmte Dinge... Ich meine, die werden einfach erheblich viel mehr Speicher haben intern. Was sie auch nicht gesagt haben und was ich denke, was auch so ein Schlüssel für diese Geschwindigkeitssteigerung ist, ist, dass das Ding OpenCL fähig sein wird. Und dass sie einfach eine ganze Menge der Algorithmen in iOS, die derzeit, die wir bisher noch auf der CPU haben, arbeiten müssen, dass sie das eben via OpenCL in diesen Core, in diesem GPU-Core auslagern konnten. Meine ich. Aber ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, wie heißt denn diese neue CPU überhaupt? Wie heißt denn überhaupt noch mal dieser CPU-Hersteller, verdammt? Wenn man sich nicht alles aufschreibt. Naja, Apple, das ist ja auch wieder so eine britische Bude. Also es ist ja interessant, dass jetzt sozusagen der Prozessormarkt wird jetzt von Britannien aufgemischt.
Aber da hat sich Apple doch gekauft, diesen Laden oder so.
Genau, da sind sie beteiligt. Das machen sie ja immer dann.
Beteiligt oder gekauft?
Beteiligt. Sie haben da 10% oder 20% Firmen beteiligt.
Aber die haben doch vor zwei Jahren, das war diese eine Bude, komplett gekauft, die sie übernommen haben.
Das waren die, die Arm Design machen.
Also die auch diesen Power PC so optimiert haben.
Genau.
Und danach haben sie nochmal in eine Bude investiert. Das meinste.
Irgendwas mit I oder S oder beides.
P A Semi haben sie gekauft.
Genau.
Genau. Und das ist vermutlich die Basis des Teams, was eben diese A4 und A5 Design macht. Und diese Cortex A8 und Cortex A9 Basis ist halt das Lizenzmodell von ARM. Und dazu kommt dann halt noch diese, ja wie heißt denn diese verdammt, diese GPU Bude, auch britische Bude. Ich komm jetzt nicht drauf. Wie auch immer. Und da haben sie sich halt beteiligt. Und so eine Beteiligung macht Apple eigentlich immer dann, wenn das für sie eben wirklich strategisch wichtig ist, dass sie sozusagen die Zukunft dieses Unternehmens mit beeinflussen können. Da wollen sie einfach irgendwie im Board sitzen, beziehungsweise so viele Anteile haben, dass sie da so ohne Weiteres keine Entscheidung an ihnen vorbeimarschiert. Außerdem keine Ahnung, was sie da sonst noch alles so tun. Ich vermute mal, dass sie mit denen sehr eng zusammenarbeiten. Und ja, das ist das, was ich denke, was hier zu der Geschwindigkeitssteigerung beitragen wird. Aber das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen gemutmaßt. Imagination Technologies. Ja, was haben wir noch? Ist verdammt viel kleiner. Ist aber echt dünn. Ist ja sozusagen wie so der untere Teil von dem bisherigen iPad, ohne dieses komplette fette Teil da oben drüber. Das ist schon echt irre. Ich bin echt gespannt. Das krollt hier so langsam, ich weiß nicht warum.
Hat eigentlich die bisherigen Apple-Mobilgeräte eigentlich schon A-Wi-Fi?
Schon A, aber nicht im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich.
Das iPhone kann kein 5 Gigahertz. Das iPad konnte 5 Gigahertz. Von daher gehe ich eigentlich davon aus, dass sie auch A konnten, aber wissen tue ich es gerade nicht.
Na ja, bei dem steht jetzt hier A, B, G, N.
Ich glaube, das war auch schon vorher so. Da haben wir jetzt nichts dazu gesagt, ob sie nur ein 3G-Modell haben, oder ob sie zwei verschiedene haben.
Wie zwei verschiedene?
Na, es hieß wohl, also zumindest steht das jetzt hier in diesem Lastblog, was ich lese, There are Models that work with AT&T and Verizon. Das könnte heißen, es gibt eins für AT&T und es gibt eins für Verizon, es gibt eine CDMA.
Könnte aber auch sein, dass sie meinen, es gibt Models, die können das gar nicht. Und es gibt einen Model, das kann halt mobil.
Aber es kann sein, dass es sich technisch um dasselbe Gerät handelt. Nur das eine ist quasi nur mit einer UMTS-Firmware und das andere ist nur mit einer CDMA-Firmware und das eine hat halt einen SIM-Karten-Slot und das andere hat keinen SIM-Karten.
Auf der Tech-Spec-Seite steht Wi-Fi plus 3G-Model und dann gibt es noch einen Wi-Fi plus 3G vor Verizon CDMA EVDO Revision A.
Okay, das spricht für zwei Geräte.
Also auf lange Sicht kann man mal sehen, die wollen da eindeutig von weg. Das willst du einfach nicht. Du willst immer möglichst wenig Geräte haben.
Ja gut, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen gehen sie derzeit diesen Weg. Vielleicht sind sie sich da noch nicht so sicher genug. Oder es gibt irgendwelche anderen Gründe. Also es gibt sicherlich irgendwelche anderen Gründe. Wann kommt es denn eigentlich? Es kommt am 25. März nach Deutschland. Das ist in vier Wochen. Drei. Vier. Drei. Das ist gut. Da wird wieder gekauft.
Dann gibt es noch ein Gyro und HDMI.
Das finde ich ja interessant. Aber kein Thunderbolt. Kein Thunderbolt, nein.
Thunderbolt und Lightning, very, very striking. Das hätte mich jetzt auch ein bisschen überrascht.
Es ist wohl auch kein PCI Express in iOS drin. Und PCI Express ist schon so ein bisschen die Voraussetzung für Thunderbolt, weil sonst kannst du damit irgendwie nichts machen. Über Thunderbolt werden wir noch reden. Aber ich frage mich, ob das nicht vielleicht bedeutet, dass sie ein neues Layout haben für ihren Dock-Connector. Wieder einmal. Ja, das haben sie ja schon ein paar Mal geändert. Ja, so über die Jahre.
Was denn?
Na, so dass VGA mit drauf lag und so. Also es gab schon Änderungen im Pinout. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie immer nur Unuse-Pins in Betrieb genommen haben oder ob sie auch nochmal was geändert haben. Ich hab sowas in Erinnerung mit einer Änderung, aber das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau. Aber wenn sie jetzt HDMI machen, ist halt auch die Frage, was machen sie da eigentlich wirklich? Weil, haben sie da jetzt einen Stein drin, der tatsächlich VGA und HDMI kann? Oder haben sie DisplayPort drin, was halt auch HDMI kann? Aber dann hätten sie ja auch durchaus hier mit DisplayPort werben können.
Können sie dann doch VGA ohne Adapter?
Ja, ich geh irgendwas von VGA...
Obwohl ohne Adapter können sie sowieso gar nichts.
Nein, ohne Adapter geht gar nichts. Sie werden auch nach wie vor VGA machen.
Ja, aber muss ich jetzt?
Also entweder Apple Digital AV Adapter oder Apple VGA Adapter. Cable sold separately für nur 39,95.
Also kein Display-Port. Tja, warum auch immer. Also das weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, vielleicht sehen sie es nicht als so wichtig an, jetzt so ein iPad an so ein Display-Port-Device anzuschließen. Da haben sie sicherlich auch recht. Also dass es nicht so wichtig ist, weil das ist nicht unbedingt das, was du tun wollen würdest. Ich hatte bloß auch damit gerechnet, dass in dem Moment, wo sie HDMI haben, dass sie das ohnehin auf Basis von Display-Port lösen und dass sie dann eben das auch können könnten. Und vielleicht können sie es ja auch, aber sie sagen, dass es, ja, es hielten es nicht für nötig, das Feature jetzt als solches auszuweisen und mittels eines entsprechenden Adapters rauszuführen, weil es dafür einfach keinen Markt gibt. Ja, aber dieses Cover, alter Falter. Also das ist ja wohl echt mal wieder ein, wie sagt man so schön, ein Bolt Move.
Findest du den Bolt?
Aber es schützt auch nur die Vorderseite.
Ja, naja gut, die Hinterseite ist Alu. Ich frage mich, wie sich das Ding verhält, wenn du es so in so eine Tasche reinsteckst. Weil das derzeitige Cover, zumindest das von Apple und natürlich auch die anderen, die umschließen dieses Gerät halt extrem solide und liegt nicht so drauf. Und wenn du das jetzt mit Wumms in so eine Tasche reinschiebst, wo jetzt noch andere Sachen drin sind, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob diese paar Magnete das dann auch so in dem Maße halten. Es ist halt nicht wirklich zu. Es gibt auch keinen Verschluss. Und es ist ja auch nur auf der einen Seite magnetisch und auf der anderen Seite liegt es einfach auf. Aber was krass ist, dass natürlich in diesem fallbaren Teil ja erstmal Magnete drin sind, dass sie dafür noch Sensoren haben, dass sie wissen, wenn das Ding zugeklappt ist, dass es dann ins Sleep-Modus geht. Und super genial finde ich das mit diesem Hinstellending. Weil das war natürlich, erinnert ihr euch, ich habe neulich mal unsere Sendung nochmal gehört, kurz vor dem iPad, also vor dem Jahr, wo wir so darüber gemutmaßt haben, wenn denn so was rauskäme, was es denn können müsste. Wir lagen übrigens ziemlich gut. Und ein Thema war halt diese Frage mit Hinstellen. Also wie stellt man das so hin? Und ich muss auch sagen, das ist eben bei dem aktuellen iPad auch ein Problem.
Na du hast doch hier diese Hölle, wo man das so...
Ja, damit kannst du es quer hinstellen, aber wenn du es zum Beispiel senkrecht hinstellen willst, und hochstellen willst und so weiter, also das ist...
Aber hochkant geht jetzt mit dem auch nicht.
Doch.
Nee, wie?
Das geht, das ist in dem Video ganz gut zu sehen. Du kannst es halt, wenn es so zu so einem Dreieck zusammengedingst ist...
Die schummeln hier. Die zeigen das, tun so, als wenn es... Also ich glaube, die haben ja an den Perspektiven so ein bisschen geschummelt, weil dieses neue Case wird an der Längsseite festgemacht und nicht an der Querseite.
Ja, so sehe ich das hier eigentlich auch.
Aber manche Bilder sind so ein bisschen irreführend, als wenn sie einem deuten wollen...
Ah ja, richtig. Na klar. Du hast recht. Ja, siehst du mal, da ist das Problem schon wieder da. Aber wenn man es halt mit diesem Teil macht, deckt wiederum dieses Cover eine Menge ab. Und dann hat man den Vorteil, in Anführungsstrichen, dass das iPad coverfrei ist. Was ja auch extrem lästig ist mit dem aktuellen Teil, dass wenn du so einen Cover drum herum hast, dann passen halt diese ganzen Docs nicht mehr. Du kannst das dann nicht mehr docken. Also eigentlich ist es total blöd. Wir haben hier in dieser Keynote auch sowas gesagt, wie jetzt haben wir so ein hübsches Teil gemacht und dann stecken wir es in so einen Cover und man sieht nichts mehr davon. Da ist was dran, das ist halt irgendwie verschwunden und man kann es nicht in dieses Dock reinstecken, wo die Tastatur dran ist.
Das haben sie mit dem iPhone 4 aber auch schon gemacht. Haben sie so ein schickes Telefon gemacht und dann machen sie ja so einen Bumper und man sieht nichts mehr.
Darum habe ich mir den transparenten Bumper geholt.
Ich habe den Bumper jetzt nicht mehr dran, weil der Bumper mir das Teil zerkratzt hat.
Ja, weil du zu viel auf dem Spielplatz bist.
Meins ist noch voll.
Immer mit den Kinnings. Mit den Kinnings irgendwie im Buddelkasten.
Ich muss ja irgendwo die Millionen, die ich mit diesem Podcast verdiene, auch irgendwie wieder verbraten, nicht wahr? An der Coca-Cabana.
Wo ist das eigentlich? Coca-Cabana? Da wird auch Coca konsumiert. Coca-Cabana. Ich war noch niemals in Brasilien. Demnächst werden wir auch mit einer kleinen Gesangseinlage hier als Intro ein. Das war gerade Spliff oder so. Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Carbonara meinst du.
So viel Spektakuläres ist es auf jeden Fall nicht. Ich hab ja die ganze Zeit gewartet auf das doppelt aufgelöste Display. Dann hätt ich ja gesagt, will ich unbedingt haben, aber jetzt warte ich noch ein Jahr.
Ich will das Ding auf jeden Fall haben. Allein den neuen Speed, den will ich sehen. Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt, inwieweit die Applikationen brauchen, bis sie von dem zweiten Core auch wirklich Nutzen ziehen. Weil das ist natürlich jetzt das alles entscheidende.
Kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen? Instantly natürlich.
Wieso?
Na, weil das OS alles auf den zwei Cores auslagert. Du brauchst das Programm noch nichts machen.
Grand Central Dispatch.
Na gut, aber das musst du trotzdem noch in deine Applikation einbauen.
Ja, die ganzen Chippo-Applikationen brauchen es doch eh erstmal nicht und die ganzen Rennerspiele da und so, da wird schon was kommen.
Du vertraust einfach, dass alles gut wird, sozusagen.
Ich war eigentlich schon immer der Meinung, du bist ja am Programmieren. Du hast irgendwie so eine Loop, die musst du keine Ahnung, von mir aus 10.000 Mal durchführen. Also kommt dir selten vor, dass man so große Loops hat eigentlich. Aber eigentlich könnte doch denn das OS im Hintergrund den Job von alleine auf zwei Cores aufteilen, aber ich glaube bisher macht es das noch nicht und da könnte sich ja auch vielleicht sogar mit Leiden was tun, wer weiß. Dass man gar nicht so von selber irgendwie das optimieren muss für zwei Cores. Ich glaube beim GCC gab es auch schon irgendwelche Erweiterungen für Multicore, hat sich aber nie so richtig durchgesetzt.
Ja, aber am Ende des Tages musst du halt das selber machen. Musst du es einfach selber machen, da musst du einfach wissen, was, was da ist. Was gab es noch Spannendes? Achso, ja, richtig. iMovie und GarageBand. Aber da war noch irgendwas mit Airplay, dass du von deinem iPhone aus auf iTunes auf deinem Computer zugreifst und das dann automatisch streamst. Also dass du nicht deinem Apple TV sagen musst, dass es sich von deinem iTunes holt, sondern dass du das von deinem iPhone quasi von iTunes holst und dann deinem iTunes sagst, dass es das dahin streamen soll. Oder du streamst es von dem iTunes auf deinem iPhone und mit Airplay dann auch gleich wieder auf den Screen.
I'm lost und du?
Also very lost. Aber irgendwie sowas ähnliches war es. Das habe ich aber nicht so genau. Das habe ich hier nur so zwischen den Zeilen gelesen. Dann kommt iOS 4.3. Aber haben sie gesagt wann?
Hälfte.
So lange müssen wir noch warten, bis wir endlich mal.
Das ist nächste Woche, Mann. Ja, und heute ist schon Mittwoch.
Also Personal Hotspot kommt dann.
Auch ja, nur für iPhone 4.
Bitte?
Nur für iPhone 4.
Reicht mir. Hab ich. Ich frage mich, also was ich auch noch nirgends wo gesehen habe, vielleicht wisst ihr das, dieser Hotspot, da kann man ja sicherlich ein Passwort draufsetzen.
Sicherlich.
Ist das dann WPA verschlüsselt?
Gute Frage.
Weil auch das WLAN-Sharing in Lion ist immer noch nur WEP.
Woher weißt du das?
Das zeigt der einem an.
Das Lion?
Ist mir zugetragen worden.
Wieso, du bist doch Mac-Developer oder nicht?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Und wenn wär's noch viel schlimmer.
Wieso?
Weil du nur dann Ärger kriegen kannst.
Ach echt?
Ja, wenn du Mac-Developer bist, kannst du so viel über Lion reden wie willst. Hast ja nichts unterschrieben.
Ich hab da kein Handy an unterschrieben.
Jetzt wird's dir ganz schön warm, übrigens. Oha, die Heizung bollert hier.
Tja, ihr wolltet es warm haben. Ich mach's mal kurz ein bisschen.
Spiel mal kurz die Warteschleife ein. Wir haben nicht vorhin Tims Heizung umkonfiguriert, weil es hier so kalt war in der Meta-Ebene. Und jetzt verglühen wir hier. Ja, das war's mit dem iPad, oder?
Naja, so richtig viel. Also, gibt's da noch Sachen zu erzählen?
Nee, wenn das... Ist halt so consumer-fu, also ich weiß nicht. Ist ganz hübsch und so. Und es wird bestimmt toll zum Musiklernen und rumspielen und dödeln und so, aber...
Gruber wird wieder schreiben, they didn't get the memo or the iPad is only for consumption.
Ja, wieso? Beer oder was?
Nein, Apple selber didn't get the memo, weil... Du kannst den Vorhang da so ein bisschen davor machen.
Ja, ich halte das mal kurz auf. Ja, ich meine, ich glaube, da wären schon viele Leute mit rumdödeln, also so...
Also ich hab das nur so jetzt, da war ich dann ein bisschen abgelenkt, weil ich hier mal rüberkommen musste, aber wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, haben sie da so das Feature, dass du eine Klaviatur hast und darauf spielen kannst, aber sie sind auch in der Lage, Force Feedback zu machen, indem sie den Beschleunigungssensor auswerten. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du auf die Tasse drauf tippst, messen sie, wie sehr du das ganze Gerät drückst dabei und leiten daraus den Tastenanschlag, die Tastenanschlag-Intensität.
Das war so, genau.
Das ist pfiffig, oder? Ich finde das total pfiffig.
Warte doch mal langsam, wo messen sie was ab?
Na, sie machen die einfach mit Beschleunigungssensor oder sonst was, wie doll du da drauf gehämmert hast auf die Tasse, und je nachdem, ob das Gerät jetzt noch so total smooth da liegt oder ein bisschen erschüttert wird, wird halt doller oder...
Also sie messen sozusagen die Erschütterung des gesamten Gerätes und legen das quasi um auf diesen Anschlag, den du durchgeführt hast und wissen dann, ob du nur etwas angetippt hast oder ob du drauf gedonnert hast.
Also so zum Rumspielen, ich glaube, ich würde mir das sogar kaufen, um so ein bisschen rumzuspielen, ein paar komische Garage-Bench. Vielleicht gibt es das ja auch fürs iPhone. Haben sie gesagt, ob es nur für iPad ist?
Das ist wohl nur für iPad.
Aber hat nicht das iPhone sogar genauso viel Auflösungen? Naja, also das ist schon ganz nett. Wenn ich ein iPad hätte, würde ich mir das auf jeden Fall kaufen. Muss ich jetzt wohl so formulieren, da ich mir jetzt kein iPad kaufe?
Also diese neunfaches, also der überhaupt CPU-Speed erhöht und Grafik-Power erhöht, ist schon ganz cool. Ansonsten, wegen mangelnder Konkurrenz brauchen sie ja mit den coolen Features erst mal noch gar nicht so rausrücken, weil es ja nur ein Stab hat im WR gemacht. Und die Grafik, Kumpel von mir programmiert ja so ein bisschen auf dem iPad und auch so Games. Und da war es schon so, dass das iPad schon ein bisschen langsamer war als das iPhone 4, weil halt der Grafik-Chip ist ja wohl in beiden Geräten der gleiche. Und das iPad muss aber viel mehr anzeigen und dadurch ging die Frame Rate schon ganz schön im Keller irgendwie teilweise. Und das wär jetzt damit sozusagen erstmal gefixt. Wobei halt die Frage ist, wenn das beim iPhone 4 jetzt auch ein Dual-Core kommt mit 9-fach, meinste?
Natürlich bauen sie den A5 auch ins iPhone ein. Ich meine, warum sollten sie das nicht tun? Wenn er dieselbe Power-Consumption hat. Also warum sollten sie das nicht tun? Ich meine, das liegt ja total auf der Hand. Was sollen sie denn sonst machen im iPhone, um das noch sehr viel besser zu machen?
Da ist eigentlich nichts mehr besser zu machen.
Also mir würden da jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele Sachen einfallen. Hardware-technisch.
Außer schneller. Genau. Und Batterie länger halten lassen.
Akku länger und schnelleres Gerät. War noch was? Warten.
Wollte ich das wirklich wissen.
Antennergate.
Ob das iPad 2 auch einen Deathgrip hat? Na ich glaube die Zeit ist noch nicht gekommen.
Ja aber wenn die kommt, dann ist Apple gleich da mit am Start dabei. Weil was hab ich gerade hier auf irgendeiner Werbe-Seite gesehen? Wer baut jetzt gerade hier auch die kleinsten Beamer? Samsung. Wer ist best friend of Apple, wenn es um dicke Einkäufe geht? Samsung.
Ja ich sag Apple würde jeder gerne irgendwas verkaufen. Da hängt es jetzt nicht an Samsung. Ich hab ja so einen kleinen Beamer mal ausprobiert.
Das war nicht klein. Ich mein wirklich, der ist ins iPhone reinpasst.
Ja es gibt diese Pico-Teile und so. Aber die machen halt so 20, 30 Loom. Und da frag ich mich halt wirklich...
Ja, ist halt nur ein Phone, ist schon klar. Es wird jetzt nicht irgendwie... Aber die fangen irgendwann damit an. Und dann ein Jahr später ist das Bild doppelt so groß. Und in drei, vier Jahren hast du da...
Ja, aber die Frage ist, würde Steve das als eine compelling presentation ansehen? Ist das irgendwie was, was awesome ist?
Du meinst, da vorne auf der Bühne steht und er da mit dem Beamer da so ein DIN A4 großes Bild auf, dass das keiner erkennen kann.
Es macht mal richtig dunkel hier. Alle mal eure Displays dem Morgen.
Ja, und das insbesondere, wo sie so eine Infrastruktur haben mit Airplay und allen möglichen Displays und so weiter. Und Beamer haben die Leute eh, oder sie haben halt einen großen Fernseher. Also es ist irgendwie dieses Business. Ich mach mal eben an einer Curry-Bude da eine Präsentation. Das ist irgendwie nicht so richtig. Das ist es irgendwie nicht. Also das kann man machen.
Was ist in Telefonen der nächste große Schritt? Auch wenn wir jetzt eigentlich noch beim iPad waren.
Das ist echt eine gute Frage.
Ist jetzt schon wieder vorbei. Also so ging es ja dem normalen Telefon auch. Irgendwann war ja nichts mehr los. Dann kamen die Farbdisplays. Und mit den Farbdisplays kamen dann ja auch schnell, relativ schnell die Smartphones. Das war ja sozusagen in einem Übergang fast. Und weil vorher ging eigentlich, ein paar Jahre lang kamen da wirklich nichts so doll spannendes mehr, oder?
Nee, mehr Telefonbombeinträger.
Die wollten wir nur kleiner und kleiner. Irgendwann war es dann auch zu klein für die Hand. Dann war nicht mehr wirklich so viel zu machen. Und dann mussten die Smartphones her.
Also was ich ganz cool fände, wäre einfach mal eine Taste, um ein Foto zu machen. Also dass einfach das Teil sich besser als Kamera benutzen lässt. Das fände ich schon... Weil das ist einfach... Nimmst es raus, einschalten, Swipe, warten, home, aus der Applikation raus, wo ist mein Kamera-Icon, scroll, links, scroll, rechts, ich find's nicht, Doppelklick, suchen, draufklicken, warten, warten.
Shit, jetzt ist das Model weg.
Dann ist es da, ja, also es vergehen einfach Stunden und Tage, bist du dann endlich, dann tippst du darauf rum, es reagiert nicht, dann hast du so viel drauf rumgetippt, dass du dann im Videomodus bist, dann nimmst du erstmal 5 Sekunden Video auf, bis du das merkst und dann schaltest du es wieder, dann machst du stopp, das dauert wieder, dann sind irgendwie 2 Minuten vergangen und die tolle, coole Situation, die du gerade fotografieren wolltest, ist irgendwie weg. Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht, warum sie nicht in der Lage sind, das schneller zu machen. Das wäre was, wo einfach so ein Knopf cool wäre.
Weil es halt keine extra Knopf machen werden.
Naja, aber ich meine, wie willst du schnell Fotos schießen, anders machen?
Mit einer Geste.
Jetzt mach endlich!
Ja...
Irgendwie so vier Finger swipeen nach schräg oben und ab in den Kameramodus.
Das wäre auch vorstellbar. Und das würde ich in gewisser Hinsicht auch als ähm... ausreichend empfinden. Wenn man dann auch gleich die Geste variieren kann, dass es auch so mit Licht ist oder so. Oder so ein Taschenlampenknopf wäre auch mal ganz cool. Also warum kann man nicht einfach das Ding als Taschenlampe benutzen, ohne da auch erst mal wieder stundenlang dein Flashlight-Programm starten zu müssen, nur um diesen Scheiß Teil zu machen.
Dann geht in deiner Taschenlampe diese Voll-Power-LED an und dann packst du es aus und es ist leer.
Das kann man ja designmäßig schon so machen, dass es eben nicht auslöst.
Ja, das ist voll Apple-untypisch. Die werden da nix...
Ich stell dir mal voll das Gesicht von Jonathan Eve wenn du da hingehst und sagst, kannst du mal an das Gerät noch einen Taschenlampenknopf anmachen?
Hast du seine...
Der Chat schlägt gerade vor Sprachsteuerung.
Johnny Ive irgendwie Sprüche gelesen, die er so...
Johnny Ive, der will ja weg.
Angeblich.
Schnauze voll.
Nee, der hat keinen Bock, seine Kinder auf die amerikanischen Schulen zu schicken. Und das kann ich auch verstehen. Ich weiß zwar nicht, ob es in Britannien wirklich besser ist, aber...
Ich denke, er hat das notwendige cash, damit er auch irgendwie eine brauchbare Schule kriegt, aber...
Aber die gehen ja in England zur Schule wohl.
Tun sie das?
Ja, das ist ja so, in England. Angeblich, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen was gelesen habe. Aber so Steve Jobs als Europäer könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen. So mit Headquarters hier in... München? Nee. England?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt auf dem Silicon Valley abhauen und dann irgendwie... in Nordengland einen Campus aufmachen. Das wäre dann wahrscheinlich Instant Brain Drain.
Außerdem haben sie ja schon ihr Rechenzentrum, oder wie heißt das?
Data Center.
Data Center heißt das heutzutage.
North Carolina.
Was sind da eigentlich für Temperaturen? Ich wollte ja in Kanada den Schnee aufmachen.
Im Data Center? Die Temperaturen?
Dennis, der tapfere Witztöter.
Na gut, also iPad 2, ich glaube wir haben das Thema irgendwie durch. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Gerät und ich bin froh, dass es nicht so ein Carbon-Fiber-Tralala ist, sondern im schicken Aluminium daherkommt. Da war ich ein bisschen beunruhigt, dass da jetzt so ein Plastiteil rauskommt.
Aber wenn man damit nochmal 100 Gramm sparen könnte, oder 50 mit Carbon-Deckel?
Ja, wenn, wenn, wenn. Also da hätte es schon auch wirklich massiv viel leichter sein müssen.
Für Carbon.
Mit dem Carbon. Keine Ahnung, ich meine klar, wenn man das ordentlich hinkriegt und es sieht dann immer noch cool aus, meinetwegen. Aber das war vielleicht eines der wenigen Gerüchte, die jetzt nicht gestimmt haben, oder?
Hat Apple bisher noch nie gemacht, weiß nicht.
Wir haben ja auch noch weitere Produktvorstellungen, die uns auch noch mehr zu erzählen. Naja, neue MacBooks.
Und Dennis hat gleich geklickt.
Echt, hab ich? Hab ich, instantly.
Achso, du bist ja hier noch auf welcher Generation?
Auf der, wo man gerade noch so den Lion installieren kann.
Da, wo noch das kleine Touchpad verbaut ist.
Ich hab das erste Chords, wo du was rauskommst. Dezember 2006 oder Oktober kam es, glaube ich, raus. Und das Lion läuft da drauf übrigens prima.
Aber du wolltest immer noch so ein fettes Teil haben, wenn man das so mit so Fett platzten und so. Hast du dir richtig auch rechts unten Konfiguration geklickt, so mit SSD und Verlagschlag?
Nee, ich hab 15 Zoll rechts unten ohne SSD.
Das ist mir halt auch echt unbegreiflich.
2011, Dennis, ohne SSD.
Ja, weil ich will keine 128 Gig SSD. 256 wäre mir auch zu wenig. Und 512 kostet schon ein bisschen viel. Ich hab niemanden, der mir das bezahlt.
Du kannst dir eine SSD in das Teil rein. Das kann ich ja immer noch machen. Das Teil ist mit der SSD schneller als das neue mit Festplatte.
Das hier, das alte Ding.
Ja, dein altes. Wenn du da eine SSD reinbaust, ist das schneller als das Teil, was du dir jetzt kaufst.
Ja, aber ich hab's mir jetzt schon gekauft. Und da werde ich dann vielleicht irgendwann in Zukunft mal eine SSD einbauen. Zusätzlich oder im Tausch, das weiß ich noch nicht.
Er ist unerleuchtet, Hucke.
Ich muss ja erst mal einen neuen Rechner haben.
Ich hab nicht das Licht gesehen.
Ja, weil ein neuer Rechner stinkt ohne SSD.
Also das ist wie mit Floppy-Disc gekauft.
Mit Drehenerscheibe meinst du, spinning rust.
Ja, also das kommt mir schon so anachronistisch vor.
Also ich kann verstehen, dass er die nicht bei Apple kauft.
Ich glaube, die 512 Gigabyte würden bei Apple 1100 Euro kosten.
Also teuer, also die 512 ist überall arschteuer.
Ja, aber weniger geht man nicht.
Die SSDs von Apple sind jetzt nicht so sehr viel teurer. Du zahlst so, ich glaube, beim AMAC habe ich es mal durchgerechnet, vielleicht 100 Euro mehr bei einer 270.
Ja, das ist mir alles too much. Pass mal auf, wir klicken jetzt mal schnell.
Die Apple SSDs, die sind halt auch wirklich schnell.
Ja, wobei sie jetzt auch nicht die allerschnellsten sind. Also es gibt schon deutlich schnellere SSDs. Also deutlich schnellere.
Schneller als die, die hier in dem R verbaut sind.
Ich glaube schon. Also ich meine, es gibt jetzt welche, die 285 MB schreiben und lesen können und so. Und meins schafft hier...
Aber diese Chips in so ein Festplattengehäuse reinzubauen, das ist so ein Frevel eigentlich.
So, ich bin jetzt hier im Store. So 512 Gigabyte SSD bei Apple plus 1100 Euro.
Ja, die sind halt teuer.
Das heißt, ich kriege für 750 Gigabyte Festplatte die drin ist, kriege ich dann nicht und zahle 1100 Euro dafür, dass ich 512 Gigabyte Solid State kriege. Ich könnte schwören, ich kriege für 700 oder 600 Euro diese 512 Gigabyte Solid State und behalte meine 750 GB Platte.
Naja, ich glaube nicht. Für unter 1000 kriegst du die glaube ich nicht. Keine brauchbaren 512er. Ich glaube, die sind immer noch zu teuer.
Ja, aber dann ist das halt noch nichts für mich. Das ist mir zu teuer. Und ich hab keinen Bock irgendwie eine 128 GB SSD zu kaufen und dann nur mein OS draufzahlen, weil nur das OS, das ist sowieso bei 8 GB irgendwann nach 30 Sekunden Nutztime alles im Cache und das muss nicht auf einem SSD liegen. Meine Daten, die ich andauernd schreibe...
Red's dir noch schön mit den Platten, red's dir noch schön. Du hast das Licht nicht gesehen. Doch, doch, doch. Du hast das Licht nicht gesehen.
Aber du zacker hast auch 512 GB. Du hast dein gesamtes System da drauf. Dann ist es ja richtig, aber nur das OS da drauf zu machen, dringt es nicht.
Hättest du selber bezahlt? Ich hätte mir dann keine 512 gekauft, sondern auch zwei Platten rein.
Sag ich ja, aber das kann man halt nicht bei Apple. Das muss ich selber machen. Noch habe ich den Rechner nicht, also kann ich das auch noch nicht machen. So, bei denen wieder mal neue MacBook Pros und ich weiß das nicht.
Aber du als Apple-Großaktionär hättest dir das ja ruhig mal gönnen können.
Ich kann den nicht verkaufen, weil dann muss man Steuerzahlen abdagen. Jetzt erst mal abwarten, wie die Kiste so fliegt. Vielleicht ist ja auch alles mit Leiden ganz anders. Und ja.
Also ist das jetzt wirklich...
Ich weiß es ja, aber erst mal habe ich die jetzt so bestellt. Außerdem will man ja dann nochmal die Differenz sehen. Also erst mal das so benutzt, dann die SSD einbaut und dann sieht man, wie das plötzlich nochmal mehr abfliegt. Gut.
Kommen wir dann vielleicht nochmal zu den MacBooks selber. Was neu ist. Also sie haben schnellere Prozessoren, also die i7s.
Naja, die neuen Sandy Bridge Prozessoren haben sie. Die jetzt auch Quad-Core haben, wenn man...
Mit High Pass Redding auch, ne?
Das hatten die alten auch schon.
Ja, aber jetzt sozusagen Quad-Core mit High Pass Redding, also so wie hier bei meinem iMac so 8 virtuelle Kerne.
Genau.
Das fliegt mit Handbrake.
Das fliegt deutlich, ja. Also aus den ganzen Benchmarks, die sind schon wirklich dann einfach mal doppelt so schnell.
Ja, wenn man Rips macht. Aber was anderes machst du auch nicht, ne?
Nee, den ganzen Tag. Der kleinste 13 Zoller ist glaube ich schneller als der schnellste 17 Zoller von davor.
Aber die haben die 13 Zoller, die haben noch nur ein Dual-Core.
Nee, die alten hatten einen Dual-Core, die neuen...
Nein, nein, die 13 Zoller haben einen Dual-Core und 15 und 17 haben Quad-Core.
Jetzt bei den neuen?
Nein!
Die 13 Zoller hatten vorher noch keinen i5. Sondern einen Core 2 Duo. Und jetzt sind sie auf i5 gegangen und die großen, 15, 17, die haben die 7.
Ja sag ich ja, die aktuellen haben einen Core i-Dings.
Ja, aber keinen Quad.
Nee, Dual.
Nicht Core 2 Duo.
Das 13 Zoller ist schneller als was?
Als das alte 17 Zoller.
Hast du einen Benchmark? Ich glaube nicht.
Aber ist bestimmt langsamer als mein kleines 11 Zoll R.
Und das nützt du bei Handbrake wie viel?
Handbrake drauf geschissen. Daily arbeiten ist für mich wichtig. Für Handbrake habe ich hier meinen iMac und das flutscht wie Hölle. Und ich finde für so einen mobilen Rechner ist das nicht so wichtig, wie gut man da irgendwie rippen kann, zum Beispiel da eh keine DVDs reinkriegen.
Ja, das ist schon klar.
Wer rippt denn heute noch DVDs?
Dieses R ist einfach gefühlt schneller als mein MacBook Pro. Jetzt das, was gerade abgelöst wurde durch die neuen Mid-Fest-Platte. Das ist einfach die Wahrheit. Und ich weiß, ich hätte das natürlich auch schneller bekommen mit einer SSD, aber dann wär's halt immer noch groß, schwer, globig und like.
Du bist halt mehr so die 13 Zoll oder R Fraktion, ich bin mehr so die 15 Zoll Fraktion und dann haben wir hier mit Hucke die 17 Zoll Fraktion.
Nee, ich bin die Schnell-Fraktion. Ich mag's einfach, wenn's schnell ist.
Die Flagship-Fraktion.
Schnell ist bisher SSD und Core i7.
Unter drei.
Unter drei. Da kann ich mit drei erst nebeneinander arbeiten. Im Cluster.
Mit iXun und so.
Bei Xcoter mit DCT macht das nicht an.
Jeder so wie er mag.
Und dann Thunderbolts and Lightning, very, very frightening. Wir brauchen, wo ist das Soundboard? Das ist schonmal die richtige Band.
Jetzt eigentlich Audiolinks? Also es gibt doch irgendwie Visual-Links, die über diese Barcodes funktionieren.
Gibt es auch Audio-Links? Wir wollen Galileo haben.
Wo dann so...
kommt.
Und wenn man so dabei das Mikro anhatte, dann wird gleich hingelinkt. Das wär's. Patentanmelden, Hucke schnell. Jetzt haben die mitgehört.
Ich fühl mal eben das Formular aus.
Hier Prior Art, wenn ihr in 10 Jahren mal jetzt diese Sendung hört, seit dem Jahr 2021, war unsere Idee. Wir sind immer noch bei den neuen MacBook Pros, bevor wir uns hier abgleiten.
Wir sind bei Thunderbolt.
Das ist ja, sind wir das schon? Also es war ja sonst immer die, also Grafik war halt noch neu. Okay, AMD sind sie jetzt wieder.
Also was man sagen muss, bei dem Sandy Bridge, der hatte halt, genauso wie bei den Chips vorher, bei den Core i Dingern, die Grafik, die GPU eingebaut. Aber jetzt hat Quatsch Intel ordentlich aufgerüstet. Und zwar ist es jetzt, voriges Jahr glaube ich nur Intel HD Graphics. Jetzt heißt es Intel 3000 HD oder HD 3000 Graphics. Und das ist schon noch mal reichlich schneller, besser weiter. Aber bei den 13 Zoll, wo das ja auch drin ist und keine extra Grafikkarte, ist es wohl langsamer, als die Nvidia Grafik, die sie vorher bei dem 13 Zoll hatten. Das heißt, wer sich jetzt einen 13 Zoll kauft und auf Grafik angewiesen ist, der sollte sich das vielleicht nochmal überlegen, weil es ist leicht langsamer. Spart wohl auch ein bisschen mehr Strom, aber ist halt eben ein bisschen langsamer.
Also ich muss sagen, dieses 13 Zoll MacBook Pro, das ist wirklich ein Gerät, das macht irgendwie überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also es ist im Vergleich zu den 15 Zollern technisch so rückständig, was Speed betrifft. Halber Prozessor, Speed, Grafik ist schlechter. Die Auflösung ist schlechter als beim MacBook Air mit 13 Zoll. Vielleicht ist der Bildschirm besser. Vielleicht ist der Bildschirm einfach das bessere IPS-Display mit mehr Farbe, mehr Brillanz, heller, keine Ahnung. Das kann ja sein. Und du kannst es ja auch jetzt in Blend frei klicken, in Matt. Jetzt doch. Das ist wahrscheinlich aber immer noch billiger als das 15 Zoll. Stimmt gar nicht.
Wir haben es immer noch nicht gemacht.
Und es ist halt schwer. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, warum man sich das kaufen sollte. Es ist nur, wenn dir partout 15 Zoll zu viel ist. Mit 13 Zoll hast du da viel gespart. Und du brauchst unbedingt ein DVD-Laufwerk.
Und einen Thunderbolt-Anschluss.
Und einen Thunderbolt. Ja, okay, Firewire ist drin, war's recht.
Und dieser SD-Slot, oder?
Ja, wobei...
Die Römer waren gar nicht so schlecht.
Die was?
Die Römer? Ich sag nicht, dass es niemanden gibt, der dafür jetzt eine Anwendung hat, aber es ist...
Du hast halt die Anwendung nicht.
Es könnte attraktiver sein.
Tim ist auch nicht berühmt, dafür über den Teller ranzugucken.
Aber was mich ja noch interessieren würde... Bei Artcom machen die ja immer ganz viel 3D-Kram. Die setzen ja immer voll auf NVIDIA und fanden ja AMD oder wie hieß das, ATI vorher immer irgendwie doof, weil die irgendwie ihre Treiber nicht im Griff hatten und irgendwie immer komische Bugs und immer nicht ganz fertig implementiert.
Das ist ja bei Apple egal, weil die mit den Grafik-Treibern ja eh immer hinterher sind.
Wobei, aber die jetzt bei Artcom ja auch mal mehr auf Apple umgestiegen sind, immer bloß mit NVIDIA-Chips und waren auch alle ganz froh, wenn es dann NVIDIA gab. Und jetzt, ich hab mal gespannt, ob sie da mitziehen. Naja, nee, es gab da schon immer mal so Leute, die meinten, ja eigentlich ist ATI auch gar nicht so schlecht, aber man müsste sich das alles nochmal angucken und und weißt schon, never change a running system. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist noch neu? Es gibt SDXC-Support jetzt in diesen neuen MacBook Pros.
Was macht das?
Na, du hast halt SD-Card in High Speed.
Und bis zwei Terabyte wohl, oder so.
Genau, und in groß. Das ist halt da diese, was war die Grenze?
Zwei Terabyte, holy shit.
32 GB war die Grenze, bei den alten SDs. Oder was, 64? Weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Das ist natürlich wiederum ein ganz cooles Feature, aber das hat ja auch das R. Also das große R hat ja auch SD-Karte, aber ich glaube kein XC. Aber überhaupt die Möglichkeit, so mal so eben noch so eine SSD reinzuschieben, das ist ja auch nicht blöd.
Zwei Terabyte, also okay, die gibt's natürlich nicht.
Theoretisch könntest du ja da dein OS drauf installieren. Ja, praktisch auch. Das wäre für dich eine Option.
Ich hab ja hier auch immer noch so einen Express Card Slot oder so was.
Ja, ich auch noch.
Und dafür, nie benutzt, aber dafür gab's ja auch schon.
Vier Jahre und noch nicht mal irgendwas drin gehabt, noch nie. Doch, ich glaub mal so eine UMTS Card, aber nur aus Test und als nichts passiert, dann hab ich sie da rausgenommen, aber sonst noch nie irgendwas drin gehabt.
Na, auf jeden Fall gab's ja da schon SSDs für diesen Slot, so zum Testen. Aber die haben halt mega schlechte Kritiken bekommen, weil die zu heiß geworden sind und die dann hier irgendwie alles weggeschmolzen. Keine Ahnung, ne? Also auf jeden Fall, also die SSD-Karten sind da wohl geschmolzen oder so.
So, da hat man doch mal drüber erzählt, da gab's irgendwie so 48 GB oder 64 GB SSDs, wo dann Leute angefangen haben, ihr OS irgendwie drauf zu installieren und so weiter, weil man auch davon booten konnte. Aber ja, so ganz happy waren die dann nicht. Ich hab da mal bei Amazon irgendwie geklickt, was wir so in den Fortschritt geschrieben haben. Und mal geht's und mal stockt's aber. Und ja, es war noch nicht so ausgereift.
Das wär halt noch so eine einzige Anwendung dafür gewesen, ja. Naja, aber ich hab auch in den ganzen Jahren nichts in diesen Slot hineingesteckt.
Ja, was natürlich jetzt noch für SSDs spricht, weil eure SSDs, wenn ihr so berauscht seid, die sind natürlich auch immer noch nicht voll und nicht ausgenutzt. Die werden ja ein bisschen langsamer. Und Snow Leopard hatte ja keinen Trim Support. Und den gibt es jetzt aber mit Lion. Kommen wir aber dann auch gleich noch dazu.
Genau.
Vielleicht nochmal.
Ein Bolt Move, wenn ich das so sagen darf.
Ja, also der Name auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Der mussten sie ja unbenennen, weil Intel hat das Ding ja Lightpeak genannt, wobei es eigentlich über Glasfaser gehen sollte. Oder was heißt Glas? Glas nehmen die dann bei so einem billigen Kabel eher, aber ist egal. Jedenfalls optisch. Und dann haben sie es aber irgendwie nicht richtig hingekriegt oder war zu teuer. Und dann hat Intel ja auf Kupfer gewechselt. Und dann war es natürlich ein bisschen blöd, wenn man es dann Lightpeak nennt, weil Lightpeak war es ja dann nicht mehr. War ja dann mehr so ein...
Nee, das hat mit Wechseln so gar nichts zu tun. Sondern ich denke, dass sie von vornherein schon immer das auch für Kabel, für Kupfer geplant haben. Und zwar aus einem ganz einfachen Grund. Über Optisches kriegst du einfach keine Power. So, und das ist nun mal bei so einem Interface das A und O. Du willst da eine Festplatte anschließen und der Festplatte nicht noch mal externen Netzteil zuführen müssen.
Ja, aber gerade auch du müsstest ja wieder mit dem Audio graben, dass gerade ohne Power auch wieder das A und O ist. Wegen hier der Gehwarnisch getrennt und so.
Ja, der Punkt ist, du kannst das tun. Du hast auch bei Thunderbolt sehr wohl, wenn jetzt auch noch nicht unbedingt kaufbar, aber von der Spezifikation her ist das auch bei Firewire. Du kannst auch Firewire optisch machen. Es gibt für Firewire auch optische Kabel bzw. entsprechende Hubs, wo du halt ein optisches Kabel reinsteckst und kannst dann eben Firewire über eine lange Strecke optisch machen. Ich hab das nie im Einsatz gehabt, aber das gibt es. Also Firewire 800 kann auch optisch. Am Ende ist das ja Wurst. Hauptsache das Signaling geht darüber und du hast die entsprechenden Transceiver. Das ist ja für das Protokoll eigentlich egal. Das Problem ist nicht das Kabel, das Problem ist das Timing im Chip. Du musst halt diese hohen Geschwindigkeiten auf beiden Seiten eben auch hinkriegen, damit du die Daten so schnell übertragen bekommst. Das Kabel macht es eben mit. Kupfer hat bloß nur die Einschränkung, dass es nicht so lang sein darf. Ich glaube jetzt hier bei Thunderbolt sind es drei Meter von der Spezifikation her. Aber du hast den Vorteil, dass du eben Power drüber liefern kannst. Und sie machen 10 Watt, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen weniger als bei Firewire, aber eben mehr als bei USB. Und das dürfte schon ausreichen.
Ich bilde mir ein Firewire war ein bisschen drunter.
Also USB hatte ja eigentlich ein halbes Ampere bei 5 Volt, was ja 2,5 Watt sind. Die Rechner, die MacBook Pros, hauen aber sowieso schon glaube ich per Default 1 Ampere raus oder sind es inzwischen sogar 2, weil dann wären die auch schon bei 10 Watt eigentlich. Bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Gucken wir mal schnell.
7 bis 8 Watt ist bei Firewire.
Siehste, also 10 Watt ist schon glaube ich Top Notch für so ein, genau.
Ich dachte das wäre, oder ist das bei Firewire 800 anders?
Ist egal, geht auf jeden Fall ordentlich was drüber.
Genau, geht auf jeden Fall ordentlich was drüber. Und das ist halt nicht ganz unwichtig, weil du dann eben Kameras, Festplatten, all diesen ganzen Muppets, den du da anschließen willst, den kriegst du halt auch gleich noch aus deinem Teil gepowert. Das ist natürlich gerade für so ein Laptop-Situation einfach Pflicht, finde ich. Also von daher hätte mich optisch sehr überrascht, weil das hätte bedeutet, dass du einen Port hast, der keine Power liefert. Und was willst du dann da anschließen?
Und Apple hat ja den Mini Display Port designt, den Stecker vor. Deswegen haben sie da schon gewusst, was sie tun und haben gleich irgendwie die Pins so gemacht, dass da noch der Thunderbolt mit drüber geht.
Also das ist wirklich großartig. Das Ding ist ja im Wesentlichen so eine Art externer PCI-Expressbus. Das ist ja Thunderbolt in seiner vollen Form. Und das eben mit derzeit 10 Gigabit. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, haben sie da auch so eine Migrationspfad nach oben. Und ich schätze mal, wenn sie jetzt auf 10 Gigabit sind, dann ist die nächste Stufe halt 100.
Ja, die wird man ja auf lange Sicht erstmal nicht brauchen. Das wird schon noch eine Weile dauern.
Meinst du, das kriegt man ja nie voll?
Doch, doch, kriegt man voll. Aber mit 10 ist man glaube ich schon mal ganz gut im Rennen gerade.
Ja, das stimmt aber. Dann ist ja wieder andere Bottlenecks auf einmal.
Wir würden aber schon ein paar Anwendungen einfallen, wo ich eben auch mehr als 10 Gigabit haben will.
Ja, haben wollen.
Na, 3D-Fernsehen. Und ich meine jetzt nicht 3D, Stereo 3D, ich meine 3D. Also so für Mediziner oder so, denn die dann wirklich irgendwie...
Ich finde das so eine coole Idee, Bildschirme und Datentransfer jetzt zu vereinheitlichen. Also diese Zeit, das...
Was halt fehlt ist der Bildschirm. Also wo ist der Thunderbolt-Bildschirm, wo ich wirklich nur ein Kabel reinstecke, der dann am besten Firewire, USB, SD, also alles mit dran hat.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das nächste Upgrade für ihre Displays.
Aber die kamen erst gerade auch beim letzten Mal, oder? Also vor einem Jahr.
Ja, ich meine, was sollte sie jetzt davon abhalten, Revice-Displays rauszubringen, die Thunderbolt haben und auch gleichzeitig noch Hub für verschiedene Pods?
Also, weil das wär's, weil dann wirklich steckst ein einziges... Und Ethernet auch, also alles wirklich an dem Display dran. Das schleppst eh nicht mit dir rum. Das heißt, da können alle Kabel ran. Das kann so stehen bleiben, wie es halt da steht. Dann, das wär total super.
Weil du musst es jetzt nicht unbedingt im Display haben. Ich meine, ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn du jetzt von Belkin oder Griffin, gibt's demnächst halt so ein Thunderbolt-Dock.
Ja, oder sowas.
So, und da hast du eben alles dran. Da hast du Ethernet dran, da hast du USB dran, da hast vielleicht sogar Firewire dran, da hast du Mini-Displayport dran für dein Display. Genau, und am besten gleich zwei.
Kannst ja nur sechs Geräte oder so chainen.
Ja, aber das wäre ja nur ein Gerät.
Meins.
Dieses Dock wäre ein Gerät.
Sechs Thunderbolt kannst du chainen. Aber wenn dann halt so ein Multi-Hub rankommt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein Thunderbolt-Gerät.
Das ist ein Thunderbolt-Device.
Wenn da dann gleich mehrfach USB rauskommt, dann zählt das ja nicht als wie sechs Geräte, wenn da sechsmal USB dran ist. Das ist ja was anderes schon wieder.
Genau, also von so Docking Stations haben sie auch explizit gesprochen. Ich halte das für sehr realistisch, dass das sogar im Wesentlichen die nächste Generation ist. Die einzige Problematik, die es da derzeit noch gibt, wo ich mir nicht so sicher bin, wie das aussieht, ist, in dem Moment, wo du da, also angenommen, du brauchst jetzt so einen Dock und das hat USB oder irgendwelche anderen Ports, Firewire. Die Kommunikation ist halt PCI Express. Das heißt, du hast da im Wesentlichen einen Systembus. Sprich, der Rechner spricht direkt mit dem Chip im Dock über Thunderbolt. Das heißt wiederum, du brauchst dafür einen Treiber. Sprich, du kannst da jetzt nicht irgendwas reinbauen und dann geht das auch, sondern das geht sozusagen nur, wenn auf der anderen Seite auch Software ist, die mit diesem Stein umgehen kann, der da halt Firewire macht. Also du hast zwar die Kapazität in diesem Kabel, aber das Kabel selber setzt dir jetzt nicht automatisch noch virtuell Firewire um oder USB.
Ja, aber die Software, die gibt es doch hier alles schon.
Für die in das MacBook eingebauten Teile. Aber in diesem Dock müsste ja dann genau dasselbe drin sein. Und das sind ja hier Apple-Steine, die in diesem MacBook drin sind. Du hast hier integrierte Interface-Chips, wo alles Mögliche drin ist. Firewire und so weiter. Und dafür gibt es halt Treiber. Aber wenn du jetzt Bude XY bist, die so einen Dock baut und will da Firewire drin haben, dann, ich meine, ich halte das jetzt nicht für unmöglich, aber das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Aspekt, den man bedenken muss, dass das jetzt nicht so einfach so geht, dass du da jetzt irgendwas ransteckst und dann ist das alles super.
Aber bei den Desktop hast du doch auch in den PCI-Slots irgendwie deine Firewire-Karte, deine USB-Karten reingemacht, wenn du mehr Ports haben wolltest. Und da braucht es ja auch keine extra Treiber, sondern die nehmen da unseren Standard und mappen dann ihre Ports. Genau, dann wird es doch da auch sowas geben.
Das kann gut sein.
Natürlich, für die ganz exotischen Sachen wird es wahrscheinlich Treiber benötigen, aber gerade so wie Firewire und USB und so schnickschnack, und da denke ich mal, wird das Out of the Box funktionieren.
Da hast du recht, OHCI dürfte schon eine ganze Menge abdecken. Was würde mir denn sonst noch so einfallen? Also wo ich zum Beispiel mir nicht so sicher bin, wo durch, wobei doch Ethernet-Karten? Wie ist das mit Ethernet-Karten? Ist auch OHCI, ne? Naja, stimmt richtig, klar. Doch. Also wo ich natürlich super scharf drauf bin, ist natürlich jetzt ein R mit Thunderbolt. Weil dann brauchst du diese ganzen Schnittstellen überhaupt nicht mehr in deinem MacBook. Sondern du hast einfach für alles einen Adapter. Und du kannst halt über dieses eine einzige Loch in deinem Teil, deinem Bildschirm anschließen. Und vor allem damit hätte dann das R endlich mal richtiges Ethernet.
Und wenn sie richtig schlau sind, dann...
Moment, ich guck mal, ob ich einen passenden Sound dafür habe.
Den Touchpad, oder wie das heißt?
Drama-Button.
Ich bin super spontan. Jedenfalls... Ne, das war's gar nicht.
Voll lame.
Der Witz ist...
Ne, dann kommt der Strom auch über Thunderbolt zurück.
Und dann hast du dein Gerät kurz geschlossen.
Ne, dann brauch ich keinen Stromstecker mehr anschließen. Wieder einer gespart.
10 Watt?
Ja, da könnt ihr von der anderen Seite doch mehr rüber schieben. Es sind nur 10 Watt, die rauskommen, weil es ein Laptop ist. Oder meinst du das so spezifiziert?
Ja.
Na, mehr geht doch immer. Sie sagen, dass mindestens 10 kommen. Das ist doch was, die sagen. Wie bei USB, die schicken auch schon mehr drüber. Aber du kannst sich darauf verlassen, dass mindestens ein halbes Ampere kommt. Aber bei den MacBooks kommen jetzt gerade auch für das iPad noch 2 Ampere raus. Das heißt, nach oben können die immer aufstocken. Aber ich würde Laden über Thunderbolt ziemlich cool finden. Weil da ist es wirklich nur noch ein Plug.
Naja, also ich meine, was man sich auf jeden Fall vorstellen kann, ist, dass es verschiedenste... Was?
Na ja, das ist jetzt zu spekulativ.
Ja, nee, mach weiter.
Ja, ich meine, müssen wir das jetzt so groß überleiten?
Nee, nee, nee, müssen wir nicht.
Aber was ist realistisch? Realistisch meiner Meinung nach wäre zum Beispiel ein Gigabit Ethernet-Interface über Thunderbolt.
Natürlich.
Und das wäre einfach der Brüller. Also fürs R. Das wäre für alle Geräte der Brüller. Das ist das Einzige, was es hier nicht gibt, was wichtig ist.
Thunderbolt-Speicher-Sticks. Ich wär jetzt keine USB-Sticks mehr. Es gab ja schon keine Firewire-Memory-Sticks, ne?
Angeblich gab's ja letztens.
Angeblich gab's ja, aber auch keine gefunden, die man kaufen konnte. Aber so ein Thunderbolt-Memory-Stick, so richtig...
Performance. Ja, stimmt. Wär auch interessant.
Finde ich könnte auch Apple immer rausbringen. So einen schönen weißen, schlichten Schnupsi ohne alles, so wie ihre Batterien und das alles. Warum nicht mal ein Firewire oder jetzt ein Thunderbolt-Memory-Stick? Für extra Premium-Preis, aber auch mit grüner LED.
Ja, was könnte man sich... Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es von Apple halt so Standard, so wie es jetzt diesen USB-Ethernet-Dongel gibt, dass es das eben auch für Thunderbolt gibt, dass es das dann auch für Firewire gibt, dass es das auch für USB gibt.
Und jeden darfst du dir einzeln für 29,95...
Mindestens. Wobei, wenn ich mir immer die Qualität dieser Adapter anschaue, ich zahle das gerne. Also hast du mal irgendwie mal nicht Apple-Adapter gekauft?
Ja, das ist schlimm, aber... Was mich richtig nervt, ist der DisplayPort-DVI-Adapter, weil der ist nur... Der hat diese... Da ist ja einmal dieser Querbalken in dem Connector, also so ein Quer, und dann ist Kreuz. Und der hat ja nicht diese vier Schnupsis um diesen Quer-Pin. Das heißt, aber alle anderen Kabel haben immer diese vier Schnupsis und die passen da immer nicht rein. Das ist voll ätzend.
Du meinst, das ist ein DVI-D-Adapter?
Ja, das ist DVD, genau. Aber es gibt halt... An vielen Geräten hängen sozusagen DVI-D-A oder I? I ist beides. Hängen halt entsprechende Kabel dran, auch wenn die vielleicht am Ende nur DVI-D sprechen damit. Aber du stehst dann immer so da, ok, ich hol meinen Adapter raus. Tja, passt nicht, doof. Ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich einfach mit meinem Proxxon die Löcher da reinbohre. Es geht ja nur darum, dass der Stecker passt. Ich will ja nur DVI-D sprechen, aber... Also im Club haben wir ja in unserem Beamer so ein richtig dickes, teures, super supreme DVI-Kabel.
Kann natürlich alles übertragen, hat die vier Pins natürlich belegt, gehen aber immer in den Adapter nicht rein.
Also ich bin jetzt echt durch diesen Display-Port und den Adapter von Apple total eingeschränkt in meiner Konnektivität. Ich kann es nicht zu Hause an meinen Beamer ranstecken und nischt.
Gibt es da nicht vielleicht noch Adapter?
Das Allerbeschissenste, da bin ich ja echt fuchsischt geworden. Ich hab einen Beamer, der hat einen VGA-Anschluss. Und ich hatte ja vorher meinen Mac-DVI-Anschluss. Das heißt, ich hab von VGA auf DVI einen Adapter gehabt. Super. So jetzt dachte ich mir, ok, neues MacBook, jetzt hab ich einen Display-Port und einen DVI-Adapter. Also Display-Port auf DVI. Also Beamer VGA auf DVI, MacBook Display-Port auf DVI. Und die beiden Adapter von Apple passen nicht. Die passen auch nicht zusammen. Aber ok, da ist es dann wahrscheinlich so, weil der VGA-Adapter dann DVI-A spricht.
Oh man.
Ich blick's nicht mehr. Ich hab mir auch erstmal nur einen Mini-Display-Port nach DVI geordert, weil ich noch so ein altes Apple-Display hab. Und dann sollte es ja wohl passen.
Ja, wenn das alte Apple-Display DVI-D spricht.
Das ist wirklich ein bisschen fail, diese ganze Adapter-Plage da bei dem DVI. Das haben sie ja versucht, sich klug einfallen zu lassen, aber irgendwie auch dieser Stecker ist auch einfach zu groß und zu schwer und so.
Der DVI-Stecker.
Ja, aber bei Apple macht es jetzt auch echt noch künstlich schlimmer, finde ich.
Aber Mini-Display-Port ist ja the way to go. Das DVI soll ja auch weg.
Ja, aber wie viel der Ansatz zum Thema Bildschirmanschluss ist das jetzt bei Apple? Was haben wir da schon alles durchmachen müssen?
Oh, dafür können Sie ihn auch nochmal ins Knie geschossen. Nachträglich, ehrlich gesagt. Das war wirklich der absolute Abgrund.
Was war das? Es war auch irgendwie DVI mit USB mit drin und Strom auch. Aber USB auch, ne?
War aber dann zu wenig Strom für die großen Displays und dann mussten sie sich ja einstampfen.
Ja und vor allen Dingen musstest du dir dann so fette Konverterboxen unter den Tisch legen, wenn dein neuerer Mac noch ans alte Display angeht. Und die Konverterboxen haben irgendwie hunderte Euro oder sowas gekostet. Das war wirklich ein...
Ne, das ging nicht.
Das war wirklich schlimm.
Das war auch alles viel zu groß und viel zu elend. Insofern denke ich, ist es... Also jetzt mit Display-Port haben sie schon den richtigen Weg eingeschlagen. Und jetzt mit Thunderbolt noch dazu, ist das irgendwie wirklich cool. Weil es ist einfach der Traum von, man hat nur noch eine einzige Schnittstelle und darüber schließt man alles an, was extern ist. Vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von USB-Legacy-Ports. Die wird es wahrscheinlich weiterhin geben und das macht ja auch Sinn. Um mal eben so diesen USB-Port...
Stell dir mal den Tag vor, wo Apple dann den USB-Port weglässt. Also kommt bestimmt.
Der kommt. Was meinst du, warum sie schon die Bluetooth-Mäuse haben?
Ich glaube, da ist noch sehr viel passieren bis dahin.
Apple macht gerne Bolt Moves.
Aber es ist ja nicht nötig.
Ich meine, warum sollen sie das machen? Wie klein soll das Gerät sein, dass da kein USB-Port mehr drin ist?
Weil der Stecker zu groß ist. Der größte Stecker ist jetzt eigentlich Firewall 800 und Ethernet.
Die kommen ja dann auch weg über den...
Also so ein Thunderbolt-Teil an so einem iPad würde meiner Meinung nach durchaus attraktiv sein. Aber es ist natürlich vom Platz her bei so einem iPad der neuen Generation wahrscheinlich auch schon echt knifflig.
So ein iPad willst du aber wirklich komplett ohne Kabel auf der Couch benutzen, oder?
Da kommt dann wahrscheinlich ein mini Micro Thunderbolt-Stecker raus. 10 Gigabit. Ich will so ein MacBook Air haben mit Thunderbolt. Weil ich bin total heiß auf Gigabit-Internet.
Ja, nie wieder ohne.
Und ich bin nur bei welchen mitreden?
Bei meinem Air. Weil das ist jetzt das Einzige, worauf ich jetzt verzichten muss, ist, dass mein Laptop hier an meinem Audio-Netzwerk teil hat, weil das setzt Gigabit-Internet voraus. Da kann ich mit Fast-Internet nicht dran teilnehmen, wegen des Tamings. Und was ja auch, ich weiß nicht, ich hab euch das mit dieser Spezifikation angeschaut, das ist ja ganz pfiffig, naja von Thunderbolt. Also das Ding macht ja 10 Gigabit, aber das mal zwei.
In beide Richtungen synchron.
Also genau genommen mal vier. Also da hast du pro Richtung zwei Kanäle A 10 Gigabit. Und halt voll bidirektional, also es kommt sich nicht ins Gehege. Das bedeutet aber, du kannst Bildschirme anschließen und die laufen über den einen Kanal, über den einen dedizierten 10 Gigabit Kanal und du kannst alles andere über den anderen 10 Gigabit Kanal anschließen, sodass dein Bildschirmtreffekt ja ja auch permanent ist.
Warum werben sie denn nicht damit? Dass es eigentlich 200 Gigabit sind?
Weil das nicht wahr wäre, weil so eine Bandbreite gibt es nicht. Sie könnten schreiben zwei mal zehn, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich Confusing, weil am Ende des Tages kannst du nicht mehr als zehn wirklich rausholen und je der Speed, mit dem dein Bildschirm angesprochen wird, interessiert keinen Menschen. Also das ist für dich irrelevant, beziehungsweise es wird eh auf absehbare Zeit erstmal der reine Display-Port-Modus sein, wo ja sich das in Datenmengen eh nicht ausdrücken lässt. Und es ist aber nur wichtig zu sehen, dass eben, das ist ja so ein Gedanke, bei dem man schnell ist, wenn man da jetzt schnelle Platten anschließt und dann hast du irgendwie zwei fette Bildschirme noch parallel angeschlossen, dann stellst du ja natürlich auch die Frage, geht das jetzt von meinem 10 Gigabit wieder ab? Und die Antwort ist nein, geht das nicht, weil das ist der zweite Kanal, sodass du eben diese 10 Gigabit auch voll nutzen kannst, sofern du eben etwas hast, was dahinter ist, was auch 10 Gigabit nimmt. Aber im Prinzip könnte das jetzt bedeuten, dass das eben auch einem 10 Gigabit Ethernet-Interface zum Beispiel die Tür öffnet. Den Bedarf dafür sehe ich jetzt bei mobilen Rechnern kein Stück, aber bei so stationären Mac Pros etc. Gut, aber die werden das wahrscheinlich dann eh eingebaut haben.
Wie war das jetzt eigentlich, ist jetzt so eine SSD schon schneller als Gigabit Ethernet?
Gigabit Ethernet ist ja 100, also theoretisches oder ja theoretisch Maximum ist ja 125 MB die Sekunde.
Ok, das heißt SSDs sind schon mal ein ganzes Stück schneller.
Ja, doppelt.
So, siehste, Peng, willst du 10 Gigabit haben?
Ich finde das toll. Also ich finde das wirklich super und das ist auch schön, dass sie jetzt auch einen Migrationspfad haben.
Also wenn diese Docs mit diesen ganzen verschiedenen Anschlüssen kommen und man kann es mit einem Klick, wenn man nach Hause kommt, anschließen. Weil ich mach das ja jeden Tag mit meinem Display und mit USB reinstecken und Ethernet reinstecken und so. Das wär schon cool.
Ja, das denk ich auch.
Und sie haben, was ich ja auch schön fand hier für Dennis, hab ich gleich dran gedacht, haben sie ja bei ihrer Game Changing Graphics hatten sie ja dann irgendwie so einen fetten hier genau World of Warcraft Screen auf ihrer Produktseite. Das heißt, du kannst dann nochmal richtig plus plus zocken?
Ja, ich hab ja hier mit Huckels, der hat seinen ja auch gerade neu seinen 17 Zoll, die Generation, die es gerade noch so gibt. Oder ja, also die letzte gab, genau. Und da hab ich ja auch mal so in Full Resolution Ultra, heißt das ja, da alle Einstellungen gemacht. Und es waren halt nicht so viele Frames, wie ich dachte. Also ist auch klar, es ist halt nur ein Laptop, so ein Desktop ist halt immer irgendwie schneller. Aber wenn jetzt das neue Gerät nochmal wirklich ordentlich schneller sein soll, also laut Apple ja bis zu dreimal, laut irgendwelche anderen Tests, irgendwie eher so 50 Prozent, was auch schon eine ganze Menge ist eigentlich, da bin ich ja doch sehr, sehr gespannt. Ja, bin ich ja voll dafür. Und weil halt bei den alten, also auch bei deinem jetzt hier, da ist halt noch diese eingebaute Grafik auf deinem Core i7, ist halt dieses Intel HD einfach, der ist halt schon ziemlich träge, der, den du jetzt gerade benutzt hast. Du hast kein Display dran und du hast auch kein OpenGL am Start. Und jetzt ist es sozusagen, obwohl da ist auch nie irgendwas langsam oder in so Modus. Und jedenfalls mit dem neuen HD 3000 ist es noch mal ein bisschen flutschiger. Aber wir können ja dann in zwei Wochen ja mal irgendwie den Piep-Vergleich machen und mal auf den Tisch packen.
Und mal auf den Tisch packen, ja.
Und dann mal so ein paar Benchmarks irgendwie fahren oder mal gucken, was so geht. Ja, ist schon sehr gespannt.
Was für mich Frage ist, ob Apple auch an sowas wie Target Disk Mode gedacht hat über Thunderbolt.
Was war's? Irgendein spezieller Buchstabe musst du drücken und dann kommt das.
Oder meinst du, ist T reserviert für Firewire?
Dann hab ich T gelesen und dachte mir, T wie Thunderbolt, aber T war es ja schon immer. Ja, okay, dann kommt das bei T jetzt einfach das Symbol auch.
Also war es schon zu lesen, dass das gehen soll.
Da kommen dann das Firewire-Symbol und das Thunderbolt-Symbol.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch wieder da. Weil bei so einem Air gibt es das halt nicht mehr. Da muss man jetzt Ethernet nehmen und das ist irgendwie ein bisschen... So, ich hab jetzt gerade gestern so ein neues Air, ein altes Air, Migration gestartet und das war ganz schön zickig über Ethernet. Weiß nicht warum. Ich mein, die machen da irgendwie Auto-IP und dralala und müssen sich gesehen haben, aber da waren die Rädchen am Drehen und hat nicht geklappt und probieren nochmal eine Nummer eingeben und so. Da dachte ich mir auch so, gute Güte. Früher mit Firewire war das mal aber echt entspannter. Wenn man das jetzt mit Thunderbolt, ich meine, gut, dann müssen wir jetzt erstmal noch wieder ein paar Generationen abwarten, bis alle Geräte das haben, aber das ist ja zumindest absehbar, dass es wieder kommt. Und dann mit 10 Gigabit Vollpower-Migration zu machen, das ist bestimmt voll der Spaß.
Mit SSD?
Du möchtest ja echt jede Woche mal migrieren, einfach nur, weil es so schön war. Ja, heute würde ich lieber mit dem anderen Rechner rausgehen und dann migrierst du einfach mal so dein System von dem einen Computer auf den anderen, um mit dem laufen zu können.
Weil so irgendeinen kriegt ja eh keiner hin.
Genau, man migriert einfach mal so on demand.
Dabei liegt eher alles in der Cloud.
Sein Name ist Thunderbolt, ich hab jetzt hier gerade nochmal auf der Apple-Seite geklickt und dann werben sie ja schon das Lassi, die BigDisc mit Thunderbolt.
Lassi, Lassi gibt's bei Indermann.
Lassi oder wie auch immer die mal. Und Promise, und Promise mit dem Pegasus. Und dann ist da auch Thunderbolt und so ein geflügeltes Pferd mit Blitz und vor. Ja, ist alles so Thunderbolt. Hast du jetzt dieses Lied von Queen eigentlich noch am Start?
Ja, jemand versucht mir das gerade per...
Will man da nicht lieber...
Ja, ist noch gleich der Pfeiltransfer hier.
Lassi DC nehmen hier mit Thunder.
Ich versuch das die ganze Zeit jetzt zu laden, aber irgendwie Irk und DCC oder wie das heißt, das will bei mir irgendwie nicht so richtig.
DCC, das waren noch Zeiten früher.
Ich hab in meinem Leben noch nie erfolgreich eine Datei über DCC geschaut.
Ich glaub doch, da gab's mal Zeiten, da hab ich so meine Wares bekommen, da gab's so Bots, die hast du angequatscht, was du haben willst, und dann haben die automatisch zu dir eine DCC-Connection gemacht und dann kam das reingeflogen ordentlich. Aber wann war das denn?
Das ist schon nirgends hier.
Zero Bites hab ich hier nur.
Krass, ich hab ja noch ein Stück Pizza.
Schick mir lieber eine Mail hier, dann krieg ich das irgendwie.
Krass, 21. Jahrhundert und Mail ist einfach immer noch da. Immer wieder staunlich. Aber das hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal hier in der Sendung. Aber ich find's immer wieder staunlich.
Das ist für dich hart. Hart.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, bei diesem neuen Sandy Bridge CPU von Intel, da gibt's ja auch neue Instructions. Und zwar sieben Stück, glaube ich, wovon sechs für AES sind. Das ist dieser Advanced Encryption Standard. Da gibt's jetzt von Intel spezielle Instruktionen, die das beschleunigen, dieses Encrypten und Decrypten.
Das gab's auch schon im E7 davor.
Hattest du dein Ding auch schon? Ist egal, na gut, dann haben die das auch schon gehabt. Jedenfalls, weil wir ja gleich sowieso zum Lion rüber switchen, bei Lion, kann man jetzt mal sagen, gibt's Full Disk Encryption. Also das heißt, man kann, nachdem man seinen Lion installiert hat, kann man klicken, ich will Full Disk Encryption, dann fängt er am Hintergrund an, ist dann irgendwann fertig, dann ist alles entkryptet. Wenn man bootet, kommt innerhalb von My Sekunden, fragt er dich nach deinem Passwort, wir waren echt der Stompleier, wir dachten, das wäre der Locken, weil der kam wirklich nach einer Sekunde, kannst du dich erinnern, Hucke? Wir waren so ein bisschen so, war so schnell, und dann war es aber nur der Bootler oder der das Passwort für die Encryption haben will und hat weitergebootet.
Du hast ja gerade die Leute aus dem Chat gepustet.
Das war ja ein Kodec aus Mittelalter.
Das ist noch, glaube ich, so ein alter Mac OS Flippershaut.
Das erinnert mich an Amiga-Spiel Defender of the Crown.
Das war das einzige, was ich jetzt gerade auf Platte hatte.
Du hast uns rausgebracht. Krypto, genau. Und wenn jetzt hier die Core i7s irgendwie Krypto-Unterstützung haben und Lion hier mit Full-Disk-Encryption irgendwie, ich meine, das werden schon eine ganze Menge Leute benutzen, dieses Encryption, wenn es dann noch ordentlich beschleunigt wird, du merkst dann halt überhaupt gar nicht, dass du unten drunter in eine Encryption fährst.
Ich glaube, so wird das sein, ja.
Ja, vor allen Dingen mit SSD.
Da braucht man den Speed dann auch, weil 250 ms muss man schon auch erstmal wegcrypten.
Das muss schnell gehen.
Und vor allen Dingen der Random Access ist doch dann auch nicht falsch.
Weißt du, in welchen Prozessoren das drin ist, diese AES-Crypto?
Na Huckel meint gerade bei seinem Core i auch schon, also bei allen Cores, oder wie nehme ich an?
Auch bei Core 2 Duo?
Ich glaube es ist seitdem i...
Das heißt AES-NI, New Instructions, muss man einfach mal kurz googlern. Und dann wissen wir das ja sofort.
AES-NI.
Also ich bilde mir zumindest ein, dass die i7 auch... Genau, Westmere-based Prozessors. Und Westmere ist ja glaube ich das, was ich hier habe. i3, i5...
Proposed by Internet in March 2008, also die Core 2 gab es ja schon vorher.
Was ist denn...
Gullfdown, Clarkdale, Arendale, also Core i3, Core i3, Core i5...
Core i7 auch.
Sandy Bridge haben es auch alle.
Die Xeons.
Und bei AMD haben die Bulldozer das. Die haben wir jetzt ja zwar nicht, aber die haben es sozusagen auch.
Genau.
Also Core 2 hat es nicht.
Das sieht so aus, ja.
Okay, weil ich hatte eine Sekunde überlegt, ob der Grund, dass Lion nur noch für Core 2 Prozessoren ist, vielleicht daran liegt, aber...
Warte noch mal, was?
Lion ist ja nur für Core 2 Prozessoren und aufwärts.
Korrekt. Angeblich der Core Duo tut es nicht mehr. Weil wohl kein 64-Bit, kann ich aber nicht bestätigen, weil auf meinem Laptop habe ich gehört, ist der Kernel auch nur im 32-Bit-Modus.
Ja, und auch auf einem schwarzen MacBook habe ich es auch mal gesehen.
Schade eigentlich.
Aber wir können ja mal noch... Also ich meine, es fing ja schon mal an damit, also wir haben ja die Notebooks announced und dann kam es ja gleich so in der Sidenote, oh, hier neue Beta, irgendwie ist im Twitter durchgescrollt. Dann war ja erstmal so der erste Aha-Moment, dass das über ein Mac App Store zu beziehen war und nicht mehr wie sonst über das Developer Center und dann irgendwie komische Downloads, sondern du hast dann einen Promo-Code für den Mac App Store bekommen, den rein gehackselt und dann so einen Self-Content und nur 3,4 Gigabyte großen Installer gekriegt, was ja ungefähr die Hälfte ist von dem, wie groß die Installer aktuell sind. Die passen ja gerade so auf eine Double Layer DVD. Und dann hast du dir das Ding darunter geladen und so mit einem Doppelklick kam dann gleich so ein Installer hoch, der dich dann irgendwie eine Disc aussuchen hat lassen. Und ich hatte ja irgendwie das ausprobiert mit einer externen Platte. So und dann irgendwie gesagt, ja dann mach mal hier auf die externe Platte. Dann hat er da irgendwie gesagt, Prepare Disc und gleich neu gestartet. Und dann irgendwie installiert. So und dann hat man sich natürlich gefragt, ok von wo hat er denn jetzt neu gestartet? Genau, hat er jetzt schon von der neuen Platte gestartet. Aber in der kurzen Zeit kann er nicht die ganzen Daten rüber geschaufelt haben.
Aber ein bisschen was hat er ja schon geschaufelt.
Ein bisschen was hat er schon geschaufelt. Und ich hab halt dann nochmal so ein paar andere Installations-Setups gemacht die nächsten Tage. Und hatte halt zum Beispiel eine Platte mit Lion drauf, extern, davon gebootet. So ein Notebook hab, externe Platte mit Lion drauf, gebootet. Auf dieser externen Platte lag auch der Lion Installer nochmal drauf. Den gestartet und auf die Platte im Rechner sozusagen installiert. Kann man mir folgen? So und dann hat er halt auch Prepare Disk gemacht, hat Rebooted und hat währenddessen von der externen Platte die ganze Zeit irgendwie Daten geschaufelt. Also die LED von der externen Platte hat die ganze Zeit irgendwie rataratarataratarata gemacht. Was dann vielleicht auch bedeutet, dass er irgendwie erstmal so diese Recovery Partition auf der Zielplatte anlegt. Davon vielleicht so das Note Installer OS bootet und dann aber die Daten noch von der anderen Platte holt, wo der Installer lag.
Oder eine RAM-Disc.
Oder eine RAM-Disc oder was auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, muss ich ja sagen, war das so die charmanteste OS X Installation. Also ich hab ja wie gesagt verschiedenste Setups und Szenarien so gehabt und es hat irgendwie alles funktioniert.
Das kam mir eigentlich total merkwürdig vor.
Da gibt es jetzt hier diese Rescue Partition, die ist ja 780 Gig groß oder irgendwie so? Und vielleicht schaufelt er da irgendwie was drauf, merkt sich, wo er seinen Installer zu liegen hat und bootet dann von dem und holt sich dann seinen Installerkram.
Ich hab wie nicht eine vollständige Installation drauf, sondern es ist eigentlich nur so ein Reparaturding. Es ist nichts, von dem du neu installieren könntest.
Genau, das hatte ich nämlich auch mal probiert.
Hast du schon mal reingeboten, das Rescue-Ding?
Ja, und wenn du dann sagst install, sag da äh, äh. Also es hat nicht, also ich dachte ja, das könnte man vielleicht...
Was kann man denn machen mit dem Rescue?
Nee, er bietet dir das als Option an, aber wenn du es halt anklickst, dann macht er äh, äh. Also es kann sein, dass es halt Beta ist und einfach noch nicht geht. Ähm, oder dass sie, ja, also ich, ich würde es mal auf Beta schieben. Also es gab die Option, mach mal hier, installier mal neu. Äh, aber wie gesagt, weil ohne weitere Erklärung hat es einfach gesagt, ne. Naja, und dann hat er ja irgendwie installiert und auch das Installieren ging recht flott und ich hab's ja jetzt nun auf rotierende Platten installiert und nicht auf eine SSD, sondern nur so auf alte Technologie. Und das ging auch erstaunlich fluffig von der Hand. Man kann jetzt halt auch noch bei dem Installer gleich am Anfang sagen, Customize. Das war's.
Das kam mir gerade so in den Browser.
Kannst ja beim Installieren jetzt auch gleich am Anfang sagen, dass du diese Server-Tools haben willst, ne. Habt ihr das eigentlich mal angeklickt schon? Kommt da halt mit genau diesem, also fast so mit diesem Setup hoch, wie früher das OS X Server sich installieren ließ, wo man dann plötzlich auch ganz viel mehr Angaben machen musste über allen möglichen Kram. Okay, und wenn man das nicht gemacht hat, hat er halt einfach so fluffig installiert und dann saßen wir so vom Rechner so, Full Disk Encryption? So, irgendwie erstmal gleich iPhone raus, Foto gemacht. Vor es weg ist. Weil es gab ja nun schon ein paar Leute, die darüber geblockt hatten, niemand hatte ein Wort darüber, weil ich das sehe und dachte mir, what the fuck?
Das hat mich auch total gewundert und es war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht auf der Webseite. Einen Tag später haben sie es dann erst nachgeschoben.
Wir hoffen, dass es nicht cancelen wie bei ZFS.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist schon integriert genug. Na ja, ZFS war nicht im Installer.
Im Installer nicht, aber es war schon deutlich und viel dabei.
Na ja, das werden wir jetzt schon drin lassen. Aber ja, es war halt krass. Dann klickt man das an und kriegt seinen Revocation Key. So, wie man das eigentlich auch von anderen Systemen gewohnt ist. Nein, Recovery Key. Und dann noch diese spaßige Option, dass man diesen Key auch bei Apple storen könne, der dann auch noch verschlüsselt abgelegt wurde.
Hier total geheim und so. Kannst du bei Apple speichern.
Ja ne, aber ich mein es macht halt auch insofern Sinn. Let's find my iPhone und Remote-Wipe. Und wenn du dann halt irgendwie den Mac verbummelt hast und du gehst dann einfach auf die Webseite und sagst ja hier, wenn der irgendwann mal wieder online geht und so, dann kill einfach mal das Volume. Oder was auch immer. Irgendwie vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Ich mach's nicht, aber...
Der war schon voll in Lion eingestiegen.
Es gibt bestimmt Szenarien so. Und dann hat er das so installiert und hat auch gar nicht groß weiter rumgetan, dann bootet er das und ha! Nach all den Jahren durften wir es erleben, diese Animation am Anfang, dieses... Weißt du, mit dem Space-Flug und so. Das kann man jetzt mit Escape abbrechen.
Ah, jetzt doch?
Ja, man muss es nicht mehr vertragen. Man kann jetzt Escape drücken.
Kenn ich schon.
Echt?
Skip, skip, skip.
Aber es ging meist no-lappert nicht?
Nein, ich meinte, Escape drücken ist dieses... Ja, kenn ich schon. Skip, skip, skip.
Mach weiter.
Escape ist nur, weil es ein Beta-Bild ist oder ein Debug-Bild und dann im Final geht es ja nicht.
Dann werden wir uns das wieder fest, ja. Kann sein.
Aber sie könnten doch schon langsamer wechseln, ey.
Naja, auf jeden Fall. Und dann war es ja gebootet. Und dann hat man von dieser Full-Description gar nichts mitbekommen, erst mal so. Außer man klickt auf die Security Preferences und sieht dann so ein Progress Bar, wo er dann so on the fly im Hintergrund... Also er bootet ja dann nochmal neu, nachdem du es angeschaltet hast. Und dann geht es aber auch gleich im Hintergrund weiter. Also es war echt so eine super silky smooth...
Du bist auf die Tatsache, dass er nie fertig wird.
Doch, bei mir ist er fertig geworden.
Bei mir zeigt er an, er ist noch dabei, aber er ist nicht mehr dabei. Ich weiß nicht, was der da macht.
Also ja, ich kann das nur bestätigen. Bei mir wäre das genauso. Und dass das überhaupt so im Hintergrund geht, fand ich schon mal ganz cool.
Das ist aber wohl, also die Linuxer im Club waren total unbeeindruckt davon. Das ist bei dem Ubuntu schon seit...
Ewigkeiten drin.
Ja, das glaube ich auch so.
Ja, das war auch definitiv immer ein Vorteil der Linux-Plattform, dass da einfach Full-Disk-Encryption einfach mal...
Im Installer drin war, ja...
.möglich war und war auch echt ein guter Grund, Linux zu fahren, wenn man darauf angewiesen war, Full-Disk-Encryption zu haben. Was ich auch noch ganz nett fand, ist, dass... Ist jetzt auch nicht so besonders überraschend, aber so wie sie es gemacht haben, ist es ganz okay gelöst, finde ich. Du kannst halt... Ich meine, was das bedeutet ist, das Ding schaltest du ein und bevor das OS gebootet wird, kommt schon so dieser Dialog hoch. Das heißt, sie haben es geschafft, in die Firmware auch diese ganze User-Interface-Optik von Lion irgendwie reinzukriegen.
Außer, wenn du das Sprachenfenster aufklappst, dann fehlen die Schatten und so. Dann ist es so ein bisschen, man sieht auch, wie das so reinpinselt so langsam.
Naja, wahrscheinlich haben sie auf das eine oder andere schon verzichten müssen und sie wahrscheinlich gegenseitig die Zähne eingeschlagen darüber, was sie nun wechsleißen dürfen und was nicht.
Wobei, Apple hat ja auch bei dem Snow Lab schon immer so eine 200 MB Partition. Da kann man ja schon auch eine Menge an Zeug noch reinklatschen, irgendwie an Programmen.
Ja klar, aber das ist natürlich von der Abtraktion her so eine Sache, wenn du das Betriebssystem auf, was zahlreiche Subsysteme bereitstellt, damit dieser Scheiß einfach so aussieht, wie er aussieht, wenn das alles nicht da ist. Was nimmst du da quasi manuell und statisch linkend in so einen Teil rein? Na gut, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, man merkt es irgendwie gar nicht. Also ich hab mich da so eingeloggt und danach kam irgendwie der Apfel. Da hat man mir so, Apfel? Ah, ja, er bootet jetzt erst so. Und bei SSD merkt man das ja auch nicht. Das bootet ja auch sonst so schnell. Aber jetzt geht es halt noch fixer. Und du kannst dann eben auch nachträglich andere User enablen, dass sie eben auch diese Disk-Encryption auflösen können. Also, dass die dann auch sozusagen mit ihrem Passwort diesen Key anlocken. Was auch wiederum heißt, du kannst dein System so einrichten, dass du das anlocken kannst. Und wenn das System läuft, dann gibt es halt auch noch andere User. Aber diese anderen User können eben nicht deine Disk-Encryption umgehen, wenn du das nicht möchtest. Und das ist natürlich auch schon mal ganz fein. Was ich schade finde, womit ich aber auch nicht auch nur eine Sekunde gerechnet habe, dass sie es einbauen, ist, dass du halt keine alternative Realität machen kannst, dass du da nicht noch ein zweites Passwort hast, wo sich dann eben dein Windows 98 hochfährt und du an der Grenze sagen kannst, ja hier sind meine geheimen Daten, bitteschön. Du kannst dich gerne in eine Kopie machen, ich habe nichts zu verbergen. Also wenn sie dir die Knarre an den Kopf halten und du dein Passwort rausrückst, dann bist du halt noch ein Stück weiter mit deiner Full Disk-Encryption.
Ja, aber es ist ja...
Man kann aber alle Partitionen... Du machst so ein Dual-Partition-Setup, dann kannst du deine OS ohne Krypto machen und so eine zweite Partition könntest du mit Passwort versehen. Und du kannst auch Sticks mit so Encryption versehen. Und in dem Augenblick, wo du sie reinsteckst, poppt ein Fenster auf und dann musst du erstmal dein Passwort eingeben.
Aber dann würde man immer noch sehen können, dass es auch noch eine zweite Partition gibt, von der man auch booten kann, wo er auch nach dem Passwort fragt.
Andererseits könnte man auch sagen, wenn du so eine Sicherheitsanforderung hast, dann ist vielleicht der Mac sowieso jetzt erstmal nicht deine primäre Wahl. Oder du hast dann sowieso ein ganz anderes Setup am Start, wenn du so ein Security hast.
Aber warum dürfen Apple User nicht auch einen Aluminium Hood tragen?
Und wenn du am Flughafen stehst und du musst da dein Passwort eintippen, weil du die Pistole am Kopf hast, also von der abstrakten Situation mal abgesehen, dann sollte man seine Geheimdaten sowieso nicht im Laptop haben, sondern auf einem Extra-Datenträger.
Der in irgendeiner Körperöffnung steckt und nicht so leicht zu detektieren ist. Naja, also das war auf jeden Fall so der erste große Löwen-Aha-Moment-Installer. Fyne Fyne irgendwie aus dem Mac App Store mit Full-Disc-Encryption.
Ja, mit Krypto, Fyne Fyne und dann Fyne da benutzt, überhaupt alles benutzt auf dem System, von einer externen Platte über einen beschissenen USB-Controller und es flutschte wie Sau. Während der Encryption im Hintergrund macht und während das Spotlight gleichzeitig läuft. Und du machst den Fyne auf und es war jetzt nicht so ultra schnell, weil war ja auch keine SSD, aber die Eigens, die kamen so rein. Also hat sich da nicht groß stören lassen von den ganzen anderen Jobs.
Das stimmt auch. Ich meine, bei frischen Installationen bin ich immer so ein bisschen skeptisch. Frische Installationen sind immer schnell. Und die Frage ist halt, wie schnell tritt sich das fest. Von daher, aber trotzdem war auch mein Eindruck, dass der Flutschfaktor irgendwie...
Und das ganze Internet ist von diesem Eindruck überzeugt, dass Flutsch einfach dieser Feinde da bringt. Weiß ich nicht, was die da gemacht haben.
Das ganze Internet.
Also alle, die berichten, sagen Snappy, Snappy, Snappy.
Ja, aber das sagen sie bei jedem OSP.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Aber nicht so viel.
Der Flutsch-Faktor ist größer als bisher.
Na ja, schon irgendwie. Also es hat sich einfach alles schon sehr fluffig geklickt.
Ich frag mich, was der Grund dafür ist.
Na, vielleicht haben sie jetzt hier Grand Central Dispatch einfach in jeden kleinen Klik-Button eingebaut.
Das könnte es bedeuten.
Wollen wir hoffen.
Könnte es wirklich bedeuten. Vielleicht ist ja auch Core 2 Duo deshalb die Mindestanforderung, damit sie auf jeden Fall zwei Cores haben.
Könnte sein, weil sie jetzt alles auf Multi ausgelegt haben.
Ich meine, beim Core Duo hätten sie das auch.
Aber eigentlich kann das nicht der Grund sein, weil sie haben gesagt, dieses Grand Central, dem ist es total egal, ob du ein oder zwei zählt. Der skaliert das alles von alleine, weil es ist ja auch logisch, weil der muss jetzt automatisch auch vier können und demnächst dann noch acht und halb.
Ich freu mich nur die ganze Zeit, was ist in diesen Core Duo und Core Solo-Maschinen denn nun so eklatant anders, dass sie das loswerden wollen, dass sie das nicht mehr supporten wollen. Es ist jetzt einfach nur, dass sie sagen, das ist jetzt so und so alt und das supporten wir einfach nicht mehr.
Der Core Duo ohne zwei war ja auch schon zwei Cores los, ja nicht? Aber er hat halt keine 64-Bit. Aber er bootet ja trotzdem bei mir, der kernel ist immer noch 32. Also kommt nicht im 64-Bit-Motor.
Genau, das Lion nutzt nicht überall.
Wie war das bei dir eigentlich?
Er hat keine 64-Bit.
Kernel stand so richtig da, ja?
Okay.
Auf welchem? Auf dem 17-Zoller? Ah ja, und das No-Lap-Bot aber nicht?
Das No-Lap-Bot, das einzige, wo das No-Lap-Bot im 64-Bit-Modus läuft, ist ja auf den Desktop-Maschinen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Ich glaube, das war dieses Server, ne?
Ja, doch, den Mac Pros.
Ich sag nicht Desktop, wenn du Mac Pro meinst.
Das ist Under Desktop.
Under Desktop.
Mainframe.
Mainframe. Workstation.
Big Iron.
Die Schwitzbank.
Big Alu. Ja, und was ich halt auch super finde an Full Disk Encryption, also was, würde ich sagen, der größte Relief ist, der da mit einherkommt, abgesehen davon, dass halt alles verschlüsselt ist, ist, dass es jetzt nicht mehr diese bekloppte Einschränkung mit Time Machine gibt. Weil der beste Grund, Disk Encryption mit Fallwolt nicht zu benutzen, war halt Time Machine nutzen zu wollen. Ich muss sagen, im Zweifelsfall ist mir halt Time Machine dann irgendwie lieber gewesen als Krypto. Ist halt total schizophrenen, weil eigentlich ist einem beides wichtig und Krypto ist eigentlich auch toll und wichtig. Aber wenn die Daten nicht gebackupt werden, sind sie halt im Zweifelsfall weg. So und das... Time Machine hat mir so oft den Arsch gerettet, seitdem es das gibt. Stimmt jetzt schon fünf, sechs Mal. Nicht so im Sinne von alles verloren oder so, aber zumindest schon viel Arbeit, die sonst weg gewesen wäre, war dann halt nicht weg.
Hier meint jemand im Chat, dass Time Machine jetzt auch Encrypted Backups kann. Das war ja bei Time Machine mal, dass man auch diese DMGs, die da erstellt wurden auf so einem Remote-Server, also bei mir ist das ja zum Beispiel auch so eine FreeBSD-Kiste, dass man da dieses DMG da als Encrypted DMG erstellt hat. Und dann haben sie es aber wieder abgeschafft und haben es jetzt wieder eingeführt, weil ich hab mich ja gerade auch überlegt, weil bisher wird ja mein File Vault, wird ja auch das gekryptete Sparse Bundle irgendwie weggebackupt. Und wenn das jetzt aber nicht mehr so der Fall ist, dann würden ja meine Daten unverschlüsselt auf meinem Backup-Server liegen. Das heißt, jetzt können sie es dann wieder. Hast du schon probiert?
Nee, aber hab ich auch gelesen, dass das jetzt so wieder ist.
Yeah, die Welt ist gerettet. Bei mir war diese Option nicht anklickbar.
Du hast ja eine Time Capsule, da wissen wir, dass da grundsätzlich immer gar nichts geht.
Also bei dir ging das?
Ich frag da mal meinen Kumpel gerade.
So, Pause während, dann ist hier mal kurz nachgefragt.
And Crip Backup, doch, kann ich hier so ein Häkchen setzen? Ich setz einfach so ein Häkchen bei einer lokalen Platte, aber übrigens hab ich, hab ich ich gesagt? Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Naja, und dann...
Das Passwort auf dem Backup ist natürlich ein anderes als für dein Rechner selbst.
Auf jeden Fall scheint es so, als wäre da Apple mal unserer Empfehlung gefolgt, denn Full-Description haben wir auch hier schon sehr vehement gefordert.
Überhaupt. Da kommt noch so einiges von dir.
Ja, wir können jetzt mal unsere Checklist...
Die Checklist ist ganz gut abgearbeitet worden, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Was ist denn, was nehmen wir denn als nächstes zur Post?
Ja, jetzt wo wir eh schon bei Time Machine sind, müssen wir natürlich noch auf das andere Power-Feature hinweisen. Sie haben es ja wohl offensichtlich tatsächlich getan und es gibt Snapshots. Für die Leute, die nicht wissen, wovon wir reden.
Wir verweisen auf Folge. Mobile Max Folge 1 bis 60.
Naja, also Snapshots. Also es ist noch vollkommen unklar, wie das implementiert ist, aber ich vermute mal, was wir jetzt hier sehen, ist das, was wir uns, was glaube ich von allen Optionen immer noch als die wahrscheinlichste galt, nach dem ZFS wegging. Sie bauen halt schrittweise Features in HFS ein, aber uns war ja nie klar, wie weit sie gehen könnten und würden und werden. Und jetzt sieht es halt so aus, als ob sie einerseits eben Full Disk Encryption gemacht haben, was ja schonmal cool ist, aber sie haben auch Snapshots. Und das hat natürlich jetzt weitreichende Folgen. Woher weiß man, dass es Snapshots gibt? Wenn man in Time Machine, in diese Präferenz es geht, dann wählt man halt entweder ein Remote-Volume oder eben so ein Local-Volume, also eine andere Platte aus, über Netz oder eben über direkt angeschlossen. Und dann gibt es auch so eine Option, dass man eben Snapshots noch zusätzlich da auch mit... Wie rum war das?
Na du hast einmal die Option lokale Snapshots, wenn du keine...
Also wenn du kein Backup hast, dann hast du immer noch die lokalen Snapshots. Das ist sozusagen das Minimum. Aber es gab noch eine zusätzliche Option zum Anklicken mit den Snapshots. Das weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz genau. Ich glaube, wenn du was ausgewählt hast, dann kannst du das auch wieder ausschalten. Dann kannst du wieder einschalten. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gibt es Snapshots.
Stündlich allerdings, nicht selbstbestimmte.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass wenn man jetzt über die Kommandozeile mal nachschaut, dass dann unter Slash Volumes ein Mobile-Backups-Volume ist. Dennis, kannst du dir mal, das hab ich vergessen nachzugucken, kannst du mal die Major Device Numbers gucken von diesem Mobile-Backup-Volume und von deiner Platte, ob die identisch sind? Naja, so Device-Shown, Slash-Dev, Tra-La-La, also ob die Devices...
Also wenn ich hier mit dem Terminal nach Slash Volumes gehe, dann gibt es da keinen... Achso warte, ich hab das ausgeschaltet.
Also was ich glaube, hier ist how I think it works. HFS Plus hat jetzt Snapshots. Wie auch immer, wie gut die auch immer funktionieren mögen, aber gehen wir mal davon aus, sie haben halt ein Layer eingezogen, wo sie sagen können, jetzt machen wir einen Snapshot und das machen sie halt Time Machine Style jede Stunde und schmeißen die dann eben auch lokal nach diesem selben Schema weg, wie sie das bisher gemacht haben. Also du hast die letzten 24 Stunden das so stündlich und dann von dem Tag davor wird nur eins übrig behalten, aber dann eben eine Woche lang jeweils eins pro Tag und dann eben nur noch eins pro Woche und das eben so lange wie irgendwie Platz ist. Und das ist im Fallsystem eingebaut. Das ist natürlich super. Und wenn du es halt jetzt laufen hast, dann siehst du eben diese Snapshots über ein virtuelles Volume. Dieses Volumes Mobile Backups ist quasi ein virtuelles Blick auf deine Festplatte. Und dort erscheint das, das ist nämlich vom Typ her ein MTMFS. Was ich mal frei übersetze mit Mobile Time Machine File System. Das ist sozusagen ein View auf dein HFS Plus oder wie auch immer das jetzt heißt, HFS Plus Plus. Was quasi diese Snapshots in eine Time Machine ähnliche Darstellung bringt. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt wirklich so einen Backups-Folder da haben, sondern nur, dass dieses virtuelle Volumes Mobile Backups quasi so ein Tree erzeugt aus diesen Snapshots. Und dann ist es eben so, als wenn du auf so ein Time Machine Backup draufschaust mit irgendwie im Top Level hast du halt ein Backups-Verzeichnis und darunter hast du dann eben für jeden Snapshot ein Ordner mit Datum, Uhrzeit etc.
Aber meinst du denn, dass es dann jetzt sozusagen wirklich Pfeilsystem ist oder sind es immer noch Hardlinks wie bei Time Machine letztendlich?
Nein, ich glaube, dass das im Pfeilsystem drin ist. Also ich meine, Hardlinks, ich bezweifle stark, dass sie das auf Pfeilbasis machen, weil das wäre einfach extrem ineffizient. Ich meine, was ist, wenn du da deine Gigabyte-Datei jede Stunde änderst, dann ist deine Platte, also das kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen. Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht ist es so und dann bin ich schockiert und schüttel den Kopf. Aber ich meine, wenn man sowas reinbaut, dann macht man das doch irgendwie auf Block-Lib-Ebene, oder? Ich kann mir das irgendwie nicht vorstellen. Vielleicht fährt es jetzt auch meine Vorstellungen einfach nicht aus.
Ich meine, sie haben ja auch ein File-System-Engineer geheiert und so, der wird ja auch den mal ordentlich ins Gewissen gehustet haben, dass jetzt mal das mit den Hartlings ganz lustig war, aber dass man das vielleicht schon mal richtig machen müsste.
Also auf jeden Fall ist das sehr vielversprechend und das bedeutet, du hast auch, wenn du eben nicht mit deiner Time-Capsule oder mit deinem Backup-Device zu Hause verbunden bist, du hast halt deine Backups lokal auf deiner Platte. Du kannst immer zurückgehen, wie war es vor einer Stunde, wie war es gestern.
Wenn du genug Platz hast.
Wenn du noch genug Platz hast, aber ich würde sagen, wenn sie blockorientiert arbeiten, dann ist das eigentlich kein Thema. Es sei denn, du hast halt eine Platte, auf der sich permanent unglaublich viel ändert.
Machen sie nicht?
Nein, aber blockorientiert können die ja bisher noch nicht.
Wieso sollten sie das nicht können?
Weiß ich noch nichts von.
Wir wissen von all dem noch nichts. Das ist jetzt in die Wolke hineingeraten.
ZFS konnte das, bei HFS gab es das erstmal nicht, bei dem Time Machine blockmäßig.
Ja, und ich weiß auch nicht, ob sie CheXum haben. Aber es könnte sein, dass sie das eingebaut haben. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne schwierig, ein Fallsystem zu machen, was das kann. Die Frage ist, kann man einen Lion HFS auf einem Snow Leopard HFS problemlos mounten?
Also die unencryptete Variante, ja.
Das hast du auch schon ausprobiert. Ja, ein kryptetes.
Aber die Optionen für was anderes gibt es nicht.
Aber diese Snapshots sind dann sozusagen irgendwie da drüber gestülpt, sodass du die dann eben nicht siehst.
Die Snapshots gab es doch schon so ein Bild. Das ist auch wieder so links und so, wie bei Time Machine, so ein Ordner mit der ganzen Struktur.
Ja, aber das ist ein View da drauf. Das ist ein View auf diese interne Struktur. Aber intern ist das unter Garantie nicht so gelöst. Was heißt unter Garantie? Ich glaube nicht, dass das so gelöst ist.
Na, wie denn dann?
Das ist halt ein teilsysteminternes Feature und dieses MTM-Effekt ist halt einfach ein View. Ja, meine ich.
Glaube ich nicht.
Glaubst du nicht. Ja, aber dann müsste das ja ein separates Fallsystem sein. Dann müssten sie ja da in einen anderen Bereich was reinkopieren und das kann ja wohl nie sein.
Das kann ich mir ja eigentlich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie das ernsthaft als Weg jetzt beschreiten. Also weil dann wird deine Platte ja wirklich im Nu voll. Du müsstest ja ein Fullbackup in einem anderen Volume haben.
Ihr seid doch nur ängstlich, weil ihr so kleine SSD habt.
Ich nicht. Selbst wenn du eine 750 GB Platte voll mit Daten hast, willst du kein Fullbackup irgendwie einmal machen müssen, um dann mit Hardlinks drauf zu popeln? Nee, also wirklich.
Also es wird sich hoffentlich demnächst auch klären. Weil irgendwie muss das ja dokumentiert werden. Spätestens wenn es release ist und das Zeug irgendwie als Open Source kommt.
Naja, das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem, weil Mac OS und Command Line Tools von Apple, da kennt man sich auch überhaupt nicht so richtig aus, was es da alles so gibt und was die alles so können, wo man jetzt mal nachkunden könnte, was mit dem Half S Plus eigentlich los ist und so. Was gibt es da, das HID Util oder HDD Util? Und dann wäre es ja eigentlich ganz cool, weil in Time Machine steht ja jetzt drin, dass es stündliche Backups macht, wenn es halt auch ein Command Line Tool gäbe, um manuell so einen Snapshot zu triggern. Das wäre ja nur auch nochmal echt ein Highlight. Weil manchmal ist man ja eben genau in diesem Moment, ok, ich installiere jetzt diese Applikation und ich weiß, sie wird scheiße sein und ich weiß, sie wird irgendwie dreck installiert, aber ich brauche sie jetzt mal 5 Minuten.
Und ich will nicht 59 Minuten warten.
Genau.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich schätze mal, das müsste eigentlich drin sein. Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt, aber ich kann mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass man das nicht forsten kann.
Test, Test. Oh, mein Steve-Kanal funktioniert nicht.
Mach nochmal.
Test, Test.
Mein Steve-Kanal funktioniert nicht.
Das ist die falsche vielleicht.
Vielleicht ist es die falsche. Ich bin an 2 jetzt hier gerade.
2 ist die falsche, du bist die 3.
Also wir sind halt echt so unspontan. Wir müssen vorher unsere tollen Gadgets alle auspacken.
Ja, heute war ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Start.
Also die Tasse geht.
Test, test. Da, wir haben eine Verbindung. Wir haben ein Amt. Steve, bitte mach das richtig hier mit den Snapshots.
Steve, enttäusche uns nicht.
Aber es ist doch schon gemacht.
Ja, aber wir wissen nicht wie. Du weißt ja nicht, ob es Tartlings sind.
Aber da gibt es doch diese Seite, da steht es doch alles.
Welche Seite? Ja, hol mal raus jetzt hier.
Die nackten Tatsachen.
Wir wollen unsere Hörer hier nicht im Unklaren lassen.
Schlag du das mal nach, dann können wir hier nochmal ein paar andere Sachen nachschlagen. Es gibt ja auch noch ein paar interessante... Auch ein paar interessante Wecklassungen. Oder bleiben wir erstmal bei diesen Chore-Features vielleicht. Wo wir jetzt so viel über Platten und so weiter geredet haben, sollten wir vielleicht nochmal die Sache mit diesem Trim-Support machen. Also es wird gemunkelt, dass jetzt auch Trim-Support mit dabei ist.
Ja, ist dabei. Kann man sehen, wenn man den System Profiler aufruft, da ist dann bei Zata irgendwie kommt so eine Zeile, irgendwie Trim-Support, Doppelpunkt, yes!
Hast du die Diskussion noch im Kopf? Also du hast ja irgendwann selber mal berichtet von dieser Garbage-Collection-Geschichte und dann saß man ja ganz so viel Sand und meinten, naja, dann brauchen wir das ja nicht mehr. Dann kam später irgendjemand nochmal mit irgendeiner Argumentation hoch, die total Sinn machte, dass man das trotzdem braucht. Aber ich krieg das nicht mehr zusammen. Warum? Es gab irgendeinen Grund, dass das effizienter sei oder...
Und einer im Chat meint auch noch Trim ist allerdings auch nur bei Apple SSDs. Das wäre natürlich besonders bitter für...
Mit Third Party.
Du Scheiße.
Da hörst du keine Backups dann.
Wieso nicht?
Na, weil nix drauf passt. Ist doch mal voll bei dir oder nicht?
Ich hab noch 300 GIG frei.
Na gut, das muss auch nicht unbedingt so bleiben.
Du wirst deinen Rechner wohl nicht.
Das muss ja nicht so bleiben.
Aber jetzt zu den SSDs hab ich noch eine News. Ist jetzt ein bisschen nicht ganz apple-mäßig, aber wir wollen ja auch ein bisschen mal so Technikwissen einstreuen. Und zwar gibt es da so ein Paper, kann ich auch gleich noch mal raussuchen, damit wir das dann später irgendwie auf unserer Seite verlinken können. Da sind so ein paar Leute, die sich angucken, wie denn Forensics irgendwie, die Forensiker, sich SSDs angucken. Also es ist ja so, die kommen zu dir nach Hause, nehmen irgendwie dein Rechner mit und da ist dann deine SSD drauf und die wollen irgendwie an deine Daten ran.
Und lassen dich gefesselt und geknibelt zurück.
Oder nehmen dich gefesselt und geknibelt mit. Genau, setze die Pistole an die Brust, damit du auch erst mal das Passwort rausrückst. Jedenfalls schließen sie die SSDs dann an Geräte, die so einen Write-Blocker drin haben, dass es nicht mehr gelöscht werden kann. Also wahrscheinlich im gleichen Rechner, weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau. Ich habe das Paper noch nicht komplett durchgelesen. Aber was passieren kann, ist, dass wenn du weißt, da die Polizei klopft an deiner Tür oder wer auch immer, dass du schnell noch so ein Quick-Format auf deine Platte absetzt. Und dann ist es ja so, bei einer 750 Gigabyte Platte, bevor die alles gelöscht hat, das geht einfach nicht. Da müsstest du die Bullen erst mal eine Stunde vor der Tür stehen lassen. Das klappt alles nicht. Oder länger, genau. Und das heißt, wenn die dann deine Platte einkassieren können, die alle Blöcke noch lesen. Ob du dann Quick-Delete abgesetzt hast oder nicht, ist egal, weil die Platte kann nicht so schnell löschen. Da wird es dann gehen, ja. Aber wir reden ja jetzt noch von Leuten, die das irgendwie nicht haben. So und bei SSDs, da ist es so, dass dieser Quick-Format, der abgesetzt wird, und die haben gedacht, dass halt irgendwann auch durch dieses Trim, weil eigentlich ist es ja ein Bitte-alles-Trim-Kommando, so ein Quick-Format, dass das irgendwie ziemlich lange braucht, bis die Platte dann diese SSD mal so loslegt. Aber sie haben festgestellt, dass schon nach 3 Minuten 80-90% von so einer SSD gelöscht sind. Das heißt, die Forensiker haben gerade voll ein Problem, bei Leuten, die eine SSD haben und schnell ein Quick-Format gemacht haben, noch an die Daten ranzukommen. Und sie waren da sehr erstaunt. Weil sie dachten, es dauert viel, viel länger, bevor die Platte da loslegt mit ihren internen Algorithmen, um dann die Blöcke als leer irgendwie vorzubereiten. Weil eigentlich hat sie ja ein bisschen Zeit so. Aber die legt halt schon sofort los, wenn sie nichts zu tun hat. Also brauchst du sie nur an Strom ranmachen, und dann fängt die schon an. Also ohne Kommandos, ohne Rechner, weil sie braucht ja dafür nichts, sie macht das ja mit ihrer eigenen Logik. Also Jungs, wisst ihr Bescheid, ne? Zum Beispiel.
Und von Discontcription anschalten.
Oder so, oder beides. Ist ja sowieso bei SSDs noch mal schwerer, weil bei einer Platte hast du, wenn du einen Block 100 schreibst, schreibst du einen Block 100, und wenn du zehn Jahre später Block 100 ausliest, dann liest du Block 100 aus. Bei so einer SSD ist das ja irgendwie nicht so klar, weil die dann noch so ein Layer dazwischen haben, weil die müssen ja dieses Real Leveling machen, dass sich die Blöcke halt immer wieder neu verteilen. Und dann ist Block 100 später physikal nicht mehr Block 100, sondern vielleicht liegt er dann an einer ganz anderen Stelle. Und von jemandem, der so Plattenreparaturen macht, habe ich auch gestern erst war das, oder vorgestern war es, gehört, dass diese Tabelle vergessen SSDs manchmal. Und dann ist eigentlich fast alles verloren, weil du weißt nicht mehr, welcher Block wo ist, weil die sind ja nicht durchnummeriert. Also auch bei den Festplatten, weil Block 100 immer Block 100 war, haben sie nicht dazugeschrieben. Wenn sie diesen Block schreiben, dass es jetzt eigentlich der Inhalt von Block 100 ist, weil es weißt du ja dadurch, dass du ihn von dort liest. Bei einer SSD kann der aber sonst wohl irgendwann im Flash landen. Und wenn du diese Tabelle hast, wo dieser Block jetzt liegt, weißt du nicht mehr, was der Inhalt von den ganzen Blöcken ist, weil es steht ja nicht dabei. Das heißt, wenn die File System Designer heutzutage neue File Systems entwickeln, vielleicht sollten die dann diese Informationen, diese 8 Bytes, die sie dafür brauchen, auch noch mal irgendwie mit verschwenden, dass sie noch reinschreiben, welcher Block das denn gerade ist. Weißte das in Zukunft nicht mehr so klar, mit diesen ganzen Metaebenen, da kommen ja bestimmt noch ein paar dazu.
Damit die Forensiker es einfacher haben, meinst du.
Ja und auch die Datenretter.
Datenretter.
Ich weiß nicht, Datenretter, also ich find das irgendwie, weißt du nicht, Daten retten, da muss man eher einfach bessere Backup-Systeme haben. Ich find das ja irgendwie cool, dass man Daten auch gut los wird. Es gibt ja auch dieses Gerücht, dass es bei Mobile Me demnächst auch so ein Find-My-Mac gibt. Auch eine unserer Forderungen. Hier aus den letzten Sendungen. Also ich hab das zum Beispiel gefordert. Scheint also jetzt auch zu kommen, und es wird ja auch total Sinn machen, dass du erstens dein Laptop findest im Klau-Fall und dann eben auch noch vielleicht die Möglichkeit hast, eben Remote Vibe zu machen. Ohne 3G ist das natürlich bei den Teilen so eine Sache, aber im Prinzip könnte das halt helfen.
Ja, surf mal dahin bitte.
Stell dir mal vor, die Bullen kommen bei dir irgendwie rein und tragen deine Karre weg und während die irgendwie... Meine Karre? Deine, Entschuldigung, deine Maschine, dein Gerät. Ja, und dann hast du einfach, sagst du einfach Remote Vibe und dann löscht du irgendwie deine Full-Desk-Encryption, wirft den Key weg.
Ich hatte keinen Remote Vibe, ich hatte halt File Vault. Ja, bei Lion siehst du aus, als wenn da, wenn man ein Zertifikat hat, was irgendwie Self-Signed ist, das ist jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen, ja, raus damit. ein bisschen höher. Wenn es ein selbstsigniertes Zertifikat ist, dann nimmt dieses Lion nicht und zeigt erstmal grundsätzlich gar nichts mehr an. Der Safari, ja.
Du hast auch redest jetzt vom Browser.
Safari Lion, genau.
Das ist aber noch voll bei Fallsystem, mein Freund.
Ja, aber das musste jetzt grad mal schnell los werden, weil es ist ganz schön fies, weil ich kann jetzt hier eine bestimmte Seite nicht ansurfen.
Und recherchieren, wo drin steht, ob Time Machine, Hardlinks benutzt oder nicht. Sucht auch hier auf meinem Rechner hier mal.
Na ist ja ganz easy.
Ach du meinst dir, man kann nicht mit die Checkbox klicken, dass man das trotzdem akzeptieren will?
Genau, die Seite kommt einfach gar nicht.
Genau. Safari can't open the page.
The certificate for this server is invalid. You might be connecting to a server that is pretending to be die Seite, wo ich hin will, which could put your confidential information at risk. Was ja auch stimmt, weil es ja self-signed ist. Jeder kann sich seine Domain selbst signieren und verschlüsseln. Das heißt, die wollen das noch ein bisschen...
Der sagt jetzt, es ist invalid. Also das ist noch ein Unterschied zwischen irgendwie not trusted.
Ja, aber es ist ja valid anscheinend, weil dir geht's ja.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber eigentlich ist da immer noch so ein Unterschied zwischen... Okay, ich trust aber auch dem CA-Z. Eigentlich ist immer noch ein Unterschied zwischen self signed und so richtig invalid, wenn der Common Name nämlich in so einem Zertifikat nicht mit dem Hosten übereinstimmt.
Können sie eigentlich nicht beibehalten?
Nee, das ist bestimmt auch noch beta.
Ich hoffe. Es war aber schon immer bei diesen Safari schon ein Problem mit diesem scheiß Zert und wie man ihn nun importet und nicht. Dabei hätte ich doch gerne diesen einen Haken, I trust this guy, so importiere mir diesen scheiß Zert und wenn was von dem kommt, dann ist das schon okay. Aber nee, machen sie nicht. Und das ging auch schon ganz oft früher an dich.
Ja, dann hast du halt always trust geklickt und beim nächsten Mal kann man noch mal hoch und dann musstest du mit alt gedrückt das Zertifikat auf dem Desktop ziehen.
Wobei es nur ein Labatt ist, ist das okay. Also da hab ich irgendwie kein Problem mit.
Hat dich auch schon ein Problem mit. Und dieser Keychain Certificate Assistant ist auch immer noch ein Major Pain in the Ass, wenn man...
Ja, es liegt einfach daran, dass dieses ganze Zert-System ist einfach ein Pain in the Ass. Das ganze SSL, Tra-La-La-Zertifikat, X509, Mumpitz, das funktioniert einfach hinten und vorne nicht und das muss sich ändern, das wird sich auch ändern, aber es dauert noch ein bisschen.
Noch 10 Jahre?
Naja, ich mein, jetzt gibt's DNS-Sack, da wird das Problem dann......woandershin ausgelagert. Ja, ich mein, dann kannst du dir...
Hast du denn nicht den Vortrag von dem... von dem DJ B auf dem Kongress angehört?
Nö, aber ich hab auf jeden Fall den Disput, den er dann mit Dan Kaminski über Twitter da ausgefochten hat, irgendwie, dass er hat, den Kaminski der Meinung ist, dass er ja nur Quatsch erzählt. Das wär er das gar nicht so verfolgt.
Und?
Das war wirklich high-level, high-tech-Talk, wo mein Basiswissen nicht ausgereicht hat...
High-tech-Boxing, ja. Und du konntest nicht mithalten, wer die besseren Moves hatte.
Genau.
Verstehe.
Jetzt, ich hab dir gerade dieses Bild gepastet von Dennis, wo dann diese Filesystemstruktur von Time Machine, von den Local Snapshots angeblich abgebildet ist.
Wobei der Tim mehr sagt, das wäre nur ein View aus Filesystem, das muss unten drunter alles gar nicht so sein. Was schon auch sein könnte, aber ich denke mal, die haben da echt wirklich Plain Shit gemacht. Nach dem Motto...
Was ist das?
Storage-Menge ist uns doch egal.
Ich meine, was ist das jetzt genau?
Wir hatten noch geredet über, wie diese Snapshots auf dem Filesystem gespeichert werden.
Du kannst da mit diesem vor und zurück, da sind mehrere Bilder.
Bist du dir sicher, dass das Snapshots sind? Das sieht mir jetzt mehr nach diesen Versions aus.
Ist doch aber nicht das gleiche. Nein, nein, das ist nicht dasselbe. Wenn du das letzte Bild in der Serie klickst, dann ist da oben Punkt Mobile Backups, Computer und so weiter. Das ist so eine Bilder-Serie. Wenn du auf das Bild draufgedetched hast, kannst du da drei Bilder hin und her scrollen. Ist da noch mal was anderes, oder wie?
Also auch im normalen Fallsystem kann man mit Punkt Mobile Backups da auch reingehen.
Hört sich fast schon wieder wie bei Punkt Z etwa an.
Und Punkt Document Revisions Version 100. Das sieht so ähnlich aus, wie sie das Album auch mit Spotlight machen. Aber interessanterweise verwenden sie hier offensichtlich SQLite für diesen ganzen Versionskram. Ja, das bringt uns zu Versions.
Ja, das nächste große Killer-Feature, was nicht von Anfang an irgendwie announced wurde. Als Steve mal hier so ein bisschen Lion gezeigt hat, da haben wir alle so gedacht, naja, das wäre ganz nett hier mit Mission Control und so.
Ach so, ja gut, das war das Langweiligste zuerst.
Na ja, aber ich meine, dafür, dass die Beta jetzt so unterm Ladentisch mal rausgeschoben wurde und eigentlich jetzt wirklich die ganzen Kracher-Features kommen.
Ja, aber ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum sie das überhaupt angekündigt haben. Also was hat das jetzt gebracht, dass sie das im Dezember angekündigt haben?
Na, dass man halt weiß, dass es weitergeht.
Ja, aber das hat sie noch nie interessiert. Also das begreife ich einfach immer noch nicht, warum. Irgendwie sahen sie da eine Notwendigkeit, diesen iPads, Macs, Kram anzukündigen?
Na, Back to Macs, sie haben halt irgendwie eine Vision wieder mal so vielleicht.
Ja, aber warum? Ich meine, wozu? Was war der Grund dafür? Was sollte das? Also das habe ich nicht verstanden. Wie auch immer, Versions ist jetzt da und ich finde das interessant, weil es ja als Teil eines größeren Ganzen zu sehen ist und das ist das, was wir hier auch häufiger gefordert haben, der persistente Desktop. Dieses, warum muss ich immer meine Dokumente selber speichern? Ich will nicht saven, ich will, dass er selber saft und das haben wir ja mehrfach beklagt. Und ich habe das jetzt nur so ein bisschen testen können, aber im Wesentlichen ist es das, wie sie es jetzt machen, das ist es, glaube ich, was ich gemeint habe. Das heißt, das Application Framework stellt jetzt die Möglichkeit zur Verfügung, dass Programme sich eben noch mehr High-Level da einklinken, sprich diese Multidocument-Metapher, der eben viele Programme folgen. Kann jetzt eben so weit gehen, dass du eben auch das Speichern komplett dem OS überlässt. Das heißt, du sagst, hier ist mein Dokument und dann hast du wahrscheinlich alle möglichen Callbacks, mit denen du da irgendwie drumherum editieren kannst. Aber das Betriebssystem ist quasi unter voller Kontrolle deiner Datei. Du schreibst die nicht mehr selber weg. Du schreibst sie vielleicht entweder lässt zu schreiben oder du überlässt zumindest die Initiative zu schreiben, den Betriebssystem, und das callt dich dann. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das API aussieht. Tatsache ist, es sichert selbst. Du kannst jetzt mit diesem Text-Edit anfangen, ein leeres Dokument zu machen, speicherst das einmal unter irgendeinem Namen weg und dann schreibst du da irgendwie und dann sagst du Reboot Computer. Das beendet sich. Er fragt dich nicht, ob du irgendwas ungesichertes noch abspeichern willst. Du hast da editiert Dokumente und Nerv und Nerv und Nerv und stundenlang und du wolltest eigentlich nur Rebooten und du wirst die ganze Zeit irgendwie genervt und gefragt. Und dann kommt dieses Teil doch tatsächlich wieder hoch. Du loggst dich ein und das Programm mit diesem nicht gesicherten Dokument in Anführungsstrichen öffnet sich genau an der Stelle wieder mit dem Programm und alles.
Und selbst wenn du es nicht initial gespeichert hast, kommt es ja dann mit an Title 47 wieder hoch.
So muss es sein. Und der eigentliche Safe-Vorgang ist nur noch dieses explizite, ich setze jetzt hier auch eine Versionsmarke.
Und dann gibt es noch das Time Machine Interface, wenn man sagt Revert.
Wenn ich mir jetzt diesen Foo hier anschaue, den du mir gerade geschickt hast, mit diesen ganzen SQLite-Strukturen etc., das lässt mich glauben, dass diese Snapshots und dieser Mobile-Backup-Kram damit nichts zu tun hat. Sondern das ist nochmal was vollkommen Seperates. Also Versions und dieses Resumen, das ist so eine Welt. Und die local Snapshots haben da nichts mit zu tun. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie das damit realisieren, weil ja die Snapshots sich eigentlich auf das ganze Fallsystem beziehen müssten. Bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber das wäre jetzt mal so meine Erwartungshaltung. Aber vielleicht haben sie ja auch so was wie File-Snapshots auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise implementiert irgendwie intern, I don't know.
Naja, also ich muss ja auch sagen, seitdem ich jetzt diese Lion-Version hier schon mal so geklickt habe, freue ich mich eigentlich auch schon die ganze Zeit auf den 47 Seiten In-Dev-Review von Herrn Siracusa.
Oh ja, Herr Siracusa ist mal wieder gefordert. Herr Siracusa an 23, bitte.
Ja, wenn der wieder sein Review loslässt, dann werden wir wahrscheinlich erst überhaupt sowieso die wahren Fakten ans Licht gefördert bekommen.
Ja, weil wir selber wieder zu faul sind.
Ja, so würd ich das nicht sagen, aber es ist halt jetzt auch nicht so ganz trivial, alles nachzuvollziehen, ohne ein Hapendoku oder...
Ja, man müsste sich halt mal den Scheiß mal durchlesen. Lass mal immer zu faul zu.
Welchen Scheiß durchlesen?
Naja, diese ganzen Specks, wie es tatsächlich funktioniert und so weiter, und die APs und Pipapo und den Sourcecode. Ich weiß nicht, was er sich da alles wirklich anschaut, aber er schaut sich auf jeden Fall die relevanten Teile an.
Naja, also Full-Disc-Incruption haben wir. Wir haben Times Local Snapshots. Jetzt haben wir Versions. Und vor allen Dingen Text-Edit, wenn du dann Reverts sagst, eben auch mit diesem Time Machine Interface, was ich eigentlich auch ganz schick finde zum Durchscrollen und so. Macht auf jeden Fall was her. Dann dieses Resume, was auch ganz cool ist. Dann haben sie das Interface auch geliftet, also gefacelt.
Oh ja, da müsst ihr auch noch mal drüber reden.
Und das finde ich ja auch sehr gelungen, muss ich sagen.
Das Aqua ist jetzt kein Hydrogel mehr, sondern wirklich Wasser. Na, vorher war das doch so gelmäßig, alles so rund und bubbly. Und so weißt schon so. So wie so ein Gel halt, was so runde Formen behält. Und jetzt ist es mehr so wie wirklich klares Wasser, was irgendwie nicht mehr so eine große Oberflächungsschwindung hat, sondern mehr so so flach ist halt. So als Gehe konntest du so Zahnpasta mäßig, weißt du? Konntest du so einen Streifen ziehen und dann hast du da so...
Dieses Scrollbars, ja.
Ja, oder diese Buttons und so, alles so 3D halt.
Der gelutschte Drops.
Ja, und jetzt ist es alles so flach. Die Ecken sind, also die sind immer noch nicht eckig, aber die Rundungen sind kleiner geworden.
Der Border, der Border Radius wurde reduziert, glücklicherweise, ja.
Und vor allem sieht's flacher aus einfach. Also dieses Aquascroller und so, die Scrawler sind weg. Dadurch sind jetzt diese iPhone Scrawlers da. Da bin ich noch nicht so, weiß ich noch nicht so genau, bin ich noch nicht so ganz überzeugt, geht aber.
Aber jetzt guckt euch mal im Vergleich noch mal dazu, den Brushed Aluminum Finder oder Brushed Metal Finder an. Das ist unfassbar, dass wir das mal benutzt haben, ja. Und dass wir das sogar einigermaßen als stylisch empfunden haben.
Ich sag nur die 10.1 Optik oder die 10.0 Optik.
Ja, die waren noch schick dagegen.
Aber das war ja wirklich alles extrem dreidig.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber das Interface find ich persönlich sehr gelungen. Auch endlich diese Progress Bars, endlich so ein bisschen slicker. Alles ist irgendwie so slicker geworden. Also so reduzierter, aber trotzdem schick.
Ja, und dass man jetzt auch endlich mal die Fenster an allen Seiten reißen kann.
Ja, krasses Feature auf jeden Fall. Und, nein, ehrlich.
Hattest du Windows schon immer, oder?
Ja, ich glaube. Und du kannst, und jetzt halt ich fest, jetzt kommt noch ein kleiner Feature, du kannst jetzt Pros basen in eigenen Desktop-Backgrounds setzen. Ja, Tim, es ist unglaublich. Und wenn du heute ein Lion kaufst, dann kriegst du auch morgen noch ein zweites dazu. Da muss man nochmal echt, wir müssen echt nochmal in deines Sound-Library arbeiten.
Ja, ja. Im Chat wird schon wieder wild diskutiert, wie schlimm das mit den Scrollbars ist. Was mich als erstes ein bisschen verwirrt hat, ist, dass sie tatsächlich, wenn man so im Trackpad scrollt, dass sie diese Scroll-Richtung umgedreht haben. Das ist halt jetzt so wie beim iPad. Während du vorher halt den Scrollbar bewegt hast, bewegst du jetzt den Content.
Aber das lustige ist, ich hab einem Arbeitskollegen, der saß so schräg gegenüber von mir, und ich hab ihm das so erzählt. Und er meinte, hä, wieso? Weil das macht doch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Und dann hab ich ihm versucht, das zu erklären. Das ist halt so wie auf dem Android. Und er hat's halt überhaupt nicht verstanden. Und ich so, komm mal her. Scroll mal hier auf meinem Phone. Scroll mal jetzt da. Und er hat so einen Klick gemacht und meinte aus und fort, das macht ja auch viel mehr Sinn. Aber wenn du das Leuten erklärst, als ich's gelesen hatte, dachte ich auch so, hä, wieso das denn? Das geht ja gar nicht. Weil ich bin so in diesem Desktop-Scroll-Feeling drin.
Ja, aber man sagt ja, scroll mal hoch. Und wenn du hoch scrollst, dann ist halt derzeit die Bewegung hoch. Und jetzt ist ja hoch scrollen, indem du runter machst. Das ist schon irgendwie komisch.
Ja, das, also es macht theoretisch mehr Sinn auf jeden Fall. Also eigentlich früher, als es so die Ego-Shooter gab, da hab ich auch letztens schon im Club was erzählt, da gab es immer die, die mit einer inverted Mouse gespielt haben. Das heißt, wenn du nach hinten gezogen hast, hat es irgendwie, also wenn du runter mit der Mouse, hat der hochgezogen und so. Also völlig counterintuitive.
Dennis, du hast da eine schöne Rolls-Ball-Taste, die funktioniert auch für Husten.
Und im Prinzip benutzen wir auch aber die ganze Zeit das Touchpad sozusagen als, also total falsch. Steve hat einfach mal recht. Also es ist jetzt richtiger.
Jetzt ist alles anders. Und jetzt ist das wahr. Und letzte Woche hätten wir das einfach noch verteidigt bis ins Mark, so wie es ist.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Ich glaube, wenn man sich ernsthaft die Frage gestellt hätte, warum das so ist, weil ich, ich konnte diese Leute, die mit Inverted Mouse gespielt haben, nie leiden, weil ich das noch nie verstanden hab. Nee, die waren komisch, keine Ahnung. Wie kann man so Ego-Shooter spielen irgendwie? Also du hast den Bildschirm und ein Fadenkreuz und du bewegst die Maus nach unten und es geht nach oben. Das ging mir damals schon nicht in den Kopf. Und jetzt ist mir klar geworden, dass ich die ganze Zeit mein Touchpad Inverted benutze eigentlich, zu dem, was da auf dem Bildschirm passiert.
Steve hat mir gezeigt, dass ich das ganze Leben über falsch lag.
Ich hab über den Tugel auch schon diskutiert, wie es denn jetzt mit der Cursor-Taste ist, weil da ist es nicht umgedreht. Aber es ist auch ganz logisch, wenn dann Cursor, also wirklich hier so ein Blinking-Cursor für Texteingabe ist, weil manche sagen ja auch, wissen ja nicht, Maus-Cursor, aber Maus-Cursor wird es nur auf Windows genannt. Das ist wohl irgendwie egal. Bei uns ist es der Maus-Pointer und der Cursor. Und wenn man den Cursor runterbewegt, dann ist auch, dass der Inhalt dann nach oben gescrollt. Also das passt schon. Also Cursor ist so geblieben.
Naja, also das ist auf jeden Fall auch mal ein Bolt Move. Und ich meine, sie vereinheitlichen jetzt damit schon so ihre ganze Device-Steuerung. Und es ist jetzt auch, also es macht schon Sinn.
Das ist das letzte Lion. Das ist halt das letzte OS, bevor iOS auf dem...
Ja, oder es ein iPad gibt, wo Lion drauf läuft. Das kann ja auch sein.
Oder so. Die Verschmelzung wird immer größer, sagen wir mal so.
Aber was jetzt total halt der Horror sein wird, ist, wenn du dich jetzt noch mal entweder ein altes Mac OS oder an einen PC oder einen Linux oder sonst irgendwo auf einer Messe ransetzen musst und du musst scrollen und du musst denken, das geht ja gar nicht. Ah, kann man das irgendwie umstellen? Ich komm nicht mehr klar.
Du drehst einfach die Maus um und dann stellst du noch ein.
Ich dreh einfach das Laptop um.
Was heißt denn die Maus? Du drehst die Maus um und dann... Du hast doch eher ein Rad.
Das ist auch invertiert.
Das Rad ist auch invertiert.
Also deine Magic-Maus, die ist ja sowieso touch. Und da ist es ja auch invertiert jetzt.
Das ist einfach am einfachsten zu verstehen, weil da scrollt man ja wirklich so wie auf dem Phone.
Hattest du eine Maus mit Scroll-Rad, wo es schon mit Hit-Roll-Erdgeist ist?
Zu Hause zum Zocken nehm ich eine mit Scroll-Rad. Es ist schon nicht so einfach. Vor allem, wenn du jetzt immer mal testest das Line und dann mal wieder Snow Lepert, da kriegst du eine Macke.
Das heißt, kaum das Line raus ist, können wir dann auch alle anderen dafür beschimpfen, dass ihre Systeme das so machen.
Ja, du bist so, instantan separiert sich das Mac-Universum und der Rest der Welt.
Ich finde es gut, dass es immer wieder neue Dinge gibt, mit denen man diese Arroganz auch immer wieder unter Beweis stellt.
Ja, und die Anfeindungen, nicht nur eine Maustaste, und dann jetzt auch noch verkehrt rumscrollen und dann...
Wie kann man mit so was überhaupt arbeiten?
Aber es ist schon so auf jeden Fall auch so nach mehreren Tagen der Lion-Benutzung, wenn ich den aufklappe das erste Mal am Tag und ich will irgendwo scrollen, bleibe ich erst mal hängen. Naja, aber das wird sich schon einpendeln, ja. Naja, aber...
Ich mache jetzt hier die Time Machine und da gibt es doch auch hier so ein Menübar und dann steht jetzt auch da, was die Backup Destination ist und dass die Local Snapshots enabled sind. Und man kann die Backups verifinen. Das gab es vorher auch nicht, glaube ich, ne?
Also da hat sich was getan.
Da hat sich was getan, ne?
Naja, es wurde ja auch Zeit. Und ehrlich gesagt, das, was sie jetzt bisher angekündigt haben an Features, ich glaube nicht, dass das schon alles ist.
Naja, wobei, also so richtig viel werden sie jetzt bestimmt nicht.
Da kommt noch was.
Hat dir das ja so ein Vögelchen gezwitschert?
Was denn?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß nicht was.
Ihr müsst jetzt Tims Grinsen sehen.
Also ich kann nur hoffen, also die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt halt, dass das alles schon so die Vorbereitung ist und dass es sozusagen API oder Framework kompatibel ist, dass eines Tages uns einfach ein ZFS unten drunter kleben und man merkt gar nichts, weil die Oberfläche ist ja für die Apple User entscheidend so. Wie das unten drunter passiert, ist ja eigentlich total schnupp, ob das funktioniert.
Also ich glaube, das mit dem ZFS, das können wir jetzt wirklich backen. Das wird nicht passieren, sondern sie haben sich entschlossen und das macht in gewisser Hinsicht auch Sinn, HFS Schritt zu Schritt zu verbessern. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit sie damit kommen und wie weit dieser Weg gehen kann und wann sie irgendwann anfangen, gegen eine Wand zu laufen. Aber wenn sie jetzt ernsthaft Snapshots drin haben, ich vermute, sie haben keine Checksummen drin.
Und ich vermute, dass auch das Pfeilsystem von Snapshots nichts weiß.
Okay, wissen wir nicht. Ich glaube, ja. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass man das nicht...
Da werden wir uns ja auf den John Syracuse von Ars Technica warten müssen.
Da bin ich wirklich sehr, sehr gespannt auf die Analyse bzw. was so in der nächsten Zeit noch herausgegraben wird. Aber ich kann mir das eigentlich nicht vorstellen. Aber ganz klar ist, dass sie keine Check-Summen haben, weil ich glaube, dann wäre es mit der Kompatibilität zu Snollerbutt etc. nicht weit her. Dann könntest du das da überhaupt nicht lesen. Okay, das können sie auch wieder irgendwo ablegen und so. Ich weiß es nicht. Wie auch immer. Ohne Check-Summen gibt es auf jeden Fall keine D-Duplication und das wäre definitiv noch ein extrem wünschenswertes Feature.
Ja.
Naja, ich meine gerade auf Apple Workstations arbeitest du mit riesen Dateien. Also auch hier so ein Podcast, da gehen einfach jetzt pro Sendung 4, 5, 6 Gigabyte an Files werden hier erzeugt, während wir hier sitzen. Und die wollen dann danach alle gebackupt werden und die wollen auch...
Aber da hilft dir jetzt ja noch kein D-Duplication.
Doch, da hilft mir D-Duplication.
Beim Backup. Wenn du D-Duplication benutzt, dann ist Backup auf die gleiche Platte sowieso kein Backup und nur da würde das D-Duplication greifen. Und wenn du es dann eben wieder nicht duplizierst, weil es ja D-Duplication ist, dann hast du in dem Sinne auch kein Backup. Dann ist ein Block kaputt und dann ist es kaputt.
Ja, also mit D-Duplication kann man sich halt sowas wie, ich mach mal ne Kopie davon und leg's mal noch irgendwo hin, kann man sich einfach leisten. Bei D-Duplication?
Ja, der macht ja eben keinen zweiten Block.
Ich hab eine logische Kopie im Sinne von, ich leg das mal in den Ordner und jetzt fange ich mal hier an, rum zu editieren und wenn ich mich total verrannt habe in meiner Editiererei, was immer mal passieren kann, dann hab ich noch das so da auf der Platte mal eben da liegen. Das hab ich jetzt theoretisch auch mit Snapshots.
Dann brauchst du auch wirklich dieses System mit den Blöcken, dass es mal dahin zeigen kann und aber auch mal dahin. Ich glaub, das kriegen die bei HFS nicht runtergeklebt.
Für Detablication, ja das mein ich ja auch.
Da können sie ja wirklich ein frisches neues File System machen. Also man weiß ja nicht, was sie da machen.
Vielleicht haben sie einfach einen Weg gefunden der inneren Erneuerung. So ein Zen-Modus für File Systeme, die dann von innen heraus anfangen zu glühen. Und zwar blau. Ja, was sie ja auch angekündigt haben, ist dieses AirDrop, auch ein weiteres gefordert von Mobamex Feature, ihr erinnert euch. Wir hatten ja auch schon mal die Diskussion, warum es denn so furchtbar schwierig ist, eine Datei von einem Computer auf den anderen zu bringen. Ich hab das aber ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gesehen. Das steht hier auf der Webseite, dass es das gibt, aber...
Wir hatten keine zwei Lions gleichzeitig am Start.
Ach du meinst erst, wenn zwei Lions im Raum sind, sieht man das?
Ja da ist ja dann dieses Fensterchen, da ist dein, wie so ein Fußballfeld sieht es aus oder so, da ist deins unten in der Mitte und macht so Strahlen. Und wenn dann andere Lions kommen würden, dann würden die da so im Feld irgendwie erscheinen. Mehr haben wir aber leider noch nicht gesehen.
Im Finder gibt es ja einfach diesen Punkt Airdrop, klickst du drauf und dann hast du deinen Rechner und der schickt dann so Radar-Strahlen aus.
Der schickt dann so Beacons raus und guckt, wer so antwortet.
Also bei euch ist das aufgetaucht.
Hört sich dann an wie bei Das Boot. Weiß nicht, ich hab nichts gehört. Irgendwie hat uns das abgelehnt. Warum haben wir das nicht zu Ende getestet?
Weil wir keine zwei Lions hatten.
Wir bringen mal einen Start jetzt hier.
Jetzt Twix nehmen sollen.
Weiter hätt ich ja gesagt, aber gut.
Ja, aber das ist doch eine schöne Sache. Und das bringt mich wieder zu meiner alten Verschwörungstheorie. Na ja, es ist ja auch von einem Feature die Rede in Lions Server, was den einfachen Dateiaustausch mit iPads ermöglicht.
Dass man das auch über einen AirDrop macht.
Irgendwie. Und ich vermute mal, das ist dieselbe Technik. Und an der Stelle war ja auch WebDAV wieder im Gespräch. Und WebDAV, also dieses Fallsystem auf HTTP, ist ja auch für iDisk schon seit Langem die Technologie der Wahl. Also hier zähle ich einfach mal eins und eins zusammen und bin wieder bei meiner alten Verschwörungstheorie, dass Apple hier quasi an so einem HTTP-basierten Local Sharing System arbeitet. Und AirDrop ist im Prinzip die sichtbarste Komponente davon und dieses iPad-Feature, was ich so noch überhaupt nicht in Operationen gesehen habe, was wahrscheinlich auch jetzt mit iOS 4.3 bestenfalls überhaupt erst anfängt zu atmen und vielleicht auch erst später, weiß ich nicht, scheinen mir eben dabei auch so eine Komponente zu sein. Also irgendwie tut sich da was und vielleicht geht es halt wirklich in so ein Homesharing, alle Maschinen sehen sich ausreichend dynamisch und sind jederzeit in der Lage per, ich schieb dir da mal was rüber, alles mögliche auszuwählen, aber eben nicht nur der Finder und Dateien, sondern alle Programme können sich untereinander eben über diese selbe Brücke miteinander verständigen.
Allerdings frage ich mich dann schon, warum sie davon zum Beispiel jetzt heute auch nichts weiter gesagt haben. Also so dieser Punkt, da scrollt ihr auch gerade mal wieder im Twitter vorbei, The iPad is a true post PC device. First thing you have to do when you turn on an iPad, hook it up to a PC. Das ist genau so der Punkt. Also irgendwie so richtig, wir machen jetzt mal alles drahtlos und ihr braucht dieses blöde Kabel nicht mehr. Kommen sie immer noch nicht hinter der Theke voll. Vor allen Dingen, also das finde ich eigentlich auch sowieso bei diesen iPads schon ein bisschen lame, dass du die wirklich kaufst, anmachst und die erst mal anstöpseln musst. Oder? Musst du aktivieren? Oder irgendwie mit iTunes-Account oder irgendwie so?
Ja, du kannst sie dir im Store aktivieren lassen. Aber im Prinzip geht halt immer noch das Alte. Du hast kein Backup. Es gibt kein Time Machine für iOS. Hab ich jetzt auch nichts von gehört, dass es mit 4.3 kommen soll.
Und wenn du Dateien austauschen willst, also wenn du die halt irgendwie von deinem Device runter oder raufsinken willst, musst du mal dein Dovid-Kabel ranstecken.
Okay, aber jetzt, wenn man das mal vergleicht, ich hab keinen Rechner, keinen, gar nichts, kein FreeBSD-Route, zau, so nix. Gehen, laden, kaufen mir einen Laptop. Hab ich auch keinen Backup. Was muss ich machen? Ich brauch keinen zweiten Laptop, sondern ich muss eine Festplatte anschließen, eine externe. Das heißt, man könnte ja theoretisch, ja, das sollen Sie mal bei Apple drüber nachdenken, müssen wir auch gleich patentieren, einfach eine externe Platte an sein iPad anschließen, der da seinen Backup macht, wie auch immer. Ist ja total egal, wie das aussieht. Dass man wenigstens irgendwas hat, dass man halt keinen Laptop mehr braucht. Weil mit einem Laptop hast du ja auch eigentlich erstmal genau nix. Okay, man muss nicht aktivieren, aber...
Morami wäre eigentlich noch sinnvoller.
Oder so.
Dass du einfach deinen Backup in die Cloud schickst und dann ist es da.
Und vor allem, die könnten wirklich deduplication-mäßig, die brauch ich die Programme ja erst gar nicht hochschicken, weil die haben die ja eh sowieso alle da.
Das Basis-Set ist wahrscheinlich in wenigen Sekunden gemacht. Und dann kommen halt deine Fotos.
Dickfilme, Musik und sonstiges. Aber wenn die zum Beispiel aus dem iTunes Store kommen, können sie sich auch gleich sparen. Machen sie gar nicht hochschicken.
Ja, und ich glaube auch so die gängigsten MP3-Rips, die Dateien haben sie dann auch schnell zweimal gesehen.
Aber okay, die müsste man wahrscheinlich trotzdem hochschicken. Obwohl, werden die dann wirklich nur noch über Hashes machen. Ich hätte hier mit folgendem Hasch... Ah nee, dann kam mal schon.
Also Dropbox macht das ja so. Und ich glaube bei Dropbox wird auch nicht unbedingt so viel MP3 immer wieder neu übertragen. Klar, wenn du jetzt anfängst selber zu taggen und so, gar keine Frage. Aber so der gemeine iPad, ich habe keinen Computernutzer. Wo kriegt der seine Musik her? Der holt die sich irgendwie aus iTunes. Ich meine, es ist eh davon auszugehen, dass diese neuen... Also iPad hat ja auch gesagt, dass diese neuen Data Center im Wesentlichen für iTunes und für Mobile Me zum Einsatz kamen. Da gab es eine Meldung. Also es geht in diese Richtung. Und es müsste mit dem Teufel zugehen, wenn sie nicht bald irgendeine Möglichkeit bieten, dass einfach ein iPad vollständig unabhängig von allem anderen genutzt werden kann, ohne dass du irgendeine essenzielle, überlebenswichtige Funktion verlierst. Und dass man es nicht back-upen kann, das geht einfach nicht, weil auch da werden jetzt wichtige Daten drauf sein irgendwann, die eben nicht unbedingt alle in der Cloud landen, weil es jetzt Mobile Me Syncing unterstützt ist, wie Addressbook und so.
Selbst wenn man irgendwie in einen Gigabyte USB Stick ranstecken könnte, würde schon eine Menge an Back-up funktionieren. Also sollten sie sich echt mal einschneiden lassen. Aber vielleicht iOS 5.0? Ja, bei meinem, wenn du die MP3s weglässt, die sind mir nicht so wichtig, aber so.
Fotos.
Was ist mir eigentlich wichtig? Ja, Fotos. Eigentlich sind die Fotos das, was ich erstelle sozusagen. Für Fotos? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele ich da gerade hab.
Na gut, ich meine, SD-Card können sie ja im Prinzip anschließen. Aber sie benutzen das halt nicht für ein Back-up. Das wär eigentlich was. Es gibt ja hier diesen Adapter, den hab ich mir auch mal gekauft. Hier diesen iPad-Kamera-Connector, wie er heißt. Da ist ja im Prinzip ein SD-Card-Slot.
Verstehe.
Und das wäre durchaus denkbar, dass man das eben als Time Machine Target benutzt. Dass du einfach auf so eine 64 GB SD-Karte deinen Kram speichert.
Also wenn sie wirklich sich irgendwie noch, also sie sind ja anscheinend mit 90% Marktführer, wenn sie sich noch mehr durchsetzen wollen und das auch noch eine Weile bleiben wollen, dann wär's schon cool, wenn man sein iPad wirklich unabhängig von einem Laptop irgendwie benutzen kann. Auch wenn du zwei Wochen auf Reisen bist, willst du ja vielleicht auch mal die ganzen Sachen, die du gemacht hast, nochmal irgendwie back-upen. Und das wär schon cool.
Ich wundere mich, dass hier so viele verkaufen, obwohl das irgendwie eigentlich alles gar nicht...
Na, weil eigentlich jeder ein Laptop hat wahrscheinlich. Vielleicht labern wir ja auch total den Blödsinn und das interessiert keinen Schrein.
Ja gut, aber auch heute auf dieser Veranstaltung haben sie wieder im Mobile-Max nachgeplappert und vom Ende der PC-Ära geredet und... Welche Veranstaltung? Na, die iPad-Veranstaltung. Ja, wir werden jetzt irgendwie in der Post-PC-Ära und der Cook hat vor ein paar Tagen auf so einem Financial Call irgendwie auch gemeint, dass sie davon ausgeht, dass sie einfach Tablets bald besser verkaufen als PCs. Und das glaube ich auch.
Könnte noch ein paar Jahre dauern, aber...
Ja, aber nicht mehr sehr lange. Ein, zwei Jahre und die Sache ist durch.
Kann sein.
Also PCs wachsen derzeit nicht mehr.
Also wie die Zukunft aussieht, habt ihr ja alle schon gesehen. Wissen wir, wenn wir nur bei Star Trek gucken, die haben ihren Rechner auf der Brust.
Auf der Brust?
Na, hier diesen Kommuniketter.
Ach so.
Das ist ja ein Rechner bei denen, haben wir nur nie gewusst.
Da kannst du einfach so einen Weltgroßtrip irgendwie auf die Brusthaare drauf takkern und deine iPhone da dranballern. iTunes 10.2 ist draußen.
Dann diese andere Sachen hier, also File Merge und Finder, Partial Screen Recording und Quick Time, auf jeden Fall cool.
Ja, das sind so Detailverbesserungen. Also gerade dieses zwei Ordner Mergen, das war immer total anstrengend.
Ach so, und dann hier mit dem Remote Access, bisher war es ja so mit, wie heißt es, Apple Remote Access, ja doch, so hieß es, konnte man ja immer nur auf den Screen irgendwie sich Access beschaffen, der sowieso gerade vorne war. Also wenn ich hier an meinem Rechner sitze und man macht Remote Access, sieht er genau das, was ich gerade sehe. Inzwischen aber kann da wirklich seinen eigenen Desktop starten, weil es ist ja ein Multi-User-System und kriegt seinen eigenen Desktop hoch.
Wie was inzwischen? Inzwischen... Nein! Nein! Doch! Du kannst von außen an den Rechner gehen und du kriegst eine zweite Login-Session?
Exactly!
Nein!
Doch!
Das heißt, man kann jemand anderes Computer benutzen, ohne dass der das sieht? Exactly. Moment, Moment, Moment. Wir reden jetzt aber nicht von Screensharing, sondern wir reden von Remote Desktop, das Produkt Remote Desktop. Das verhält sich anders als Screensharing.
Naja, würde jetzt auch eigentlich sogar Sinn machen vom Namen her. Screensharing. Shares den Screen und bei Remote Desktop hast du halt den remoteen Desktop.
Hat er aber nicht ganz unrecht.
Nee, hat er total recht.
Das müssen wir echt nochmal ausprobieren.
Du kannst ja morgen im Club mal treffen und dann alle Features einmal anklicken. Mit AirDrop und allen anderen.
Ein gegenseitiges Befruchten. Ja, was ist noch neu? Sie haben so einen...
Nur via AirDrop.
Es gibt jetzt diesen Migrationsassistenten.
Ja, den gibt es ja an sich sowieso schon immer.
Auch für Windows.
Aber auch für Windows, ja. Da wäre ich ja auch immer sehr gespannt, wie gut das funktioniert.
Aber mal ehrlich, wir brauchen sowas. Ah, die Switcher, die, ja gut.
Laut Apple sind das ja immer noch die Hälfte der Leute, die sich einen Mac kaufen in Apple Retail.
Aber langsam müsste dieser Pool doch mal leer sein. Der ist unerschöpflich, ne?
Nee, das sind so viele Lost Souls draußen, die da irgendwie noch eingesammelt werden müssen.
Ich will auch nicht, dass man die alle haben will.
Also mittlerweile glaube ich ja sogar daran, dass Apple in der Lage ist, diesen PC-Markt auch noch zu übernehmen. Also das ist ja das, was man erwähnen kann.
Hätte Tim's Bolt Move wieder.
Hätte zum Ende der Sendung auch noch geladen, die Dinger raus.
Wir reden uns in einen Rausch. Heute ist Max nicht da, der uns runterbremst. Wir rennen jetzt unbeschleunigt gegen die Wand.
Max, wo ist der Rettungsfeindschirm? Du musst uns bremsen, mach einen Call in.
Nein, aber ich meine mal echt. Es ist einfach, Apple hat jetzt wie viele Quartale hintereinander doppelt so viel Wachstum wie der gesamte Markt gehabt? 19 oder 20 Quartale seit 5 Jahren?
Ja, aber der Prozentanzahl ist, also irgendwie ist da noch nicht so richtig was zu sehen bei Apple. Ich meine, auf dieses Volume und das als einzelne Computer, wie viel Platz sind die bei Computer? Volumen verkaufte im dritten Platz hinter HP und Ace Outer Dell?
Ja.
Also die sind da schon ganz schön weit oben. Also es kann nicht eine Firma diesen PC-Markt sättigen. Das geht, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Nee, sollen die nicht sättigen? Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Also, weißt du, die können nicht das, was die Milliarden von Hinterhof-PC-Buden an einen Rechner zusammenschrauben. Das kann Apple einfach nicht bewältigen. Also, und ich meine, die sind jetzt schon fast die größte Firma der Welt.
Na vergleichen wir es jetzt mal so mit dem iPhone oder mit dem Telefonmarkt. Ich meine, im Telefonmarkt ist es so, sie sind diejenigen, die da am meisten Geld verdienen. Ich rede jetzt mal nicht so von Unit-Share, sondern von Money. Money, also oder Revenue-Share, wie man sagt. Also sozusagen, was da wirklich konkret verdient wird. Und Apple verdient natürlich mit jedem verkauften Computer sehr viel mehr als HP oder Dell mit ihren Büchsen verdienen. Und deren Margen sinken enorm. Sie sind ja auch nur noch in diesem billigen Bereich überhaupt noch präsent. Also alles ab 1000 Dollar ist im Prinzip von Apple schon komplett geowned. Also gäbe es nur Computer ab 1000 Dollar, dann wären sie fast die einzigen. Das ist natürlich nicht, aber offensichtlich werden die Geräte ja auch gekauft. Und die guten Absatzzahlen des letzten Quartals beruhen unter anderem auch auf diesen billigen Rs. Das R hat vor zwei Jahren noch 2000 Euro gekostet.
Was kostet das jetzt?
Das Kleine geht bei 999 los. Und das ist schon mal ein echtes Statement. Und das Teil ist echt erfolgreich.
Ich hab schon Leute gehört, die da sehr begeistert sind.
Das ist ein fantastischer Computer. Und das merken, glaube ich, gerade auch eine ganze Menge. Na gut, das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen Kaffeesetz-Leserei. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht zu viel mit aufhalten. Kann man nur gerade so. Aber bleiben wir noch mal allein. Was ist denn noch raus? Front-Row gibt es nicht mehr.
Schade.
Gibt es nicht mehr oder kommt vielleicht ein neues, was jetzt gerade noch nicht aktiviert?
Ich glaube, sie sagen jetzt einfach, es gibt doch Apple TV. Ja, es ist mit Homesharing und tralala.
Also Hucke hat es ja immer benutzt zum Trailer gucken.
Ich benutze es ausschließlich zum Trailer gucken, weil die Apple-Webseite ist mir nicht komfortabel genug zum Browsen.
Aber was heißt ausschließlich? Du bist auch einer der wenigen, die ich kenne, die sich Filme bei Apple ausleihen.
Ja.
Ich würde das auch machen, wenn es mal welche gäbe, die ich auch gucken will und die es dann auch in Englisch gibt.
Also ich habe das ja vor einer Woche mit Hucke hier auch im Club. Irgendwie wollten wir einen Film gucken. Und wir hatten gerade nichts am Start. Und dann fiel mir noch so eine alte Kamelle ein. So alt war die gar nicht. Aber ich dachte, wer gut war, der dann halt nicht so. Haben wir aber ausgeliehen als HD-Version 399. Und es war auch mein erstes Mal. Ich muss sagen, Flutsch lädt sie runter, rockt rein wie Sau. Keine Ahnung, wie schnell sie da reinkam. 4 MB die Sekunde bei unserer VDSL-Leitung. Und dann konnten wir da in Ruhe einen Movie gucken. Das war schon nicht so schlecht. Die Qualität war super. Kann man jetzt nicht beschweren. Unser Beamer ist jetzt auch nicht so der höchstauflösende, sondern so Standard. Aber das war okay. Also besser als DVD. Also immer ganz eindeutig. Und da für 4 Euro musst du nicht raus, musst nicht wieder rein, musst du nicht nochmal raus und nochmal wieder rein beim Abgeben. War schon ganz okay.
An sich ist es schon cool, aber hatte ich ja auch schon mal gesagt, da gibt es einfach echt noch so viel, was sie da verbessern können. Vom Angebot mal abgesehen. Subtitles. Und so. Da können sie schon noch ein bisschen was machen. Aber an sich ist es schon eigentlich sehr komfortabel. Und in Front Row habe ich sonst eigentlich nichts gemacht. Ich habe da nur die Trailer geguckt. Und wenn sie dafür vielleicht nochmal, also mir würde es dann reichen, wenn sie stattdessen einfach nur so einen Trailer-Player oder das in QuickTime oder in iTunes irgendwie einbauen.
Denen kann ehrlich gesagt aber auch wer anders koden wäre. Was auch Neues bei Lion unten drunter als Api, es gibt jetzt wirklich so eine AV-Framework oder Audio-Video. Jedenfalls so ein ganz einfaches Framework, wo man wirklich so mit Objectiv-Steam und nicht mit C++ oder was auch immer, die da sonst am Start hatten, seine Audio- und Movie-Daten hin und her schieben kann und konvertieren und machen und tun. Das Framework ist wohl jetzt auch neu.
Das gab es vorher schon bei iOS.
Ja, das gibt es jetzt auch bei Lion. Hab ich noch nicht reingeguckt, aber...
Jetzt einfacher Filmchen aufmachen.
Genau. Und was es wohl noch gibt, was mich ein bisschen wundert ist, fürs X... Quatsch für Lion soll Xcode 4.1 kommen. Also auch noch mal eine neuere Version. Wahrscheinlich, weil die Version dann diesen Fullscreen-Modus kann. Fullscreen haben wir noch nicht drüber geredet. Jedenfalls soll das neue Xcode dann auch als 4.1 kommen, wobei noch nicht mal das 4.0 draußen ist. Also ich denke mal, das 4.0 kommt demnächst mal für Snowlapperd raus und dann bei Lion schieben sie gleich das 4.1 hinterher. Ja, und bei Xcode freue ich mich schon auf den Fullscreen-Mode, weil da macht es dann echt Sinn mit dem, was man schon gesehen hat bisher von Apple hier von Xcode 4.0, dass jetzt auch so ein riesen Single-Window-App ist, da würde ein Fullscreen-App voll Sinn machen. Oder iTunes würde da Sinn machen, iMovie würde da Sinn machen, Garageband würde da Sinn machen. Also all diese ganzen, die so ein riesengroßes, fettes Fenster haben, das ist alles als Fullscreen-App voll super. Ich meine, das Terminal geht auch als Fullscreen-App, aber erstens nutzen sie da den Screen nicht aus, sondern es ist oben und unten noch so ein kleiner Balken wie im Kino. Also nicht ganz so groß wie im Kino, aber so ein Balken und ich weiß auch nicht, was man mit so einem Fullscreen-Terminal will. Also, wenn da müsste der wirklich in Schwarz sein, sodass man so eine Konsole hat.
Ist nur für Schwarzarbeiter.
Naja, aber diese Fullscreen-Apps müssen wir auch nicht so viel zusagen, oder?
Doch, das finde ich eigentlich eine sehr erfreuliche Sache. Eine Sache, die mich immer total genervt hat, weil die bei Mac OS einfach besser war, der Zoom-Button. Der war halt bei Mac OS so definiert und im Prinzip auch bei Mac OS X immer, aber es hat sich irgendwie keiner dran gehalten, vor allem das Betriebssystem nicht. Dieser Zoom-Button bedeutet, macht das Fenster optimal groß und nicht maximal groß. Optimal groß. Schau dir den Content an, den du gerade hast und machs einfach so, wie es dafür angemessen wäre. Nicht breiter als nötig, nicht länger als nötig, aber eben so groß, dass du eben den Content einfach gut präsentieren kannst. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was man meistens möchte, mit diesem ganzen herumgezuppelt. Es gab einen Fehler und die Sendung wurde mittendrin unterbrochen. Und der Grund dafür ist mir unklar. Ich hab dummerweise so im Hintergrund, wie es so meine Art ist, so, ah, neues iTunes, dann spiel mal ein. Und offensichtlich hat dieser Installationsvorgang, der hing dann so ein bisschen fest und drehte irgendwas über, meinte irgendwas mit registrieren Components. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was eigentlich derzeit bei Mac OS in dieser Phase tatsächlich passiert, aber offensichtlich hat dieses Registrieren von Components dazu geführt, dass hier alles sich irgendwie, alle Componenten unregistriert wurden, ne? Alles hat sich hier irgendwie auf einmal verhakt. Also das war hier ganz böse und offensichtlich gab es dann auch gleich so ein Fallsystem-Fnord. Also das war wie in guten alten Mac OS Zeiten. Und ich musste hier die Maschine zwei, dreimal durchbooten. Also ich hab die mit so einem Safe Mode wieder gebootet und der dann mittlerweile auch automatisch laufende Fallsystem-Check hat die Sache wohl schon wieder hinbekommen. Aber dann als ich meine Programme gestartet habe, kam er dann so bei häufig gestartetem Programm mit der Meinung hoch. Das wäre jetzt aber das erste Mal, dass er diese Applikation sieht. Aber immerhin, Ableton Live hat doch eine sehr solide Recording-Subsystem-Infrastruktur. Da ist jetzt nichts verloren gegangen. Außer dem Geschwatz, was lief, als hier schon gar nichts mehr lief.
Ja, aber der Chat hat ja schnell sozusagen reagiert.
Der Chat hat uns gerettet.
Genau. Jetzt haben wir ja sozusagen schön über Fullscreen-Apps geredet, aber ich glaube, da war dann auch irgendwie alles zugesagt.
Ja, Fullscreen-Apps halt, ne? Ja, also es ist...
Zoom-Button und Tralala und so.
Also es ist, ich muss schon sagen, dass irgendwie diese Interface-Geschichten, also auch dieses Mission Control und Loungepad, die kommen schon sehr schick daher. Ob man die jetzt wirklich so im täglichen Gebrauch verwenden wird, so... Weiß ich noch nicht. Also gerade so dieses Loungepad...
Du nutzt ja auch Spaces, ne?
Nur sehr selten eigentlich. Exposé, ich bin Exposé-User.
Ich bin Spaces Nutzer, aber auch nicht so richtig Hardcore.
Also Mission Control fand ich schon ganz praktisch. Also es ist auf jeden Fall übersichtlicher als Exposé. Also man kann damit jetzt, finde ich, mehr anfangen und gezielter wieder dahin navigieren, wo man eigentlich auch hin will. So dieses Loungepad, was jetzt ja sozusagen diese Screens vom iPhone und so, also vom iOS sind so, mit auch diesen Foldern und dem Textur-Hintergrund und diesem ganzen Ladderadatsch, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob man die wirklich braucht. Also ich meine, wir starten ja unsere Apps eh mit Loungebar, denn es startet ja irgendwie alles mit Spotlight, ne? Also ich sehe einfach den Bedarf überhaupt nicht für dieses Loungepad. Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es halt User, die nicht so sich auf ihren Festplatten auskennen und welche Programme es da überall gibt und die keinen Bock haben, jedes Mal ein Finder-Fenster aufzumachen, nach Applications zu klicken und sowieso, ne?
Ja, das machen wir ja auch nicht.
Ja gut, aber es gibt schon wenig Leute, die auf die Idee kommen, Applikationen über Spotlight zu starten. Also es gibt viele Leute, die dieses Konzept nicht so verinnerlicht haben. Wir als Power-User hingegen, ich glaube wir werden dieses Loungepad nicht so oft sehen.
Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob das mich da nochmal heranführt, weil ich auch diese ganzen anderen Sachen zu meiner eigenen Überraschung kaum benutze.
Welche anderen Sachen?
Na alles, also Spaces, Exposé.
Bei Exposé nutze ich eigentlich auch nie.
Echt dauernd. Aber eigentlich immer nur das hier, also alle Fenster zeigen oder Desktop.
Weil du keine Screens benutzt, oder? Wenn man Screens benutzt, dann braucht man ja eigentlich keine Exposé, weil dann hat man es ja schon sortiert auf den einzelnen Screens. Du hast halt alles auf einem Screen und deswegen brauchst du Exposé.
Ich weiß immer welche Fenster ich habe und ich cycle halt durch. Ich mein ich könnte es manchmal wahrscheinlich bei Safari benutzen, aber ich komm immer... Ich glaube es liegt auch daran, dass die Taste, mit der ich das aktiviere, sich so mit jedem Computer...
Der Huckel macht es hier mit so einer Geste.
Ja, ich mach einfach nur Mausecken. Rechts oben ist alles weg und Desktop einblenden. Nein, Maus weg mach ich nicht. Aber Desktop ist doch... Also rechts oben ist bei mir, zeigt mir den Desktop. Dann greb ich, kann ich irgendwas vom Desktop grabben und zack wieder zurück in irgendeiner...
Das ist ja auch irgendwie eine schicke Geste, aber man kann doch jetzt auch hier so mit vier Tasten und so...
Ja genau, in Lion kann man jetzt auch mit irgendwie Gesten das alles machen, ja.
Nee, das geht jetzt hier auch noch, auch schon mit Ding.
Ja oder, ja stimmt, hier geht das auch, ja.
Das sollte ich mir vielleicht mal angewöhnen. Vielleicht würde ich dann häufiger Exposé benutzen. Ja, ich hatte zu lange kein Gerät, was diese ganzen neuen Gesten unterstützt hat. Und dann hab ich es mir irgendwie nicht so richtig angewöhnt.
Ja, so zum Beispiel der Robert, ja, der nach wie vor mein Arbeitskollege ist.
Der mystische Robert.
Der mystische Robert. Der hat ja auch jetzt irgendwie schon rausgefunden, also auf seinem Snow Leopard mit Xcode, dass zum Beispiel ein Xcode auch so mit drei Fingern oder vier Fingern links, rechts swipen, dass man dann zwischen Header und, wie heißt das Gegenstück zum Header-File denn ist?
Sourcecode-Futter-File.
Dass man zwischen Header und Sourcecode mit Gesten hin und her swipen kann und so weiter. Und beim Safari hast du das auch eigentlich gesehen, Timmer? Zwischen die Back-Forward- und Back-Buttons kannst du auch mit drei Fingern hin und her und dann legen sich so die vorher gebrauchsten Seiten so übereinander, so ähnlich wie im neuen Twitter-Client. Schieben die sich so seitlich rein? Genau, schieben die sich so rein und raus und so. Also diese Gesten werden da schon auch sowieso mehr und mehr Einsatz finden.
Wobei die Gesten gab's auch schon, gibt's auch jetzt schon.
Ja, aber da, also nicht so mit so schönen Effekten. Das macht halt dann mehr Spaß auch irgendwie, ne?
Ja, ich denke, es ist auch relativ wichtig, dass sowas auch unterstützt wird optisch. Dass es nicht einfach irgendwie so eine hohle Nummer ist. Ja, wir haben zum neuen Safari auch noch gar nichts gesagt. Ja, also der wirkt auch sehr flüssig und hat vor allem basiert er eben auf WebKit 2. Und WebKit 2 ist ja schon vor einiger Zeit mal angekündigt worden von WebKit Org. Und das Kernfeature von WebKit 2 ist, dass sie jetzt auch so mit so einem Multiprozesskonzept daherkommen, so ähnlich wie man das von Chrome kennt.
Aber es ist ein bisschen anders als bei Chrome.
Es ist ein bisschen anders.
Weil Chrome, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, startet einfach mehrere Webkits. Und wenn einer abstürzt, dann ist der halt abgestürzt. Und bei WebKit 2 ist aber das Webkit-Framework selbst schon irgendwie, ja, was eigentlich? Multithreaded?
Es arbeitet auch mit mehreren Prozessen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Und so ist es halt so, dass eben die Seite selber, also die Skripte einer Seite, laufen halt in einem Prozess, aber nicht in demselben Prozess wie der Browser selber. Genau. So dass Java-Skripte nicht dem Browser quasi den Kontext wegnehmen und da sich breit machen. Und es ist halt ein Security-Trennungsmodell und es ist auch ein Performance-Trennungsmodell. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, sind auch diese Webkit-Plugins, die es bisher gab, so deprecated. Und tatsächlich geht man quasi auf Plugin-Ebene auf Netzgeb-Plugins, also die guten alten Webplugins, APs wieder zurück, weil die eben sich dann auch als eigener Prozess darstellen. Also auch Flash, etc. Jetzt nicht nur wegen 64 32-Bit, sondern auch generell alle Plugins, die so herkommen, laufen dann eben auch als eigener Prozess. So habe ich das gelesen. Noch nicht wirklich überprüft. Das wäre jetzt mal ganz interessant, mal so ein paar Webseiten aufmachen und gucken, was da eben jetzt wirklich an Prozessen sich aufklappt im Activity-Monitor. Aber das ist schon nachvollziehbar, dass das eben aus Sicherheitsgründen ganz gut ist und auch eben so Crashes wahrscheinlich besser abfangen kann. Und vielleicht eben auch so für die Flüssigkeit eine Auswirkung hat. Auch wenn man das theoretisch natürlich mit SREZ machen kann. Aber so Prozess Encapsulation bringt auch nochmal was. Und so ein bisschen anderen Charakter. Ich kann das jetzt ein bisschen schwer beschreiben. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall, ich meine, haben wir jetzt schon irgendwie alles genannt, was uns wichtig erscheint. Also es gibt auch kein, diese Java-Geschichte hat sich geändert. Jetzt wird kein Java mehr mit ausgeliefert, aber wenn ich es richtig sehe, wenn du Java starten willst, dann bietet dir gleich einer, das runterzuladen. Also es ist nicht wirklich weg.
Bietet dir einen, einer runterzuladen.
Ich lad dir jetzt einen runter.
PowerPC Code Emulator Rosetta ist nicht mehr dabei.
Genau, das ist auch dead.
Und was man aber jetzt auch herunterladen kann, sind Voices für Sprachen außer Englisch. Und das ist ja wirklich auch mal, also Apple Daumen hoch nach all den Jahren. Haben wir ja auch gefordert, wir haben schon über diese Voices gesprochen, und dass man sie teuer erwerben kann. Und jetzt macht es den Anschein, als wenn für jede Sprache auf dem Planeten gleich noch drei unterschiedliche Voices in guter Qualität auf Knopfdruck herunterladbar wären.
Also auf jeden Fall gibt es Deutsch, aber es gibt auch viele andere Sprachen. Deutsch kriegt allein drei Stimmen. Zwei Mädels und ein Kerl. Es gibt auch alles Mögliche. Kanadisches, Französisch, Französisch, Finnisch, Tschechisch, Chinesisch. Ist mal auf da mit der Flasche, die fällt da gleich runter, wenn du da so ein Fu machst mit dem Kabel. Ja, auch ein bisschen auf die Sicherheit achten. Denn jetzt müsste man eigentlich auch in einem separaten Prozess starten.
Aber ich brauch die Flaschen, damit das Kabel hier von vorne kommt.
Du kannst auch neue Mate holen und die Flaschen wegbringen.
Ne, noch eine schaffe ich nicht.
Wir quatschen hier schon wieder seit Stunden.
Und den Mund fusselig und trocken.
Und uns den Mund fusselig und den Hörern, die Ohren wund.
Die Trommelfälle wund. Das mit den Voices. Man konnte es in der Beta auf jeden Fall mit Deutsch noch nicht ausprobieren. Da hat er beim Downloaden auch wieder gesagt, meh, geht jetzt noch nicht. Aber das ist echt mal ein Schritt nach vorne, finde ich.
Das ist großartig, zumal dieses Voice-Over bei den Blinden so gut ankommt. Das bedeutet, dass sich jetzt quasi die blinden Verfügbarkeit von Mac OS auf enorm viele andere Länder erweitert.
Ja, und das ist eine weitere Forderung auf unserem Katalog, die erfüllt wurde.
Das ist krass, wa? Ich glaube, langsam, die hören uns zu. Und nur um uns allen auszuwischen, bauen die das dann auch alles ein, damit uns dann so die Evergreens ausgehen.
Die nervt das nämlich auch langsam, wenn wir immer über die gleiche Sache reden.
Was noch geht, ist, dass hier bei Snow Leopard gab es ja auch schon die Location Services unter OS X, die es vorher nur auf dem iPhone gab. Und jetzt in Lion kann man anscheinend auch das Pro-Programm ein- und ausschalten, ob die das dürfen oder nicht. Und es wird auch angezeigt, ob die das in den letzten 24 Stunden benutzt haben. Also auch wieder ein bisschen mehr Privacy-Sicherheits-Features. Ich hab auch irgendwo was gelesen, aber da hab ich jetzt auch leider keine Quelle. Aber da war irgendwo was aufgelistet von die Sandboxing-Features werden weiter ausgearbeitet unter Lion. Da hab ich aber noch nicht genauere zugesehen. Da müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Ja, es wird gemunkelt, dass Lion wohl auch alles R unterstützt. Also diese komplette Randomization des Speichers. Derzeit, also in Snow Lab BUD gab es auch schon Memory Randomization. Du weißt wovon ich rede? Dass man die Pages per Zufall quer über den Speicher verteilt, sodass wenn es jetzt so ein klassisches Jailbreak-Loch gibt, also so ein known exploit, dass man dann eben nicht mehr davon ausgehen kann, dass Speicher, wo er eben war, auch beim nächsten Mal ist.
Dass eine Lab, wo man irgendwie eine Funktion anspringen will, an einer bestimmten Adresse liegt, sondern dadurch, dass die Lab jedes Mal an einer anderen Stelle liegt, weiß der Hacker nicht, wo die ist.
Genau, wenn du halt den Stack da manipulieren willst für die Rücksprungadressen, dann ändern sich halt diese Adressen immer. Und bisher war es aber nur für Libraries so, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, und mit Lion ist es offensichtlich alles so.
Was noch?
Na, jeglicher Code, alles, der komplette Speicher, auch der Kernel, alles ist rell normal. Und das ist natürlich ein wichtiges Feature. Das ist ja etwas, was Windows 7 auch hat. Das gehört auch zu diesen Eurongenschaften, die Microsoft in diesem, hilflos will ich jetzt gar nicht nennen, sondern in dieser massiven Anstrengung, XP und 2000 etc. diese ganze Generation von Windowsen mal dicht zu kriegen, dann am Ende hatte. Ich meine, das ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass Microsoft einen riesen Fortschritt gemacht hat mit Vista und Windows 7, was eben diese Security Aspekte betrifft. Es ist sicherlich noch nicht komplett bug-free, aber dass es jetzt so ein offenes Joint-Tor ist wie die alten Windows, das ist ja nun auch nicht mehr der Fall. Und gut, Apple wird es natürlich immer vorhergesagt, dass dieses Mayhem auch ausbricht, weil sie ja ach so ignorant sind und was nicht alles. Hier jüngst CCC-Sprecher Felix von Leitner bei Heise.
Ich fand's ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall wieder, das Ende ist nah.
Na, er hat gesagt, dass sie sich halt auch jetzt schon durchaus einfach mal, also dass sie sich mal hinsetzen müssen. Ja, das ist ja das, was er 10 Jahre gesagt hat.
Aber es wird ja auch gerüchtet und es hat er ja auch gesagt, dass die Apple wohl gerade ordentlich viel tun in dem Bereich. Also gerade nicht nur drei Leute haben sich für Security kümmern, sondern mal mehr, so vier.
Also vor allen Dingen, ja. Mehrheit.
Ist ja auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt noch nie was getan haben. Ich meine gerade in jedem der letzten Mac OS X Releases gab es signifikante Fortschritte mit Sandboxen und Peeper Pro. Klar, wenn man jetzt die Hardcore-Security-Fraktion befragt, die ist immer so mit, naja, das ist ja alles ganz unsicher theoretisch, aber praktisch ist ja nicht viel gezeigt worden. Ich meine, das ist zwar, du hast so alle paar Monate, da hast du mal wieder, es gibt einen Trojaner für Mac OS X.
Gerade noch in Erwicklungen und so.
Ja gut, ich meine, Trojaner ist halt Software, die du runterlädst und auf deinem Computer startest. Das ist eine ganz andere Intrusion-Nummer, als jetzt wirklich, du kannst von außen rein und hinein exploiten. Ich sag ja nicht, es gibt keine Exploits. Aber es ist wirklich sehr, von sehr wenig Problemen gibt es irgendwie greifbare Berichte. Ich meine, kennt ihr viel? Es gibt auch Botnetz-Attacken für Mac OS X. Aber ich meine, es ist bisher noch nicht endemisch. Das kann man nicht sagen.
Also, hatte ich ja auch letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass ein X-Surf in der Uni auch befallen wurde von so einem Ding. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist da noch einigermaßen Ruhe.
Ja gut, aber es ist definitiv nötig, da Fortschritte zu machen. Offensichtlich werden die jetzt gemacht. Ich meine, es gab auch auf Heise die Meldung, dass sie diese ganzen Spezial-Experten, wie heißt der Freund hier, Charlie Miller, der immer die Büchsen aufmacht auf diesen ganzen Security-Events und andere und Stefan Esser hier auch aus Deutschland, also auch wirklich anerkannte Experten im Security-Bereich explizit eingeladen haben, da doch auch mal auf Tuchfühlung zu gehen mit Lion. Wenn sie das machen, kann es eigentlich nur bedeuten, dass sie zumindest der Meinung sind, dass sie jetzt einen signifikanten Fortschritt erzielt haben. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es vor allem eben mit diesem ALSR zu tun hat, wenn auch vielleicht nicht nur.
Ja, auch da müssen wir wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr vom Syracusa dann wieder präsentieren bekommen. Ja, der hält sich ja immer sehr zurück mit seinen Fettballs.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du so einen 50 Seiten Artikel schreibst, da brauchst du halt auch eine Weile dafür. Und deswegen gibt es ja jetzt auch noch keine News, weil muss man erst mal eine Weile gucken, machen, tun.
Ja, der wird sich auch sagen lassen, bis das Ding offiziell released ist. Ich frage mich jetzt nur, lange es noch dauert, bis es offiziell released ist. Ob es jetzt noch bis zur WWDC dauert?
Wann ist die denn diesmal noch gar nicht angekündigt? Kann also frühestens in acht Wochen sein. Weil die Dingerlapper müssen ja auch ein bisschen planen, wenn sie darüber fliegen. Es gilt ja wieder den Rekord zu brechen. Letztes Jahr war es, glaube ich, nach acht Tagen ausverkauft oder so. Mal sehen, wie schnell es diesmal ist. Es ist einfach noch schneller weg.
Also diese Google-Konferenz war, glaube ich, nach 24 Stunden ausverkauft. Da müsste Apple jetzt eigentlich auch landen.
Es kostet ja schon ein bisschen. Wie viel kostet die Google-Konferenz?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, die ist immer kostenlos. Und du hast noch ein Android-Telefon dazu, damit überhaupt einer nicht...
Bei Apple kostet es irgendwie 1.500 Dollar.
Nee, bei Google wird es schon auch noch was kosten.
Das ist die Reise wert, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die Reise kostet extra.
Also ich denke mal, weiß ich nicht. Also ich meine, für die erste Beta, die sie raustun, da haben wir früher schon echt schlimmere Releases gesehen, wo echt noch gar nix ging und es war in allen Eggment-Enden noch irgendwie löchrig war und dafür macht es jetzt für eine erste Beta schon einen ziemlich guten Eindruck, aber ich würde mal trotzdem tippen, dass es mindestens noch 1-2 Beta Releases gibt, also wahrscheinlich mindestens 2 oder 3. Das heißt, ja. Also ich würde mal auf Juni tippen. Na jetzt ist März, also sind...
3 Monate bis Anfang Juni.
Ja, und der ganze März noch stimmt. Ja doch Juni, ich glaube Juni.
Anfang Juni. Ja, was das Schöne ist, dank iPhone und iPad und überhaupt alles, was Apple so macht, weiß ich, es dauert jetzt doch gar nicht so lange, bis irgendwie was passiert. Also die Zeit vergeht irgendwie schneller. Vielleicht machen wir auch zu viel Podcast. Also ich meine, es hat jetzt auch anderthalb Jahre mit diesem Snow Lab gedauert und irgendwie kam es mir gar nicht so vor, als ist plötzlich schon wieder Neues da.
Wir werden alt, Dennis.
Naja, nee, weil wir uns in der Zwischenzeit auch auf, hier iOS 4.3 freuen und so, wir haben ja eine ganze Zeit, irgendwie warten wir auch auf andere Sachen. Dann im Sommer gibt es auch wieder ein neues iPhone.
Sind wir jetzt schon hier eigentlich durch mit unseren Themen? Ich werde langsam ein bisschen müde, deswegen muss ich gerade mal schauen, wie es hier aussieht.
Ja, wir können auch so langsam die Akte schließen.
Ja, es gibt noch so ein paar Aspekte. Ah, der Maus-Cursor.
Ja, darauf hab ich gewartet, dass du diese Nuss noch pickst.
Der Maus-Cursor. Der Maus-Pointer.
Der Maus-Pointer, Maus-Cursor.
Unter Windows wurde es immer Maus-Cursor genannt. Ich hab mal nachgeguckt in der Wikipedia. Der Maus-Cursor ist wohl nur unter Windows üblich. Und ich bin auch dagegen. Wenn ich Cursor sage, meine ich den Cursor.
Ja, da wo der Text eingegeben wird.
Und wenn es möglich ist, zwei Sachen anhand des Namens zu unterscheiden, dann sollte man das tun. Cursor und Pointer ist echt irgendwie für eine Maus besser. Weil man pointet auch. Und wohl mit dem Cursor pointet man eigentlich nicht. Da cursed man. Ja, aber jetzt erzähl. Du wolltest was zum Maus-Pointer erzählen.
Nee, ich finde die Bezeichnung Cursor gar nicht so falsch, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich bin mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so...
Ja, aber dann muss man ja beim Cursor immer dazu sagen, welchen man meint. Das ist doch total blöd. Da sag ich doch lieber Cursor und Pointer.
Wie, es gibt nur einen Maus-Cursor.
Ja, siehste, du musst Maus-Cursor sagen. Was ist, wenn einer mal nur Cursor sagt?
Hab ich ja nicht. Ich hab ja Maus-Cursor gesagt.
Ja, aber das ist wieder typisch deutsch, ja? Den mindestlangen Begriff benutzen.
Wenn ich jetzt nur Pointer sagen würde, was würdest du dann denken?
Nix.
Also an den Maus-Pointer. Weil es gibt nur einen.
Bewege mal die Maus dahin.
Ich bin auch sehr nitpicking, ich weiß, aber ich weiß nicht, Cursor passt irgendwie nicht zur Maus.
Cursor ist ein schönes Wort.
Cursor ist das, womit du also damit bewegst du halt den Texteingabe.
Genau, den Cursor halt.
Den Cursor halt, ja. Da, wo du Text-Input hast und den Cursor bewegst, ja. Da müssen wir jetzt mal gucken. Aber das machst du doch nicht mit der Maus.
Der Cursor heißt...
Ja, was heißt Cursor eigentlich?
Naja, ein Cursor ist ein Moving, in der englischen Wikipedia heißt es Moving Placement or Pointer that indicates a position.
Ja, moving, genau. Dein Mauspointer, der moved ja nicht von einer und du moves den.
Nee, das ist ja damit nicht gesagt, was den moves, denn du moves ja auch deinen Text-Cursor. Der moves sich ja auch nicht von alleine.
Na doch, wenn du tippst, dann...
Hier, der Cursor, Englisch Cursor vom lateinischen Cursor Läufer. Da wundert sich die Leute, warum der Pointer so lang ist. Eine Textmarke, die läuft halt, eine Maus, die läuft nicht, die schiebst du hin und her.
Also halten wir einfach mal fest, Cursor ist nicht festgelegt auf Text und man kann das genauso für alles andere, was in irgendeiner Form eine Position anzeigt.
Das halten wir definitiv nicht so fest.
Ich gehe anders ran. Der Mauspfeil. Aber es ist ja gar nicht nur der Pfeil. Es ist alles, was sozusagen...
Mauszeiger.
Es ist der Cursor.
Es kann auch die Uhr sein, die pointet nicht.
Nee, warte, das ist ja egal. Aber Cursor kommt von Läufer. Vom lateinischen Begriff Läufer. Und eine Maus läuft nicht, sondern der Cursor läuft mit.
Eine Maus läuft nicht? Nein.
Guck mal, ein Cursor läuft mit, während du Zeug tippst. Da läuft er nämlich mit deiner Eingabemarke. Die Eingabemarke läuft halt so lang, während du tippst. Deine Maus, die läuft da nicht, die steht. Und die bewegst du vielleicht hin und her. Aber hin und her Bewegung ist kein Laufen.
Aber wie würdest du es in Deutsch sagen?
Haben wir noch Leute auf dem Stream? Das ist doch jetzt wirklich die Diskussion, mit der man sich aus den letzten Hörern entledigt.
Nee, da scheißen sie alle ein. Jetzt wird's wichtig. Wie würdest du es in Deutsch sagen? Mauszeiger? Oder nur Maus?
Jetzt kommst du mir so. Es gibt keine gute Bezeichnung für Cursor, ne?
Texteingabemarke.
Gucken wir mal, was die deutsche Müllhalde sagt. Einfügemarke, Schreibmarke, Eingabemarkierung.
Das willst du doch nicht als Mauszeiger bezeichnen.
Deutsche Wikipedia, ich bitte dich. Der glaub ich gar nix.
Also du willst...
In der deutschen Wikipedia, das sind alles so DOS-Benutzer, die das schreiben. Den glaub ich da gar nix.
Na, jetzt gucken wir mal nach Mauspointer.
Also, Lion erlaubt mir, das Symbol, was auf dem Bildschirm ist, was sich bewegt, wenn ich auf meinem Treckbett herumwische, ja, zu skalieren, ohne, dass es Jackie Lyons gibt. Du stehst so? Meine vergrößerte Maus auf meinem Bildschirm sieht jetzt nach elf Jahren Mac OS X nicht mehr scheiße aus.
Dazu muss man sagen, wie war es, echt? Es skaliert jetzt?
Ja, das Tim ja, wie wir schon, hab ich gesehen im Internet.
Und wie kann ich das machen?
Weil Tim braucht ja, wie wir in einer der vorangegangenen Folgen schon festgestellt haben, eine Brille und hat deswegen schon seit Längerem den Mauszeiger, also den Pointer, also den Cursor. Ja, seitdem der Mauszeiger doppelt so groß ist. Naja, auch der Adler muss manchmal näher rangehen.
Ich find das eigentlich ganz bequem, aber jetzt ist es wirklich...
Ah, Cursor-Size.
Das, aber im Moment, das ist pixelig. Nein. Mach mal groß. Das ist nicht scharf. Das ist keine scharfe Kante.
Das ist gesmoost, die Schweine.
Aber es ist nicht scharf. Es ist nicht richtig vectorgescaled.
Hab ich nicht gesagt.
Ist jetzt large doppelt so groß, ja, ne? Oder ist mehr als doppelt so groß? Nee, hier ist doppelt so groß, ne?
Also, mach mal ganz groß. Und dann ist hier unten, das da, ist hier alles unscharf.
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber...
Es ist much, much, much, much better.
Aber man kann auf jeden Fall...
Ja, es sah wie das aus, was es war. Es war einfach ein kleines Icon ohne nennenswerte Liebe vergrößert. Schön, dass wir so ein wichtiges Thema auch so einen breiten Raum hier geben können.
Ich probier das jetzt mal auch mit ein bisschen einer größeren Maus. Obwohl, warte mal, die ganz kleine probieren.
Also, übrigens gibt's einen Redirect von Mauspointer auf Cursors Computer, ne? In der englischen Wikipedia, Dennis.
Warte noch mal.
Also, wenn du Mauspointer in der englischen Wikipedia suchst, dann wirst du redirected auf Cursors Computer. Oder Cursor Computers. Allerdings...
Oh Gott, und dann... Also, ne, das geht gar nicht. Guck mal hier. Und wenn du dann hier so eine komische Eingabe magst, dann sieht die auch total scheiße aus. Ja, können sie gleich knicken. Also Apple, da müsst ihr noch mal ran. Ich würd's ja gerne machen, aber da... Also, die Maus, wo guckt man die ganze Zeit hin? Da, wo der Mauspointer ist. Und da muss Smooth sein, Jungs.
Vielleicht, wenn wir das jetzt 10 Folgen lang Steve aufrufen, das mal einzubauen, vielleicht erhören sie uns ja dann noch. Rechtzeitig zur Golden Master vom König der Löwen. Ja, ja.
Schön, dass wir das geklärt hätten. Was mir noch aufgefallen ist, sie nennen jetzt das WLAN nicht mehr Airport.
Die Wi-Fi-Extreme jetzt demnächst.
Das heißt jetzt einfach alles Wi... Ne, ich denke, die Produkte werden immer noch so heißen, aber sie haben jetzt eingesehen, dass es auch andere Firmen gibt, die WLAN-Produkte herstellen, außer ihnen selbst.
Wahrscheinlich hat es einfach so viele Support-Anfragen gegeben, so wo stelle ich denn das Wi-Fi ein?
Was ist denn das hier mit dem Flughafen? Ja, das war auch wirklich verwirrend.
Die müssen halt jetzt den ganzen Windows-Nutzern auch ein bisschen entgegenkommen, ne?
Ja, aber das war eigentlich Quatsch. Ganz am Anfang habe ich das ja noch eingesehen, als die so die Einzigen waren, die sowas eingebaut haben und dann fancy Names hatten, aber das dann wirklich durchgehend, so eine ganze Geschichte so mit drin zu haben.
Wofür steht Wi-Fi eigentlich?
Fidelity.
Das ist so wie Hi-Fi.
Ernsthaft?
Der neue Name ist auch scheiße.
Welcher?
Aber WLAN ist halt uns nex.
Na, Wi-Fi.
Also WLAN klingt halt nicht schön. Wi-Fi ist halt so wie Sci-Fi.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, woher das eigentlich kommt.
Heißt jetzt halt Wi-Fi.
Also um das SSL hier einen Start zu kriegen, gibt es ja beim Safari auch nichts, die Schwein. Ich dachte vielleicht ist es ja ne Option so. Aber klar, Sicherheit entweder oder. Da gibt es ja nicht so viel dazwischen.
Es gibt jetzt auch eine Reboot-Win-Freezed-Option. Das gab es vorher auch noch nicht, oder?
Ja, und vor allen Dingen gibt es, wenn du abcrashst oder eine Exception wirst, kannst du Continue klicken und sie noch weiter beim Zerbröseln beobachten.
Ja, damit wenigstens noch zu Ende speichert. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du hier auf ein Array zugreifst, dein Array hat 10 Elemente und du greifst aufs 11 dazu, ist ja eigentlich erstmal eine Exception. Wenn du nicht abhängst, ist ja eigentlich schon vorbei. Und in dem Fall würde dann da stehen, ja hier folgender Fehler, so Out of Bounds, willst du trotzdem weitermachen. Ich lief einfach mal nicht zurück, weil da gibt es auch eben nichts. Und eigentlich sollte Objective-C-Code ja auch damit klarkommen. Wenn du kein Objekt da hast, kriegst du einfach ein Niel und dann ist Ruhe.
Warum haben sie das wohl getan?
Na, weil die alle nicht programmieren können, die Windows-Coder, die gerade rüber schwappen. Ich meine, ich könnte schwören, dass auf dem iPhone, naja, die müssen sich da halt auch erstmal anpassen, aber dass auf dem iPhone halt irgendwie schon mehr als die Hälfte irgendwie erst seit einem Jahr irgendwie Objective-C macht oder so. Also klar wollen jetzt alle da irgendwie schnell mal was zusammen coden.
Schnell mal in Angry Birds launcen.
Schnell mal reich werden, ist halt wie Lotto spielen. Ne, die Chancen beim Lotto sind besser. Aber, ne, wahrscheinlich sind sie noch nicht besser. Aber naja, keine Ahnung, wie die da drauf kommen. Also, ist ja schon ein Feature, dass es nicht gleich einem um die Ohren fliegt.
Es gibt da noch diesen Retina Display Support, der ist jetzt wohl irgendwie auch...
Ja, da fällt mir... Siehst du, den wollte ich auch noch testen. Quartz Debug, kann man den wohl einschalten. Bumm, da ist es. Bumm, Zack, Return, genau. Und, äh, so, Force, Quartz. Also dieses Resolution Independent Interface, oder wie heißt es? Haben sie, glaube ich, mal gecancelt. Also sie haben es schon seit der Beta für 10.4 irgendwie eingebracht. Bis heute ist es nicht irgendwie vernünftig. Ich glaube, sie haben es eingesehen, dass es auch unnötig ist. Weil der erste Ansatz war halt, dass sie unendlich weit irgendwie skalieren können, dass sie irgendwann mal 1000 dB Displays haben, dass es dann immer noch irgendwie skaliert. Brauchen wir gar nicht 1000 dB Displays, weil unser Auge hat eh nur eine gewisse Beschränkung. Wobei, wenn wir dann die ersten künstlichen Augen kriegen, dann ist eh egal. Nee, aber irgendwie bei 300, also so bei dem, was das iPhone kann, vielleicht noch plus ein bisschen, ist irgendwie vorbei. Mehr verträgt das Auge eh nicht. Also da können wir eh nichts mehr unterscheiden, dann ist egal. Das heißt, eigentlich brauchen sie sich nur auf diese Auflösung einschießen. Auf so sagen wir mal 400 DPI. Und damit wäre dann alles gegessen. Und dafür braucht man kein Resolution Independent Interface, sondern man braucht halt eins, was auf 400 DPI läuft.
Wie kommst du jetzt gerade auf 400 DPI?
Weil das iPhone hat jetzt wie viel? 326 oder so. Und da geht vielleicht noch ein bisschen für Leute, die richtig gut gucken können. Außer wenn man ja mal so ein bisschen, weiß ja, eine Drogen nimmt, dann kannst du ja manchmal besser gucken, so, wenn wir jetzt halt noch so ein gewisses extra haben. Deswegen denke ich mal, so 400 DPI könnte das sein. Und vielleicht können sie auch auf alle mal auf irgendeine Zahl einigen. Vielleicht ist es ja auch 360 oder irgendeine binär kompatible Zahl, dass alles irgendwie prima ist. Und dann braucht man keine Auflösung, die skaliert. Dann kann man sich das mit dem Weckterzeug auch irgendwie sparen, sondern man nimmt einfach eine richtig gute und dann passt das. Und das machen sie wohl jetzt mit diesem Verdoppeln, weil das ist ja der Trick, den sie beim iPhone gemacht haben. Und wenn sie den beim Desktop auch machen, sie warten einfach auf den Tag, wo sie verdoppeln können, machen den gleichen Trick wie beim iPhone und danach müssen sie nie wieder irgendwas machen.
Wo sie verdoppeln können. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Programme heute eine Vorstellung davon hätten, wie groß der Bildschirm ist, den sie anzeigen.
Oder das OS.
Also wie meinst du das?
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann es so...
Na ja, 1920...
Gibt es irgendein Programm, was dir auf dem iMac genau sagt, wie groß der Bildschirm ist? Also diese DPI-Zahl, kriegst du die?
Ne, braucht man, also Photoshop, musst du dir das nicht wissen?
Brauchst du gar nicht erst mit anzufangen, weil es ist ja irgendwie bogus. Also ich meine, da sind halt einfach nur Pixel von 0 bis N. Und wie groß die sind, interessiert die Programme ja nicht. Deswegen ist ja jetzt alles dann kleiner. Wenn du halt eine hohe DPI-Zahl hast, wird halt alles kleiner. Dann kannst du es irgendwie nicht größer machen.
Ja, aber auf dem iPhone wurde es ja eben nicht kleiner. Die Auflösung hat sich verdoppelt.
Ja, aber beim iPhone ist klar, wie groß das ist. Da ist eine physikalische Dimension fest damit assoziiert. Und dann kamen mehr Pixel, und jetzt hat es die doppelte Auflösung und gut ist. Aber die physikalische Dimension ist klar, und beim iPad ist die physikalische Dimension auch klar. Man weiß exakt, wie viele Millimeter das sind. Aber bei diesen ganzen Computerbildschirmen ist da einfach gar nichts klar. Auf jedem Bildschirm ist es irgendwie anders. Auf jedem Laptop ist es anders.
Also ich hab jetzt 4920, also Full HD in 17 Zoll, und auf Arbeit hab ich einen Full HD in 26 Zoll, und es ist dann viel größer auf dem Display.
Aber bei dem iPhone kann man sich den Skalierungsfaktor holen, den das neue iPhone 4 hat. Und da ist es halt so, du hast irgendwie, dein Bildschirm ist da 320 Punkte breit, aber in Wirklichkeit sind es halt 640 Pixel. Und dann kannst du diesen Skalierungsfaktor, kannst abfragen über so eine API und der sagt, der ist halt 2 zu 0. Also 2 halt.
Naja, beim iPhone.
Und der könnte auch anders sein.
Beim iPhone wissen sie es ja auch. Aber wenn ich jetzt hier diesen Bildschirm über DisplayPort anschließe, sagt der Bildschirm dem Computer, wie groß er ist?
Wer weiß.
Naja, vielleicht tut er das, aber ich hab noch nie gesehen, dass diese Information irgendwo ankommt. Was weiß ich hier, System Profiler oder so? Der sagt einem noch nichts, oder? Steht da was von Bildschirmgröße? Wär mir mal ganz neu. Graphics, Display, der sagt mir, was da für Romrevision drin ist. Und Resolution, sagt er mir. Und Pixel Depth. Aber mit DPI ist da nichts zu sehen.
Der weiß einfach nicht, wie groß der Bildschirm ist. Also, er versucht sehr, wenn du halt...
Was absurd ist. Ich meine, dieser Bildschirm weiß, wie groß er ist.
Theoretisch schon, ja.
Ja, nicht nur theoretisch. Also praktisch ist das irgendwie schon klar. Da hätte man da das eine oder andere Bit schon in so einem Rom mal hineinschreiben können.
Also mich verwundert das ehrlich gesagt auch. Aber ja, vielleicht ist das auch...
Also deswegen, ich frag mich jetzt einfach, was ist die Strategie? Was wollen sie jetzt machen? Wollen sie jetzt... Klar, sie können jetzt Bildschirme mit doppelt so viel Pixel rausbringen. Aber dann wissen die Programme immer noch nicht, wie groß dieser Bildschirm ist. Es wird ihnen nur so gesagt mit... Ich könnte die doppelte Auflösung haben, wenn du willst. Ja, also du bist ein kluges Programm und du fragst nach. Und du könntest auf den Hinweis, dass es auch doppelt so viele Pixel anzuzeigen gäbe, was anfangen. Ich glaube, das ist das, was sie jetzt implementieren. Das ist ja quasi beim iPhone dieselbe Methodik. Und dann bräuchtest du quasi einen Bildschirm, der aber auch, wenn die Programme das nicht können, immer noch genug Pixel anbietet. Also das muss schon wirklich doppelt so viel sein. DPI ist da jetzt, glaube ich, gar nicht festgelegt. Es ist nur so, dass er doppelt so viele Pixel hat, wie man normalerweise so hätte. Aber das ist schon wirklich verdammt viel. Wenn ich mir das so bevorstehe, so ein 27 Zoll iMac. Ja, gute Frage.
Nicht so berauschend viel wahrscheinlich, aber...
Du musst jetzt doch wissen, wie viel i der hat.
Aber ich meine, die Wunschsituation, die ich ja gerne hätte, wäre, du hast halt einen Bildschirm, du hast irgendeine Auflösung und dein Mac weiß halt, wie groß die Bildschirme sind, wie viele Pixel sie haben und passt einfach das Interface an. Und egal, wie viele und unterschiedlich große Bildschirme ich an meinem Laptop dran hab, egal, wo ich dann ein Finder-Fenster hinziehe, ist es überall gleich groß. So, er eskaliert mir, also eher... Also von der Abbildung genau gleich groß. Und wenn du jetzt ein Fenster auf unterschiedlich physikalisch große Bildschirme mit der gleichen Auflösung ziehst, dann sieht das überall unterschiedlich groß aus natürlich.
Der Witz ist ja, dass Apple vor vielen, vielen Jahren haben sehr versucht, an ihren 72 oder 100 DPI irgendwie stehen zu bleiben. Und dann sind ja nicht mitgegangen mit immer noch größeren Bildschirmen und noch größeren Auflösungen. Und dann haben sie es aber irgendwann aufgegeben, weil natürlich musste Markt wegen der Konkurrenz irgendwie hochgehen und genau jetzt könnte man es eigentlich gebrauchen, dass alle eine fest definierte DPI-Zahl haben. Aber die war halt einfach damals zu gering und klar musste man da hochgehen und die ist auch noch immer zu gering. Ich meine, es gibt von Apple immer noch keine 15 Zoll-Geräte, die 1920 können. Bei IBM kriegst du das schon als 14 Zoll oder so.
Da frage ich mich auch echt, warum. Aber wahrscheinlich, weil sie eben genau nicht ihr Interface so klein haben wollen. Nee, weil sie es halt nicht beliebig skalieren können und dann eben auf einem fünften Zoll mit Full HD irgendwie das Interface trotzdem gleich groß erscheinen lassen können, nur eben ohne weniger sichtbare Pixel sozusagen.
Also mein 27 Zoll iMac hat 108 DPI.
108 nur? Steh, ist ja nix.
Aber du sitzt auch weiter weg, das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Genau, ich sitze ja viel weiter weg. Also ist ja im Vergleich zu meinem iPhone locker der 5-, 6-fache Abstand. Ich könnte auch noch ein bisschen näher sitzen, aber trotzdem, wenn ich das jetzt einfach so einstellen könnte, wie groß ist da meine Systemschrift und Icons und so. Icons kann man im Fein skalieren, aber wenn man grundsätzlich einstellen könnte, wie groß ist zum Beispiel der Menu Bar oben? Ich würde den glaube ich größer machen.
Ich auch.
Ich würde den so ein bisschen hoch zuppeln, mir ist das zu klein. Ich meine, man gewöhnt sich an vieles, aber es ist eigentlich viel zu fitselig für diesen Abstand, den ich habe. Deswegen wäre das schon cool, wenn das irgendwie änderbar ist. Aber ich glaube halt nicht, dass dieser Retina-Vorstoß in der Hinsicht viel bringen wird. Ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sie bei so einem Bildschirm verdoppeln. Weil ich weiß nicht, was mir die 200 DPI da bringen würden.
Außer, dass dein Menü Bar, was du ähnlich aus der Entfernung siehst, noch fein aufgelöster und weniger pixelspielig ist.
Ich kenne hier keinen einzigen Pixel.
Dann habe ich eh einen Schaden. Was eine höhere Auflösung wirklich enorm verbessert, und das sieht man halt auch erst, wenn man es hat, ist einfach so Textdarstellung. Der Eindruck ist dann schon, dass alles viel schärfer und crisper ist. Gerade bei Textrendern, gerade im Web, wo so dieses Anti-Aliasing, was ich auch immer noch nicht so richtig optimal bisweilen finde, das macht dann schon einen enormen Unterschied. Das sieht man auf jeden Fall auf dem iPhone mit dem Retina-Display, wie crisp plötzlich der Text darüber kommt, wie schön und sauber und pixelfrei das ist. Das merkst du auf dem iMac dann garantiert auch, wenn du da plötzlich die doppelte Auflösung hast, dann ist da Textlesen ein Hochgenuss. Und vor allen Dingen siehst du ja auch öfters hier so diese weißen Kanten von diesem Anti-Aliasing, die ja da so an die Schriften mit ransetzt und so. Und das würde dann sicherlich verschwinden. Zumindest für dich wahrnehmbar. Nicht mehr wahrnehmbar. Na ja, aber irgendwie habe ich den Glauben an dieses Resolution Independent Interface jetzt auch abgehakt, so ähnlich wie ZFS. Da müssen wir mal abwarten. Was du sich dann noch einfallen lassen.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich habe grundsätzlich schon mal ein ganz gutes Gefühl bei Lion. Es scheint mehr Speed zu haben. Es hat spürbar mehr Sicherheitsfeatures. Es hat Krypto an den richtigen Stellen. Also mit Full-Disk Encryption und mit Time Machine Encryption ist ein Riesenschritt gemacht. Wenn es mit den Snapshots ordentlich gelöst ist und man da auch vielleicht so ein paar Tools schnell dazu bekommen würde, mit dem man das mehr für sich nutzbar machen könnte. So was wie ich mache hier jede Minute einen Snapshot. Das wäre ein Riesengewinn für die Arbeitssicherheit.
Also ich muss auch sagen, das ganze Interface, die ganzen kleinen UI-Tweaks, die haben jetzt ja hier und da noch eine Animation mehr und so. Und es wirkt immer noch echt schick und modern. Und sie gehen da irgendwie in die richtige Richtung. Und nicht so in diese Windows-Richtung, alles transparent und bunt und bobblig, sondern eher wieder ein bisschen reduzierter, aber wirklich schick. Es klickt sich gut.
Wies denn das eigentlich, dieses Lion Server?
Ja, hab ich, ja.
Ist das, ist da alles dabei? Also ist das alles, was man so von Server kennt? Oder sind es nur so ein paar Sachen, die so serverig sind und es ist irgendwas rausgefallen?
Also sobald du das anklickst im Installer, kriegst du halt schon das ganze Setup, was du sonst bei OS X Server hattest, mit erstmal Active Directory einrichten und Services auswählen. Und du hast dann einen viel elaborierteren Setup-Prozess, weil du einfach Dinge einschreibst. Und wenn du kein Netz beim Installer hast, was du ja sonst irgendwie, ist ja kein Problem, sagst du, ich hab kein Netz, das nervt mich später mit der Registrierung und so. Wenn du da kein Netz hast, dann hängt er dann erstmal ewig und kann irgendwie sein Active Directory noch nicht so richtig hochfahren und so. Und dann kannst du dir halt gleich auch im Installer auswählen, welche Services du alle hättest. Ich hab jetzt nicht wirklich gecheckt, ob's alle sind, die jetzt auch im letzten Server an sich mit drin waren. Aber es war, ich glaube, die Liste war schon relativ lang auf jeden Fall, dass du dir da so zuklicken konntest.
Hat denn aber Apple gesagt offiziell, dass das später eins sein wird oder ist es nur, dass sie jetzt einfach das Lion Server als Beta verteilt haben?
Ich bilde mir ein, sie haben das auch tatsächlich oder es wurde schon so kommuniziert.
Das steht auf der Webseite ganz groß drauf.
Na, weil, mal ehrlich, dann kommen viele Leute und gerade die Leute keine Ahnung haben, so Server, ja, hört sich ja ganz geil an, mach ich mal und sind danach völlig überfordert.
Du musst das ja bei Customize extra anklinken. Obwohl, es kommt halt im Installer sehr harmlos daher. Du sagst halt einfach nur optional installs und hier ein bisschen Server-Admin-Pools.
Und dann beim Starten fragt er dich tausend Sachen schon, wer ist denn der Admin und wer ist die Company?
Ja, aber wer nicht weiß, was das ist, kriegt das nicht an.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, die Consumer kriegen das glaube ich nicht an.
Die Consumer kriegen auch die sinnvollen Sachen nicht an. Also da machen wir jetzt weniger Gedanken, aber was schön ist, ist, dass das wirklich bedeuten wird, dass einfach mehr Eyeballs auf dieses Server gehen. Also viel mehr Leute werden sich jetzt... Und das kann eigentlich nur gut sein. Ich habe nicht so viele Erwartungen an dieses Lion Server, weil es war bisher immer so ein System, was so, naja, es funktioniert ganz gut für so eine Pi mal Daumen Installation, aber versuch es mal für irgendwie was anzupassen und irgendeinen Grenzbereich zu fahren.
Wie gesagt, haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, das Einzige, wofür das taugt ist, man hat eine kleine Firma oder irgendwie zu Hause und will irgendwie Clients, managen zentral, irgendwie Accounts verwalten, also Benutzer-Accounts für die Rechner und vielleicht so ein bisschen Rechteverwaltung machen.
War dieser Profile-Manager, den Sie da bewerben, war das in dem letzten Server auch schon mit dabei?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also in dieser Preview-Seite gibt es einen kurzen Beitrag hier zu Lion Server, was dabei ist und dann haben Sie Server Setup, also Screenshots von Server Setup, Profile Manager und Wiki Server 3. Warum auch immer Sie diese Auswahl drauf haben. Okay, Wiki Server kann ich verstehen, das mag für manche Leute interessant sein. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Profile Manager. Das ist hier so ein etwas unscharfes Screenshot. Profile Manager, Admin, den kenne ich jetzt aus alten Server-Zeiten noch nicht. Aber das könnte auch einfach so die Evolution von diesen ganzen Application-Settings sein.
Genau, du konntest ja schon immer für die User und für die Rechner, die dir so managed festlegen, wer da welche Applikationen und welche Versionen vom Finder sehen darf. Das sieht vielleicht so ein bisschen danach aus. Hm, müssen wir dann noch mal angucken.
Profile Best Setup und Management von Mac OS X Lion.
Ah, sogar das. Also wie gesagt, dieses Active Directory oder Open Directory oder wie es bei denen heißt und diese ganze Nutzerverwaltung und das Management von den Clients, das ist schon echt auch ein bisschen fitzlich bisher immer gewesen, aber man konnte relativ gut damit umgehen und das war so das einzige, wo für dieses OS X Server so richtig getaugt hat. Alles andere, dafür kann man dann auch ein normales Mac OS nehmen.
Der Podcast Producer kommt dann sozusagen auch jetzt gleich mit.
Ja und dann ist ja noch irgendwie spannend, finde ich ja, dieses Apple Mail, dass jetzt irgendwie auch so iPhone-ig, iPad-ig daherkommt mit dieser einen Sidebar Links und so weiter.
Kann man ausschalten.
Ach, kann man auch wieder in den Classic Mode?
Genau, so heißt es auch so. Heißt auch so.
Nein, ich mein jetzt okay.
Naja, ich hab halt schon viel Mail aufkommen mittlerweile und unterschiedliche Accounts und so.
Meinst du, das ist mehr so diese Easy View? Wenn man so einen Account hat, dann ist ja ganz praktisch, wenn man mehrere hat, dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Das könnte schon sein.
Ja, ich hab hohen Bedarf nach Metadata. Also ich sehe gern viel auf einmal. Ich bin glaube ich auch eher für den klassischen View. Ich hab mit dem nicht so Probleme. Aber ich kann verstehen, dass sie das so einbauen. Das ist auch immer mal so für den Casual-Mail-User.
Also ich hab's mir jetzt noch nicht angeguckt, weil Beta will man auch keine Mails irgendwie benutzen. Aber ich würde mir den zumindest mal angucken.
Aber man kann immerhin seine Lieblingsfolder auf seinem IMAP Server jetzt so als Shortcut oben in so ein Bookmark-Leiste reinballern. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie so eine endlose Liste von Foldern hat, wie es bei meinem Mail-Account ist, ich dann immer ewig rumscrolle und mir so die Ordner, die mich interessieren, rauspicke und dann immer viel Mails übersehe, könnte das Leben jetzt etwas einfacher werden. Dann haben sie noch diese Konversationen da drin. Das mag ganz sinnvoll sein. Sie folden auch so gequotetes Zeug weg und so.
Und sie folden wirklich.
Und sie folden wirklich. Was mir aber jetzt noch fehlt, oder was ich nicht gelesen habe, dass es drin ist, was vielleicht so das einzige Feature ist, was wir ja immer gefordert haben, oder ich zumindest, was ich jetzt noch nicht erfüllt sehe, ist halt, dass es mal so Support für Mailing-Listen gibt. Wenn man auf so Gruppen ist und so, dass man dann den richtigen Account dafür auswählt und so weiter, das hat man ja auch alles schon.
Da kann mal einer irgendwie von den Wertenzuhörern mal so eine richtig gute Mark verdienen, indem man mal den Mailklein TM raushaut. Da zahl ich auch 30 Euro für.
Achso, es gibt da übrigens einen neuen, ne?
Diesen Sparrow schon wieder, ne? Noch einer?
Genau. Wie hieß denn der jetzt? Nicht Postbox, sondern so eine richtig schöne Coco-Anwendung.
Echt?
Und chatlos. Komm, einer von euch weiß das. Wie heißt ihr dieses Teil?
Cocoa Mailklein.
Bitte, und zwar also IMAP-only. Das sind ja verdammte Mailmaid. Mailmaid. Hab ich jetzt noch nicht so viel getestet. Sieht aber auf den ersten Blick sehr ähnlich aus zu dem normalen Mail. Und nennt sich selbst Ambitious und hat irgendwie Features. Den kannst du dir mal auf deine Liste setzen.
Ich hab ja immer so Angst bei Mail-Klines. Weißt du, wenn du dir dann so das startest und du lässt sie auf deinen Mail-Account los, und dann wurschteln sie da irgendwas rum mit deinen Ordnern und danach ist auch in deinem alten Mail-Kline nichts mehr so, wie es vorher mal war. So diese Mail-Horrorszenarien.
Ah, der hat Mailing-Listen-Support.
E-Mail for Power-User, da sind wir mal gespannt. Das probieren wir mal aus und berichten das nächste Mal.
Genau.
Und jetzt machen wir Feierabend.
Ja, es ist nämlich schon viel zu spät. Heute gibt es auch nicht so viele Show-Notes, weil wir eigentlich nur über drei Themen geredet haben.
Nur?
Na, iPad.
Noch schnell ein Produkt für ein Affiliate-Link.
Die Hörer werden es bisher als beste Sendung des Jahres interpretieren.
Warum? Weil sie mittendrin abgestürzt sind?
Kein Web-App, kein Nokia, kein Microsoft.
Stimmt.
Da gab es jetzt auch nichts Neues. Nächstes Mal empfehlen wir auch mal wieder ein paar Podcasts.
Und basteln noch ein bisschen auf Web-M rum.
Vielleicht liegt es auch an der guten Pizza, die wir jetzt immer essen, dass wir von der Super-Sendung machen. Nee, gibt es jetzt schon nicht mehr. Die wurden doch von Microsoft gekauft.
Jetzt hast du angefangen.
Ja, das ist doch, weiß doch jeder.
Wie lange läuft die Sendung jetzt?
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich hier noch mit dem Namen?
Lange.
Also ich wurde ja von, du wahrscheinlich auch, hier von jemanden kontaktiert, der dieses eine Bumm Zack Return Logo schon gemacht hat und irgendwie sich wunderte, warum es überhaupt gar kein Feedback gibt und warum wir uns dann noch nicht umbenennen und in den Kommentaren und so. Aber mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass wir eigentlich Bumm Zack Return gar nicht mehr cool finden. Liebe Hörer, jetzt ist es raus.
Ja, es hat sich noch nicht so ganz durchgesetzt. Ja, bei mir auch noch nicht so. Ich finde Bumm Zack Return insofern cool, als dass es einfach ein super Slogan ist. Also ich finde es passt als Slogan hervorragend zu dieser Sendung.
Das wird unser Claim sozusagen. Willkommen bei Bumm Zack Return.
Und deswegen ist auch dieses Intro super. Alles ist super. Aber diese Logos waren alle irgendwie... Es war immer dieselbe Idee. Es waren immer diese drei Worte oder bestenfalls Symbole, die diese Worte bedeuten, die aber auch so ein bisschen generisch an den Hahn herbeigezogen. Nicht wirklich... Also es hat mich nicht so richtig vom Stuhl gehauen. Im besten Fall sah es halt schick aus. So Comic-Styles hatte schon irgendwie Wumm, aber...
Wir können uns noch nicht voll damit identifizieren.
Es ist ein schwieriger Prozess. Es ist ein schwieriger Prozess. Es gibt andere Kandidaten, wir denken da weiter drüber nach.
Aber mir fällt auch noch nichts Bestes ein, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab noch eine Idee, aber das diskutieren wir danach. Vorher wird wieder alle verrückt. Wir sind müde Leute, wir können nicht.
Wir machen jetzt mal Bumm Zack aus.
Bumm Zack Suspend.
Das endet jetzt mal so richtig.
Diesmal wirklich.
Ja genau, aber ihr wisst ja, heute ist nicht alle Tage.
Nicht Ende aller Tage, ich komm wieder, keine Frage.
Heute ist nicht?
Ende aller Tage, kennst du nicht? Ich bin Panther.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage, sagt er.
Sagt es nicht auch Bugs Bunny bei den Looney Tunes?
Sagt er nicht, heute ist nicht Ende aller Tage?
Nein, heute ist nicht alle Tage, ich komm wieder, keine Frage.
Ich dachte, das hätte auch Bugs Bunny gesagt.
Jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich plagiiert.
Nein.
Gedoktort.
Gedoktort, genau. In diesem Sinne.